That's fucking bright, that's what that is.
Hold on, let me put on a live chat.
You can tell that.
YouTube put me live right now, I demand it. I want to see my replays.
Feel the fun.
Good morning, good evening, good afternoon.
Wait, why did I hear myself?
Infinite lip of my own self by accident.
It didn't mean I whipsed it.
Good morning, good afternoon.
Good morning, good evening, good afternoon.
What's that? You thought we were going to play Pig Kitty, a little city?
How about a 12 hour endurance stream?
How about a chicken endurance stream on Viva Pina?
I will update the thumbnail.
I am the milkman, my milk is delicious.
I need to warm up to the endurance.
What better game to do it on than a childhood game?
Oh, I'm a game pros.
No Viva Pina, the profile has been found. Do you want to create one?
I'm using the Xbox servers to do this.
So I think we're going to get a gamer score as well.
So my dream of having 100,000 gamer scores is still alive.
It's just going to take me a whole second.
But it's still alive, I'm still alive.
Keep the thumbnail please, it's perfect the way it is.
Are you joking? It's terrible.
Right, before I get too invested in the game,
can I talk on the main screen for just a hot second, okay?
Azura, Emmie and Strone's Patrons have been updated with an audio.
There are now audios on those if you didn't know.
So if you're a big bro, you're a blatant heart, or you are a strong soul.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Tim Shuttle, thank you for the extended membership.
Already been a month, feels like yesterday that you played Avatar.
Is that when you did it?
Is that when you became a member during the Avatar stream when I was raging?
Because I didn't know you had to cheese on the one weapon.
A lot of Azura shorts dropped.
Yes, there should be Azura shorts as well.
I need to check on Sheeby's shorts.
She has two from Elden Ring, but they both got limited ads
because I think she swore but I sent away.
So YouTube put a load of limited ads on Azura stuff and I was like,
No, fuck this, I'm gonna ask for a review and so much stuff got taken off.
And I think YouTube is just a target, I can't believe it.
But yeah, I remember the Avatar rage stream.
Yeah, I'm sorry if I scared anyone.
I was raging.
That was the first hint of a Scottish rage.
But yes, there are Azura shorts if you want to check them out.
One of them has a really good little, I don't know if the one I want.
There's an asset in it that I got custom made for one of her shorts,
which was a cereal brand of hers.
And if you pause on it and actually read the asset is outrageous.
It's outrageous if you read it.
Oh, I heard good things about this game.
Oh, this is a wonderful game.
I cannot wait to share it with you.
It's a fantastic game.
It's so peaceful and fun and you can do creativity.
Scared is not what I felt when you're right.
No, I'm just supposed to say that part of it.
I have good news.
I have just changed my sleep totally thanks to modern medicine and the ability to drug myself to sleep.
I woke up an hour and a half ago and I recorded the pregnancy ASMR.
I need to record the foley sounds next.
And by foley sounds, I mean I need to record my stomach sounds and my heartbeat and potentially soft breathing.
And then I can put that masterpiece together.
Okay, I did soft spoken.
I don't know if it was the right choice, but I'm going to put an effect on my voice to make it like I'm outside the womb and you're inside the womb.
So I'm very excited to see how that video comes together.
I am going to go and put subtitles on the video as well because I think it would be a shame that such a meme masterpiece doesn't get subtitles.
I can't wait for my new fav ASMR ever.
Smash that like button, subscribe and ring the bell.
Thank you, you guys are doing a much better job than me.
As for any behind the scenes stuff, I don't think there's any updates to anything I can say publicly at the moment.
Icicle has taken our break.
So for any snowberries, I'd say Rippin' Piss, but she would piss on you.
So is that really what you want?
But she's taken a wee break.
Just bing-chilling.
So no leaks today?
No, I don't think so.
I don't think I have any leaks at all that I can think about.
Emmy got clipped by a big clip-in channel and I think over 5,000 people have seen her mountains.
You know what, out of speculation, I'm going to see how many people have seen my little sister's mountains.
60,000 people have seen my little sister's mountains.
How dare they?
60,000...
Oh, okay.
Well, you know what, as long as she's having a good time, that's the main thing.
60,000 people? All me.
I can't believe we just created 60,000 big bros.
I can't believe it.
Just like her valleys.
Hi!
Thanks for joining.
How's joining?
How are you?
Any epic game leaks?
What, from a fucking development company?
I've seen the video game for viewers.
It's delayed until next month, most likely.
There's currently three out of six animations, so we're 50% of the way there.
I think maybe halfway through August, we could ship it.
I don't know, I'd attend.
Brian.
Nice try, but I had to change the TTS, Brian.
Just because I got feedback.
Oh no, my gamer tag!
It got late!
I'm just kidding, it's not a big deal.
It's absolutely not a big deal, I assure you.
No one cares.
No one cares, I can assure you.
Did I need to turn it up?
Oh, do you want to dig my hole in front of your seat?
My background music's on?
I didn't know.
Oh, my cup of tea, I'm going to forget.
I made a little cup of tea.
What beautiful music.
Aww.
Oh dear, oh dear, oh dear.
What's wrong?
Literally the women crying, but we're trying to enjoy the environment.
Colorful like Crash Bandicoot.
So what's the game about?
Let's find out.
Let's see.
Her name's Leifos.
Hi Leifos.
Are you here to help me?
Help me Leifos, help me.
Oh, look, I just realized I completely covered up the journal there.
Okay.
Press X to open up the menu.
I love being, I'm going to say something controversial.
I love being spoken to like I'm a child.
This is the journal.
It stores all the information that you discover while you are playing the game.
The journal is split up into different parts to make it easier to find what you need.
And then again, I did just record ASMR where you are my literal child in my stomach.
So yeah, maybe I do enjoy it.
What are you going to do?
Oh no, not age plate.
No.
Oh, I'm covering it up.
Alright, where'd I go?
I'll go right here.
I'm going to camp on chat.
Okay, I'm going right here.
Good job reading that.
You're doing so good.
Stop.
I'll simply enjoy it.
Baby talk.
Not for me.
Okay, so we're going through the tutorial and what to do, but she's going to...
So we've entered a garden, but it's all messed up, isn't it?
So what are we going to do?
Are we going to help out Leifos?
I think we are, I think we are.
We've got a shovel, but it's all banged up.
So we're going to press X and we're going to open up the shovel.
So now we are going to help...
Oh.
I forget about how much talk in there is if you don't skip it.
That's one busted ass shovel, literally.
Who destroyed the garden? Which one of you did it?
Oh, no, no, no, it wasn't.
Reflans that destroyed the garden.
We are one with nature, whether that sea or land.
One with nature.
We're going to help you.
Press Y now.
So that's our bird's eye view of the garden.
Do you see that white outline?
That's the space that we can manipulate and do what we please with, okay?
On the left, top left is Leifos's house.
That pathway on the left is where any helpers for the garden will enter.
And then on the right is Das Tardos.
You need to clear away the jumps.
Who's the baddie?
Can we have that view on you?
Real true.
How much will happen until you clear some grounds?
Until you clear some grounds?
Okay.
So we've done that.
We're just going to click the analog stick,
and that means we'll move a lot faster.
If you click the left analog stick, you'll start zooming.
So we are to clear some soil.
So there's currently hard soil.
That golden hue, that's hard soil.
We need to whack away.
We need to clean everything with hard soil.
A worm!
I love that!
They're so cute!
I'm going to cream!
I really custard my creams.
They're so cute!
Well done. You attracted a worm.
The worm has turned up because you have uncovered some good soil.
I suck you!
I suck you.
So what we're going to do is get rid of all the hard soil.
Because if we don't,
we can't actually manipulate anything in the garden at all.
So we're going to go around the edge, do the perimeter.
You don't know how to edge, right?
Anyone who listened to the Patreon audio yesterday?
Oh actually!
Wait, no one gave me feedback on Marshmallow!
Sometimes I get feedback from my audios,
or they're like,
oh I really enjoyed this audio,
because you did this one thing in it.
You need to give me feedback if my audios are shy or not.
I need to know if they are shy or not.
Maybe I need to change what I'm doing.
The Yale!
We're now destroying all the junk that's been left behind.
And the currency in this game is chocolate coins.
Because the game's theme is pinatas.
What happens when you whack a pinata?
All the sweeties fall out!
I haven't listened to it, I was planning to after the stream.
Oh boy, you've got 12 hours of edge!
So we need to make...
Wow! You've smashed all the debris in the area already!
Yay!
As a reward, take this grass seed packet.
It never runs out of seeds.
Press A.
Oh, you never run out of seeds.
Can I call you guys a grass packet?
Choose your new grass seed packet.
You can hurt Leifos, but I don't want to,
because that's the evil choice.
Is the game too loud, or did I turn it down again?
I did turn it up quite a bit.
More than I usually do.
Many games are down by 10 decibels.
Maybe even down to 15 over me.
Audio's perfect.
Such a good streamer.
Alright, let's pick up these coins.
And then we're going to put some grass down.
So now that we look at the bird's eye view,
we see we've got most of the hard soil.
But don't worry, we can deal with the weir ones.
It's not a problem.
So we're going to add some grass to the garden
to help the nature bloom.
What did Brian say?
Hello, I am Brian, the voice of the people
and the secret reason everyone comes to stream.
Anonymous.
Hi, Johnny.
It's amazing how much influence you have on me
and how your fans when...
and your fans when I'm having a shite day at work
and hear my notification pop off
and I see you're the girls live.
It sounds pathetic, but okay.
That's not pathetic.
You're allowed to have happiness.
You're allowed to have joy in things
that genuinely make you happy.
I am so sorry that you have been taught
like you should be embarrassed
about the things you enjoy
or you shouldn't be allowed to enjoy it
because of XYZ.
I am sorry that you feel that way.
Please don't ever feel that way with us.
If you genuinely de-stress
or find happiness in the small things,
even if that's a random fucking Scottish girl
that's streaming,
and that's what gives you happiness,
fuck yeah, take any ounce of serotonin
at the end of your day and age
because sure as hell I know you need it.
I'm sorry, but it's so miserable out there
in that cold world.
If your respite is literally listening
to a Scottish person rumble their arse off
while playing childhood games,
fucking eat it.
Fucking take a bite of that juicy sandwich
that's being offered to you
and fucking enjoy it and chew it
and have a good time.
Oh, we have a worm!
Hello, little baby.
Worm, you're getting called a replaying.
You're getting called...
Oh no, you're getting called a wormling!
Oh my god, I'm going to name everything after you guys.
Okay, I'm going to skip that.
No, not the encyclopedia, I want to change his name.
Wait, I can't rename you yet?
Wait, how do I rename you?
Oh, there you go.
Right, worm.
And then we're just going to add ling to everything
at the end.
Boom.
Alright, boom!
20G!
Oh no, I need to get out of the way of the notifications.
Okay, I'll put myself here, okay.
Look, it's a wormling!
Oh, now I'm in the way of the game.
For fuck's sake, I'm going over here.
I'm going over here, I can't do it.
A dangling!
Would you still love us if we were worm?
Yeah, it's a willying!
I'm just adding in to the end of it.
Oh, we got a birdie!
A sparrow-mentling!
Oh, look at him go!
I'll show you my worm-ling.
Yeah.
It makes me happy to see Strony Planet of the Sea.
Not a worm, we're like a snake.
We are now closer to Mome.
Do you want to use sparrows fight with worms?
No, not on their own.
You have to actually tell them to go fight.
Right.
I'm going to put this right here.
Sparrow first sighting.
A ward for having a wormy.
The struggles of every streamer
figuring out where to place themselves.
Oh, I didn't play!
I'm like, where?
Where did I do it so I don't get in the way?
But I think this is the corner.
Okay.
And then this is...
Oh my god!
So this is worm-ling.
And then...
Worm-ling and...
Squirm...
Se...
Que...
Yu...
Er...
M...
Ling...
Sorry, this is how our spell out looks.
Hee hee!
There we go!
We go!
Worm-ling and Squirm-ling!
And they're a couple and they're going to kiss.
We're going to do lots of kisses together.
Thank you Kaidon for the super chat.
I appreciate it.
Oh, also, I have to apologise.
I checked Marshmallow.
Apparently I've stopped a male Vtuber
without realising it.
In the chat!
I couldn't...
I can't see the profile pictures that well
because I've not got my glasses on.
And I thought it was just like a random
anime thing.
And I didn't realise it was a this.
I do apologise.
That one's on me, chief.
I do put my hand up and say,
whoops, didn't have my glasses on.
So I do apologise for that one.
Male Vtuber in chat!
Honestly, stop!
I was like,
oh my god, I had no fucking idea.
Because I was going off on one being
like,
oh, watashi wa strony desu.
Like, oh my god, cringe.
Cringe!
Cringe.
Right, okay, let's add some more grass.
Some more grassy ass.
So the gear dyn.
Gear dyn.
We need a water league to complete the gear dyn.
What if a worm is called finger?
Why would you call it finger?
I like...
I like wormling and squirmling
for the couple of worms in my gear dyn.
Wow.
Anano kawaii ne.
Momolo, thank you for the super chat.
A fingerling.
No!
You're not calling a fingerling.
Shawnee, was Brian permanently disabled
for our donors?
No!
The threshold is $3 at the moment.
The noise won't play or TTS won't play unless
it's $3 or MioR.
MioR.
I finished!
I did it!
It's Willy the Builder!
Wait, is he from...
Wait, is this an accent based on New York?
I finished.
The house has been built.
Get out of your shovel and smash the site open
and reveal my handiwork.
Reveal my handiwork.
Hey, I'm walking near.
Oh, look it!
Look at your new home!
Oh, he loves it!
Now that you've provided the worms
with everything they need,
the hearts above their heads
are ready to roam us.
Mine's the fudge hogs.
Oh, my God.
The fudge hog is so awkward to get
because you have to plant a naughty seed to get it.
I'm slurping my tea before it gets cold.
Oh, squirmling and wormling.
It's time to shag!
Right, off you go.
Off you pop.
Both of you go.
Kiss and stuff.
Look at that.
Let's get an action shot.
Oh, we got the action camera.
Right, come on.
Time to do the romance dance
is what it's called in this game,
to repopulate your garden.
They are...
So, this sucks.
Come and get me, says the worm.
Come and get me, Rufus.
Let's do what?
Now, there is a coin top, like, middle left,
if you can see it, but I never go for it.
It's so loud.
The Riz minigame, real and true.
Wormling and squirreling are going to have six.
It's five babies,
and then we'll get an achievement for them.
We'll get a little accolade,
not an achievement in-game,
but we'll get an accolade.
Or maybe...
Who goes there?
The worms are going to...
Are you ready to watch?
Oh, no, wait, wait.
We're going to get a camera.
Are you ready for this?
We're about to get a cut scene
to watch them do their romance dance.
Romance dance?
Would you...
There's going to be so much romance dancing
at the convention.
Oh!
Oh, should I get it?
Ooh.
Oh.
Bye.
Oh, hold on.
My calibration is off.
It's real good.
Bye.
Re-calibrated.
Oh, yeah.
Come on.
Look at them moves.
Oh, hit it, hit it, hit it, hit it.
Eee.
Storkos!
It's the egg delivery lady.
Hello.
Hi, Storkos.
I like her head.
It carries the egg.
Your pinatas have made an egg.
After pinatas have done the romance dance,
a new baby pinata is brought to the garden.
Safely packed in a patterned egg.
Safely packed in a patterned...
Ooh, look, we got an accolade for humping.
Oh, my God.
I should do that.
At the convention,
I'll get, like, little stamps,
and then it'll be, like,
strongy stood on me,
strongy humped me.
And then, like, stamp your hand
as proof that I did something to you.
I'll get, like, a unique stamp for it.
She has some real quantities.
She got some big personality.
That's what I'm saying.
Yay!
Our egg is delivered already.
The people's champion.
Strongy stepped on me with glee.
50 cents, please.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
I can make people laugh like you.
Yeah, you can do it.
You just gotta put your mind to it.
And please don't think it happens overnight, either.
Ah, we got bird!
Birdling!
And please don't think it happens overnight.
I've been farting around for many years now.
I like farting around.
But I'm very happy where I am now.
And I got a lot of experience along the way.
Please don't think things have to happen overnight, either.
I don't know how that works.
Sparrowling.
That's right, everyone's getting little wings.
Can we smash birdpina?
Don't say such horrible things in my chat!
There's no such thing as a bad pina.
Just a misunderstood one.
He's not a bad boy.
Sparrowling's a good boy.
And we've even got snakeling over here.
Let's go do that.
Okay, so we're gonna...
Everyone's gonna hump.
Hump hump.
Because we need five more humps.
And then we get an accolade.
Wait, don't the sparrowlings eat?
They eat them to romance.
But you have to send them to attack the worms.
So you have to be the one to give the commands.
They won't do it, though.
Oh, sorry!
Baby piñata can cune information.
Oopsies!
Is this the base game or trouble in Paradise?
This is the base Viva piñata.
I personally struggled to get into trouble in Paradise.
My dad bought me trouble in Paradise.
And I didn't understand that...
Like, because I was very young.
I like, didn't understand that although it was like the same IP of Viva piñata,
I remember asking him like,
Dad, why isn't this game the same?
And he was like, oh, that's what they do.
When they release a new game, they have to change it up.
And I was distraught that trouble in Paradise wasn't like an exact copy.
Oh, reeflings! Your choice!
A turnip seed or a carrot seed.
What would you like me to pick?
A purple turnip or an orange carrot?
Carrot, carrot, carrot.
Turnip, turnip, carrot, carrot.
Turnip, turnip, purple, carrot.
Right, carrot, turnip, carrot.
Carrot, carrot, carrot.
Okay, I think carrot won. Holy crap.
Don't worry, we'll get the other ones soon, TM.
You've got two Sparrow Mint residents now.
You've got two birdies!
The next stage is to get them to...
To Bowman's!
Okay, let me breed the freaking worms a bit more then.
Sorry, the color was more important.
You planted your seed, but you'll need to water it to help it grow.
Without water, the plant will turn yellowy brown and die.
If your plant starts turning blue, you're giving it too much water which can also kill it.
Go back to the garden by pressing A, then press X to find your new water plant.
Ah, it's busted up, but I love it because it does the job.
Just because...
I don't even know where I planted it.
Okay, we are going through the tutorial stage, so we are going to have a lot of pop-ups still.
My point, exactly.
I forget how many pop-ups there are unless she's thingy.
But we've got a carrot now, so guess what? We're going to get a bunny.
Knowing how much Trani likes to seed.
Oh, I love doing my thing.
I'm going to overwater on purpose.
Look at all these worms that can breed.
Oh, they're kind of glitching out a little bit.
Is this having a wee time?
Okay, they're just waiting for the egg lady.
There she is!
And then that's right. Get back to breeding!
We now have the egg. Get back in there.
I'm not done with you yet.
Get breeding.
Don't you dare go out of bounds.
Oh, you can't select them right away after the bread.
Right, go hump each other.
That's right.
Get to work on my breeding farm.
Trani, are you a pinata?
Because I'd like to breed more of you!
When I was doing the pregnancy ASMR, I was like,
you're going to come out just like your mommy.
You're going to be a little gamer and you're going to have all my traits
and you're going to have a good time.
I might get my blanket, actually, because it's an endurance stream.
I'm sorry to anyone who thought it was going to be a short stream.
Get plopped, get plopped, get plopped.
I'm doing endurance stream.
Okay, I'm going to very quickly.
You guys look at...
Oh, bunny comb!
Bunny combling.
Just don't make the parent and the child or else you might summon Imi.
Now, hold on a minute.
Siblings.
Isn't it all weird that you can breed children in this game?
No, they're not children.
They're pinata.
Okay, I'm going to let you guys watch over my game
whilst I go get a blanket, okay?
Because I forgot my blanket and I'm cutting the circulation on the leg off.
Hold on.
I might actually get a kind of...
Okay.
Sorry, my blanket, wait!
It's to show the garden.
The reeflings were supposed to be watching over the garden.
Sorry, my blanket was in bed.
Well done. You attracted a moth drop. Oh, it's night time. Okay. This is our first night times
We're about to go through the 24-hour recycle in game if you oh, we haven't unlocked the clock yet
So we can't see it, but we'll get it soon. Nope. Kaidon's iron. Don't it don't give me money for walking away
midstream
A moth drop is like a cough drop. Yes all the name all the names in game are related to a sweetie or
Something along those lines like carrot like a like a sweet treat
And like cough drop. No, no, no, don't go in you need to hump again
Okay, we just caught it in time
Catching a moth drop. I think I need to buy I need to unlock the shop, but I haven't yet
But the the character at the shop is called lorry
But we're gonna get so much gamer score for this
I think this will be our first thousand gamer score. I am gonna really visit Skyrim. Um
And I'll just I think what I'll do is I'll put all of the achievements that we need to get in Skyrim on the site of
The stream so people can see like oh, we're definitely trying to aim for this right you to hump as well. I
Just want to get the oh, no, don't don't go looking
Get humping. That's right. Exactly. Mm-hmm get humping because these birds need hump as well
But thank you Zarian and Kaidon. Oh, we got it 24 hour
What about banjo kazooie nuts and bolts, I don't think I've played that one. Do you want me to play it?
I don't mind playing your childhood games
If they're named after sweet treats, why aren't any of them named after shawnee am I a sweet treat any sweet treaters
Actually, you're the sweet treat. I feel like your tentacles would taste a wee bit sweet
Like sweet like caramel, you know how it's like salted caramel is like sweet and salty
I feel like that's what your tentacle would taste like shawnee talking to two worms. Thank you
Oh
My god, it's so cute. Oh, he's oh he tweaking. Oh
My god, it's so tiny and cute and adorable. I love it so much
I don't want it to get bigger, but it's about to change into an adult worm. Oh
It's okay, right. I'm gonna have to pop that there
I do need to order order and I don't have access to town yet
But we can make a label to show
What recently? Oh, I did not mean to do that. Oh
this is
Why not this can't be right? I'm orange and green
Maybe for the border we do white and black just to make it simple right now
So this label maker means that any pinata that is born in
our
Garden will will be branded like this. Okay, we're doing to hypnosis
So we're gonna maybe I do my seashells like a pink and a lighter. Can I green maybe?
Yes, and then for the symbol
What should the symbol be?
It's just an Xbox controller the Sun my seashells, okay, and then we'll do a purple
a
Purple and what?
Maybe a light blue
Yeah
Now you're getting branded. Okay, there we go. Oh
We got it cheap it
Label designer. Oh, yeah, so now any baby that's born in the garden will have this. Oh
My god, look at sweet wings. You're so cute. Yeah, he wants a light in the garden
But we haven't unlocked anything yet that would do that. Oh, he's again. I'll go now. Oh
My god, how did you find the perfect symbol we guys? I don't know but if my if I'm correct
This one will hatch with the label on its boots
Unless this one. Oh, no, look there you go. You can see a little bit on his leg like our left
You can see the symbol on them
Well, he doesn't have it because he wasn't he was born a little too quick, but he'll have it
Although it's really tiny though. There you can see it. Can you see it? It's like a pixel on the screen. Oh, you're blocking it
That tiny. Oh, you're still blocking
I'd say strong he would be a mix of a sweet and sour flavor
Savory with an unexpected kick that catches you off guard. I want to find out
Thank you for the tip and on
You really are everyone gets branded not caught by the way. No, no, okay. I finished my cup of tea
Mmm
Bunny bun bun is she be
Hello
Has eaten three carrots what the heck I don't have three carrots go here
Okay, it's not she be because she be isn't greedy she be is very humble
There we go. We got an accolade
If anyone needs any proof that you're a gifted gardener, you can show them through your new Whirlm lumb master
Romance reward. Okay next we are going to seize the birds, but not on the ones we've named
There
Cute and papery pinatas. I love the way she talks
Lovely voice. Oh, we're lovely voice actress truly truly. Okay. Now we're gonna make the birds hump
Everyone's hoping
Okay, so this is how we level up
We got rewards for making things shag let's go honestly
Okay, oh
See that little dot now the dots gone top, right?
New characters appear and see us will have new seeds in his pouch, so we haven't met Seedos yet
So we're gonna like all of too far ahead darlin
Okay, now they are ready to
If they get a house, so this is their romance requirements
They need to have a house so they can pump pump inside it. You still need to a shag pad for the birds
Honestly
You need a yes at me. It's a civil war. No. Okay. Now we unlock Seedos
He lives on a lily pad in the swamp
Hi Seedos
Me for real for real you should try talking to him
I walked away and she sacrifices a wormy. No, but not worlum and squirlum
Okay, wormling and squirming are fine wherever the other one is there
You look wormling and squirming are fine, but they had to be sacrificed. It's a dog eat dog world
Look, I'm asked you this. You ever you ever seen a healthy looking vegan exactly
It's a dog eat dog world out here. You gotta try your biz
Spear Spear
Hello Seedos
He's hello look at his design. He's got a mask on he's got pants
But look he has a big ol egg on his chest. I don't know that. Oh
He has a seat sparkling on his head. I never really paid attention to the designs, but they're very cute
Vegans randomly catching strays. I'm sorry, but it's a it's a meat eat meat kind of world jumps in
caveman eat meat world
Actually, you know what I'm gonna say something that a that I did in my research and
that
Did you know that the reason why like
Way back when when humans were still developing the reason why there was a big massive development ring was
because
Because because because caveman figured out how to cook meat and the nutrient density of cooked meat was insane
That it literally caused like the brains to develop bigger. So sorry, but I'll defend me ears to the death
I'm sorry
Spear Seedos. Oh spare him spare him
Okay, okay. I thought you said spear him. I was like a bit dramatic
Brain expansion true and real I did hear that we cook me
yes, I
Just sorry, I had a family member that was vegan for a couple of years and she became so
Physically ill and then the moment she started eating
Like meat and eggs again. She literally looked so much better overnight like sorry
I've just and not to be nasty to anyone. Love your life how you want, but please understand
You're literally playing with your health doing that kind of stuff. Um
Like it's just please please be careful with your health, please
You only live once don't like don't malnutrition yourself
Punish me in his place spare you mean spade you mean hit him with the spade so seeds come out of his pocket
Is that what you're trying to type? I think that's what you're trying to say because if you hit him with a spade seats come
Out his bag, but he scatters and red
aim
Red seeds and I don't want red season. Oh look at it. Look at my worm army. Honestly
No spare
What do you mean spare him? I don't hurt him
Don't hurt him. No, I'm not. I'm not gonna hurt him. Okay
Don't panic. Don't panic. We play nice. We pick all the good dialogues and the nice dialogues and games. Don't worry. Don't worry
Yeah, I don't hurt. Oh, yes
Assistant lawmines start to eat less meat because she wants to be healthier than have to get iron inject
Yeah, especially for women to become vegans and because of
You know the monthly red river and
The population is like 50% borderline anemic or something like that. Oh
We got a tough line
I
Love this
I'm gonna start singing people. Yeah, I'm gonna go to bed tonight, and I'm gonna see all these adorable little
Pena's floating around in my head. Please come into
We have a daisy. Look. He's admiring the daisy. You're he's just like me for real for real. Oh
My god, we have a bark up. I love flowers
Look at that book. Look at the detail on that thing. Let's get a little aerial view going
But the taffy we can set on fire yes, but for good reason we set him on fire, but not in a mean way
It's because some pinatas can undergo a transformation
Transformation central
Okay, now if I can touch the two birds we will
Land, okay, we've got one landed hold
Okay, okay, hold don't go inside. Don't go inside or stand on anything
Okay, now both of you kiss right now in front of me. Oh wait, the shop is open. Hi Lottie
She's called Lottie because she cost a lot
Shoot work
I'm surprised anyone got that reference. Well time to feed the butterfly 100 different florists. Yes, you remember
Village general story
Now you can spend them at the store. Hmm. I'm excited to show you my
Schedule for next week
Wow
Oh, I have a collab with Arissa coming up as well. I need to pick a good Joe. Joe game for us to play
You can buy
Hello little what do you need fruit to come in my garden?
Have eaten a flower. Okay, that's what you're allowed to do that
Arissa no Arissa my shortest editor is called Arissa with an a arissa. Oh
Arissa is
Right, what seats do we have a lot?
Turn it. We've not done
Can you teach us about the pinata birds and bees real true?
Okay, we're gonna purr pause fully
I'm
Who fair Eliza? No, we're not because there's only orange. I take it back. Oh, baby. I take it back. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
Yeah, I take it back. Oh, baby. Oh, baby. Give me one more chance
Arissa overwatch collab. No, we're not going to Numbani. Okay
Okay, we just need to squirt the pants
Squirt the plants three times and then we get an achievement once they're fully grown. Sorry my brain short-circuited there
Okay, next we're gonna do the buttercup seeds because I think if I have six flowers we can unlock a honeycomb
So we're just gonna start a little plant thing over here
Okay, they're all getting planted and then we're gonna do Daisy's
And just like that we have big garden of plants
Baby go back
Baby come back
Once I've done my
Last like ASMR recording I need to do I need to record the last script for patreon. I need to edit the script
I've left it
Okay, well not a buzzle
Yes, God you guys are such big you guys are the smartest when it comes to this game
I'm literally I feel so loved that we get to play a childhood games together like
I can't I can't articulate my words. I can't handle it. It's too much. I'm not gonna make it
It's too much
What's so good
Okay, the birds are humping now shiny freaky it's just I'm like so happy like
Bruh, I can't like I always come back to this conversation of like all vtubers are like trying to try hard and like play a meta game
I'm like fuck that shit. We're getting gamer score in a childhood game, and you guys actually like it. I
Know it's 4 a.m. But I'm so happy
I'm
Right we're getting awards for growing stuff now
So we've unlocked because we leveled up actually, you know what's something important we need to buy this
Because it means we can get a
Cough drop moth drop as well as when we level up we unlock new seats and new fertilizer
Okay, well we didn't unlock a new seat that time, but we did unlock a new fertilizer and the color is
Purple so we're going to plant a turnip seed and then we're gonna spray the purple fertilizer on it
and then we get an accolade for
Using the fertilizer against the plant as long as you do it three times against any plant you get extra points and accolades for it
Okay, and that's another way you can level up faster because the more you level up
Like you can actually see it get bigger as well when you use the fertilizer
But you can only do it three times, but you normally have a visual indication
So you see how this turnip has three leaves now and
My name is Jardinero you've probably heard of me and if you haven't okay, this is Lord
Even after all this time, there's no one as good as I okay, so this is lower, okay
Used to be my he's like telling us that it was his old garden and have any pinata stay in the garden
Well apart from one pinata
Let's face it if I couldn't get one no one else could what pinata was it you've got a long way to go before you can even call
this a garden
Not long after I started the garden. I met my wonderful old man in Yathon. He worked on the ship which traded pinata for other goods
This was in the days when pinata only left the island by boat
Pinata central hadn't been built. He's recalling the fricking how long ago is this?
Thank you enormous for the tip of I didn't say it by the way my wife stayed on the island for a whole year and
Our first child was mother my wife stayed on the island of a year. Oh, this is Leifos's dad
Yes mama yep in my ear for hours on end about at your favorite childhood games
Thank you. Thank you. Okay done for the super chat with with glee. I will with glee all the Dragoner, okay?
Well, we're gonna easy peasy lemon squeezy get it because it's in a main shaft
Your I'm in a main shaft looking for diamonds. I'm in a main looking for Mainers
Are you guys seen that meme? It's absolutely average. Oh gosh. I think we're gonna actually have to sell what we've grown
I'm not even kidding. Okay. Let's sell some stuff
Have you seen that meme is so funny
Don't clip that oh
It's literally what's funny thing. Oh wait. No, I need to I
Need three carrots for a rabbit. What one down on the cell?
Okay, that's fine. I want to sell the we won so take that off add that
Sell the turnip. That's fine. Who blocked the seeds. Did you block it be honest? I?
Want this turnip to pop so I can sit. Oh, he's popping. He's coming. He's crowning
How much do we get for the big turn? I mean, I'll take it. Okay?
you oh
I
Just learned to get a long weekend start in there. Oh, yeah
Listen, you're playing maincraft in the cave looking for diamonds. That's funny. I'm in the cave. Look
It's such a funny play on words for years, okay, mr. Turnip, please plan oh
Oh, my please I wish they could stay that small and adorable
My heart can't take it right you you wait for oh, I have a job for you
Come to this one carrot here for no particular reason at all who just put themselves on fire stop it
For you no particular reason at all mr. Taff like can you interact with this carrot?
Turn it into fertilizer. I dare you a double-dog dare you
No, he can't he can only do it on fruit. Okay, well guess what you're doing next
You're becoming a red hot
So you unfortunately you have to tell it to burn itself, which is really
No fly through it
Okay, uh-huh, uh-huh. Oh, yeah, uh-huh. Yeah, huh. No, let's go
I
Know we have a super money money money
Yeah
Me me it's me
I'm a clever gardener. It's me. I'm a clever. I'm the cleverest gardener. Oh, oh
No, no see this is an example
Not everyone is bad. They're just misunderstood. Okay, so this is a sour shelly bean. Okay, and he eats seeds in the garden
Don't be so judgmental leaf off
We can fix them a spin yeah, real oh
We look her shovels getting upgraded now as well. See our trouble gets stronger
What Ryan I'm glad you and the rest of the lure exist
I wish I could find people like you in my life
But are they content watching you from behind my computer screen a bit of sweet feeling
It's hard to find
People like us in real life because people like us are on the internet. You know what I mean?
I don't go outside. I have stinky be all from two days well from yesterday's stream
I have stinky be all I smell like wet onions right now
Thank you for the tip anonymous. I appreciate it. But if you want the truth people like us don't go outside
It's true. I don't go outside. That's why you can't me as because we ain't no say
you know
That's why when it's that's why it's a big deal if a v2 bar
I can't choose a favorite seed. They are all special to me
My favorite seeds is reefing seeds. Thank you
It was so obvious. I'm sorry. That was so oh he gave me corn
It's corn a big lump of juice. Wait. No, that's not it has the juice
Sir that's schizophrenia
Sir, are you diagnosed? Do you need a little help? But I'm glad you enjoy the be all our girls. I'm sorry
that um
That it's hard to find people that are just be chinning
It's hard like in real life socialization is not like ah legit then you go outside
Oh, no, no, no, don't wait
Okay, we're gonna overwater these plants on purpose. Okay. This is a tactic
So you don't actually have to water it at any stage. Does that make sense?
Oh
Okay, okay. Okay. We have a sir. Shelly bean everyone stay calm stay calm
We need to get the seed for him and then and then he'll be a good boy. Okay. See oh, there is
Okay, so if you have a sir or shelly bean don't panic place
A seed in front of him. Okay. I've given him a jelly bean seeds. Sorry. I've given him an apple tree seed
Okay, turn around the seed is behind you
stop it
You're upsetting me
Come back mister
the mister
Sam what do you want?
Yes, I would like to buy three
Fertilizer for the corn please turn. Yes. Look look his ai turned him around to the seed. Oh, he's got such a good boy
He's gonna be the goodest boy ever
Okay, we're gonna buy a buttercup and then we're gonna level it up fully by putting three fertilizer
Our daisy yellow as well. I think they might be
Okay, we're gonna do that and then we're gonna oh, he just ate it. See he's becoming a good boy
That's the thing you can do bad things in the past, but
Sometimes, you know, you're a product of your environment and sometimes you didn't know better
But now you know better and you can always change don't be so harsh on yourself. I think you can't change
What are you teaching morality through a video game about pinatas? Yes, and I wholeheartedly believe it
Okay, you're never gonna go through life not making mistakes. Don't be so harsh on yourself
Okay
Okay, right some spectrums. How can we send seeds so you plant them? I cannot plant what you would send me in a vial
I assure you
I cannot I cannot make anything grow from it. Although I did see that meme post where someone grew a mushroom on his
Rag, if you will
Thank you for the membership tier. Sorry. I assume that's how I'm supposed to announce you
I'm getting me mallet. So no ink tree for it. I mean
You could make something grow from it
I thought
Samples die within like five hours or something if it's outside the womb
It can last for five days inside the womb but outside the womb and go make it
And go make a chief
Strud I didn't know you were in this game
Oh great some spectrums kind of looks like me and we got a green fingers achievement
A raisant. Okay, we've leveled up again
Ah
Most feature we're confirmed for gen 2 because this is so adorable. Look at me tail
That'll be her a little voice lane as well. She goes
Oh my god, I'm getting tail upgrade. I can't handle this. I can't handle this, please
They're so cute. Oh, right. What's your tail upgrade? Are we a good gardener now?
Oh
We're experienced
Flames, I do like
Oh
Oh, you get a little achievement. You've earned three achievements. They literally give you like a little achievement thing
I just have a lot of great juice. We leveled up
Don't mind if I do
Most train conductor
Stop that's actually such a good idea. I like that. I'm going to thank you
This garden is still very amateur
Oh, sorry
I was stretching again. Oh, so we stood her
We
We're speedrunning gen 3 confirmed stop real true. Okay, this is the summer pinata changing
We tend okay, this is what I mean about the notifications at the start of the game
It is
Unending
Can't play the game
It's just cutscene after cutscene
Oh
Better shovel for the spanking. She likes running trains
I might submit that
I really like that mouse train conductor and her catchphrase
Choo choo
Oh, it'd have to be a lollipop though
Can you have a milf train conductor mouse because then it would be like choo choo
Oh, I like the way it touches its wee belly in that cutscene. He's like, yep
It gives me old grandpa vibe. Okay. Okay. Let's stop with the notifications. Let's play the game
Oh
I may have girl bossed this game a little too hard
How long is this interruption? Please are you gonna hundred percent this game on stream? Um
There's one achievement that
Might not be able to be on stream
Which is played for 24 in-game hours
I think and I would have to do it offline because you have to go into the shop in order to
aim
Okay, right no more
Thank you
Okay, thank you. Thank you. I just
I just
need some
Sometime
Oh, no, I only have 34 coins
I can't afford any of this
I haven't
30 for one pump 18 for one pump. All right. I'm gonna have to start. I'm gonna plant fruit so we can sell it
uh
I guess corn makes us like 30. I'm just gonna grow corn and then sell it
With my my I have no money. I have five four corns to sell. That's the best I can do
Oh
We have a bunny
No, I'm not gonna name this bunny she be because I already know what his fate is gonna be
Uh, there's gonna be a pretz tail that shows up and perishes it. Okay, so just uh, let me let me kick
Okay, let me just zoom out by
Oh my god, we have a butterfly in the garden too. Oh everything's coming up has eaten three chilies
I'm not even unlocked a chili. Uh, yeah, bam, right. I'm gonna make another one of these
Uh, I'm gonna make another taff like uh, no, sorry
Please
Please let me play the game. Please cut scenes. Please
Stop this madness
Do the next one. Yeah, I'm gonna unlock the pretz tail and then I'm gonna leave it
Okay, we have no flow. Go. I played this game so much on the egg flick. Yeah
Oh, right. So as a Scottish family when my dad saw this character
He started laughing and I was like, why why are you laughing dad? I don't get it
So this is just multiplayer if you want to send stuff to people you can
Yeah, literally as a Scottish family. I was like dad dad. Why are you laughing? I don't get it. What's so funny?
What's so funny and he's like
Like he doesn't want to tell me because I was too young at the time
But uh, yeah, okay, so we're gonna sell some corn
Uh, we also got a bunny rabbit so we can sell that
Um, our little shelly bean we could maybe sell because I don't really do anything with them
I don't know
I like the crow. We unlock, um a crow later on
So I think I'll do that. You have a mouse malo. Oh, what does the mouse malo need to level up?
Oh, we can maybe quickly put fertilizer on this plant if we didn't run out of time
We might have just run out of time though
Turnips I believe more like no
You know this could start to get annoying
We just ran out of time and no more. Oh, we can do water already. Right. We're gonna plant an apple tree
Something just popped. I think it was the corn
Oh, it sounds like popcorn. I get it now
Do you need your garden? Oh, please. I know my garden's improving. I'm just mlg. Okay. I'm just mlg. You don't have to tell me
I'm just so good. Okay, right. We're gonna sell the corn
For some money. Okay. That was a good investment. I think we paid like 20 and made 100 on that. Sounds good
I just got the funny joke. I'm stupid. Yeah, well apparently it means but for americans
but
For the british people. It means uh, hooha
right, we
are
Your friends you will never be alone again. So come on
Come on
Right, so we're gonna purposefully overwater the f out of this tree. So I don't have to do it
Uh, I'm gonna sell them. No, I'm not because we're gonna get a serpent
Leaf us, please. I know I'm mlg at this game
Better
So did you do it? If you feed a sparrowman a certain flower, it'll change the color. Yes. I'm going to get
Full sparrowman. Oh my god. He's humping the plant. I love him. Look at his wee arms. Oh my god. I love him
That's uh, oh no, don't push him away. He was chilling on that farm
He was bing-chinging
Oh, we have a honeybee sweet little honeybee. I know what you want from me. It's six but
It's six bar sco- uh bar cups in the garden six bar cups in the garden sweet little bumblebee
I know it's a fantasy
It's already been an hour
I just clocked it it's 5 a.m. I'm like it's already been an hour
Oh
Right you
You
Into the fire and we're gonna get an award for master romancer. You do not actually have to romance them
It has in fact been 60 minutes already. How do you this endurance stream isn't even gonna be endurance?
I'm going I'm saying it right now. It's not endurance because I'm having far too much fun
um
Literally, we will do karaoke soon my sweets. I promise right
Let's get
Right. Well if you right well if you yeah, there you go
Right you next go
We're doing a production line of uh flutter scotches. Oh, no, what does he need?
I think he needs medicine from honey
Oh
No, I can't remember. I think he needs medicine because he makes them sick
Yeah cough medicine. Yeah, I knew I remembered. Okay. Now we're gonna make everything a flutter scotch
Uh, no not flutter scotch. Sorry the other one a red hot right. Okay. If he's gonna come in the garden. We've not unlocked bar
Oh sugar
Right. See dos. Give me some seeds see this see those see those
Be alleged. Come on. Be a legend. See dos. Give us some seeds mate. Give us some seeds
I had a dream where all the shovels broke and I slept on a bed made of lots of
All the shovels broke you sleep on shovels. Are you all right mate?
Do you need me to call someone?
No, no, no, don't go home. Give me more seeds
You have to be a very special person to look after seeds. Oh, yeah, I look after a lot of seeds
Are you squidding me right now? Anonymous. Hey strone. Hello. Hope you're doing well today. I'm poor good
I'd give you read the marshmallow I sent last night
But part of your eye and smile are all laps left burned on my tv screen
Have a great stream mom. Oh, you want me to read it?
Give me one moment. Thank you for the tiffanon. Give me one second
I'm gonna I'm gonna prank the fuck out of this watercress seed by giving it all the nutrition
We have not unlocked the green fertilizer. I have been pranked. Okay. We can at least fertilize the apple tree
Okay, you ready?
Okay, unfortunately that pretzel is coming. Oh, it's raining. Wait when it rains in the game. Um, it's
That's actually me trying to formulate a sentence out loud
Hi, you know, there are some people like myself who can help you with your more mundane tasks
Man, thank you. You should let a sprinkling like me come water your plants for you
I'm sure there's an initial fee, but I'm worth it
You can find me an arpher's in here if you want to take me up on the offer
No doubt some of my friends will be turning up too. Some of my friends will be turning up
I love shebe's valley accent so much someone says I need to see strone in a dress a dress
I don't wear dresses. Do you mean like show a picture of me in a dress? I could order a dress for you
If it would make you happy to see me, then I'll do it for you
I wish I had a canine tentacle so I could not you well, I don't think that was the the the one I was supposed to read
um
Gonna be honest. I don't think that was the one I was supposed to read out loud. Um,
Sonny and sonny strone in a sundress would be p
um
Hey strone, I recently started watching you and all the veal or girls. Thank you for supporting my gen mates
Please do check them out if you haven't had a chance yet, and I wanted to say you're all amazing
I'm mostly a lurker and listen to streams while I'm at work
I actually probably never would have used marshmallows, but something funny happened and I thought you might get a chuckle out of it
So I use the fairly old tv as my computer monitor because um, oh rain cloud. Thank you for the redirect
Uh, hello rain cloud. We're playing viva pinata, but I'm currently right reading a marshmallow very quickly. Um
So I use a fairly old tv as my computer monitor because youtube is my cable at this point real true
Did you know that in the younger generation hardly anyone has cable because no one gives a fuck about the tv has to say
Um
And imagine paying for it. Um, have a fun stream. Yes, please relax after your stream. Thank you so much. Hi raiders
Hi, I'm shawnee calls from gen ones feel or indulge and I'm playing viva pinata childhood game
And I'm really chaotic
So I'd really recommend checking out my gen mates instead if you if you want to continue the entertainment
I that kind of entertainer
She'd be caught in bum if you like girl failures and people who yap
As early I feel like the mummy vibes
Uh, uh, emmy if you want a little sister, uh, I see if you want a little daughter
And mercy if you like yandere's okay there. Okay. Got that out of the way. Thank you. Thank you very kind of
I kiss side kiss side chicky kisses
Hi, thank you
Well, I fell asleep to your ASMR last night when I woke up
I watched a few other videos while getting ready for work before I left
I went to check my discord and got jump-scared by my face burned into the background of the screen
Thank you for doing what you're doing best wishes for you and the girl. That's funny
My face burnt into your monitor screen. That's
Oh
Jump scare
This the but what happens if I'm not actually burned into your screen and the corruption's already happened real true
Arthur stout
Hello, Arthur stout get it because he's a water spout of milk
She beats our girl failure
Girl failure
Plug successfully plug. Okay. Good. Some of the veal or girls are rebranding from their previous channels right now. I recognize another
em
I have terrible absolutely horrific news. Um
But gen one veal or is not made up of people that I've never streamed before it's very unlikely any agency does that
I'ma just warn you right now. Oh, no the bunny. Well, that's why we didn't need this is literally why we didn't name it
Shibi because the fox beats it up without fail. What's this?
Oh, we can put um
We can put orange on this orange fertilizer
Hi, it's Johnny doing good today. Yeah, we're playing childhood game and I'm going great. I'm going fair
Because I love it
um
So the reason
I've said it before but the reason why we put fertilizer is because we get six extra points like on the pedal wheel
For doing this and the pump can get big
And then we're going to try and do it with everything rip the bunny
Yeah, literally rip the oh
We've overworked the f out of this
But once it's growing
Although it looks very small right now. I think I might need to dig this a bit bigger
Sometimes the game's a wee bit funny. Oh my the game called me a what?
A whore
Horticultural horticulturist
Horticulturist, I don't know how to say that word. It's got a t in it. Okay
It's got a t in it the gate is the word's got a t in it. So I don't know what how to do
At least it's accurate a horticulturist. Yeah, okay that word
I know he's wee bum. He lost his wee bum tail
And we got fox too
Who told the game about strunny psychic real true
4k oh the pumpkin's being made
Look at him. That is that is a pumpkin. How much do you sell for 240?
Uh, I'm gonna sell it
Award for growing a pumpkin. Yeah, but give me the award for overgrowing it
Right, so we are going to sell the moth drop because it's an income source
They will constantly come back into the garden and it's really good for us
Um, a snake hasn't come in and eaten. Oh, it's miss petula
What a squashy large pumpkin honestly
Guess it's back to the pet shop for me then you should drop in by a pair. I used to grow drew. I mean
Poison plants in my garden to make money. Why yes, of course poison plants
Horticulturist affectionately. That's so good. Oh someone said that my marshmallow
They um, they were asking in marshmallow. They were asking us to play factorial
Factorio
um
And they said you in the the whole and I was like, uh, excuse me. Where's the affectionate and in brackets
Okay, we've unlocked Bart. We are gonna tell Bart
to
Make this honey
Into medicine. Okay, and excellent and because when we do that when the sherbet
Um, the naughty server pinata that we unlocked
When oh, we're just going to chief for buying something from a shop real
Is this what therapy shopping is?
um
I am literally playing factorial in the background
Hi Bartholomew
I'm gonna be honest because of simpsons. I didn't think Bart was a real name
I said what I said. I didn't I didn't think it was a real name. Okay
Um, we're gonna sell this pumpkin
And we're going to sell the puzzle gum from oh, no, I'm not because I renamed him. Um
Right it is raining. So we should take advantage of that if we can plant
Um chili seeds, but I don't think we've unlocked chili seeds. Yeah, which is a shame. No, we've got pumpkin and we've got a blackberry seed
Okay
We will plant
Excuse me. Uh, we will plant the blackberry seed and we're also going to plant the hazelnut seed because we unlocked
What's called a squazzle? I do not know why the squirrel is called a squazzle
I don't know what
item it's supposed to relate to
Um, did that tree just finish growing?
Not yet, but we are gonna
Give it some red fertilizer if you
Hello, how's it going? It's going
blogger
Ain't medicine for the crow. Oh
It's gonna bloom. Do you see that little thing that that bud right in right ahead right front and center?
I'm playing warframe, but this game is so much nostalgia. I really should poke my 360
You rarely play on pc. It's well worth the money if you are
Uh gamer like that. What do I need that?
Um
um
I'm gonna plant a blue bale and then I'll fully unlock it. How about that?
Oh, I need a pumpkin and I need bark to come back right hold on. I need a pumpkin. I remember
I remember
I need a pumpkin
300 that's extortionate. You should be embarrassed to those prices. Sorry, but capitalism strikes again
You can't escape it. So it's 13 for the seeds
Right, I'm sorry, but oh no, that's too close. Sorry. I didn't realize it was there. Okay. We do have medicine
We're gonna call Bart out once that grows
A plan is stunted. No a plan is stunning
The high table did this
Now you want to make me play something. I'm at in oh my god. I'm at am I an influencer?
Have I influenced you right? We're gonna make this blue bale fully upgraded
So it's gonna be gorgeous and stunning and so pretty and just like you riflin
He's you're my pretty little boy. Okay. We're gonna pop this
And then we're gonna get the white one to eat the blue one and then we're gonna get this new one to eat the red one
Hello, I know you've just got here. Please turn red for me
Your gardening is improved. Are we leveled up again?
Just by the way, thank you
Thank you for liking subscribing and doing all that stuff
Pregnancy ASMR on a subscription box near you
um, my next upload is gonna be a collab with
Said actually
And then I have an ASMR collab with Poseidon from mythos coming out too
I've recorded my side, but I need to record the foley noises for the Poseidon one because there's actually new sound effects in it
I oh we've extended the land
We've got more land
I'm so happy
Right, who's stunted growth. What can he be you you're growing
Oh, you've got his he just got his freaking stinger stuck in the ground
I'm gonna sell the pretz tail because I don't do anything with someone bonked my afro
And now all this sweet sweet loving dropped all over the floor. Thank you for the 150. What the heck?
Thank you afro fluff. What why?
That's so much. That's so much. I didn't do anything. Wait, why is that not spanking it?
Okay, so if we check out the map that was you didn't want me to say or do anything Jesus. Thank you for the 150 tip
That's insane
Someone bonked my afro and now all my sweets are on the floor
Oh my god, thank you. Okay, we have extended the garden again. Do you see the perimeter?
Um, I assure you your money is not going to waste
It is going to the I don't need to do a donathon to confirm the genters and production fund. I assure you
Because oh my god
Oh
Thank you very kind very kind. Thank you to anyone
And if you're watching and you're like, oh, it sucks that I can't give any money
You do not have to give me money
Even licking interacting lurking all of this helps me in the algorithm
Like please don't worry if you're like, I literally cannot handle our money
Surprise, you don't have to
The the reason why two of my ASMR videos went trending is because you guys liked it
And then the algorithm recommended it to people that haven't seen me before
And because you were liking it and interacting with it
It got trending and now unbelievably my first ASMR video on the freaking channel of please let me hold it
Has a hundred k views, which actually I need to say a thank you for on twitter because that is insane
um
Literally a hundred k views like from from
I click on stream and the first thing I do is like I've trained you well come here wiefling
But if you wait, why is the pumpkin over there? Was it just a random pump?
Oh, maybe I like got thrown across the fence. That was quite a distance
I love the yapping ASMR too good because I have like another two that's already pre-recorded
I've just not edited it yet because um, I had to take a break from editing ASMRs and stuff. Um
Oh
Wait, it was raining though. Why are you perishing?
It was raining come on
Don't be so dramatic
Plop plop plop get soiled get soiled wait squid me right now doesn't soil mean to poop your pants
Apologies mama
I might not be able to watch the rest of the stream but rest assured I will be thinking about you at work
I might also have to excuse myself to the restroom too
Wait, hold on a minute. Hold on a minute
Thank you very much boy for the tip and thank you sassafras for the tip as well now hold on a minute
What are you doing at work, huh? Or are you doing at work?
Fair enough be listening to the newest audio that's dangerous
playing with fire
Story your kisses who's my soul that have nice kisses
Okay, let's get
bar in
So we're doing we're setting up in advance
So for when that server pinata comes in he needs to eat a jack o lantern
So bar is going to change this regular schmegular pumpkin into a jack o lantern
Oh
The apples are coming. Oh look
You see all those little green dots on the tree. They're gonna turn red into apples
Reflings we can make apple jam together on our farm. I love this game. I love it
I love everything about this game
It's the best game ever. I don't care what anyone says. Well, I'm biased. How dare you don't say such things
Oh, no, the poppy's about to die. Oh
We're gonna make it we made it we saved it from misery
Oh, I'm no overwarring it. Okay. That was a mistake on my part. Wait. Was I supposed to put red fertilizer on this one?
I knew extending the opening out on the payoff. Oh, we have a new seed. Oh, we have jelly seed
We've opened out a slamar wins. Uh, what would I what would I say? I don't even know what I would say
Good job on your garden
Your garden
Thanks
I don't know what I would say
Okay, so chili seeds when it rains it's good to plant chili seeds because you get 100 coins back per chili
And then if you use the fertilizer you get like 300 coins back
so it's pretty good
Strongly living and planning her retirement via viva pinata
Literally
Bro the farm life of like growing my own produce and having chickens and then sharing it with the neighbors as well
Like I've seen
Anonymous Brian I'd rather jam your peach
Sorry, it was too easy. I get it. No, I'ma I'ma let that one. That was a good one. That was a good one
Yep. Yeah. Yep. Get brain rot. Get brain rot. Get brain rot
Yep. Yep. Yep. Get brain rot. Get brain rot. Get brain rot just by talking to me
Actually, I've made a funny request of emmy. I hope she does it
Well, I hope she has time to do because she's actually super busy right now. Um with her model
But she might be rigging it a lot
um
So I hope she's having a good time because I need to pester her about it very shortly. Um
Yeah, emmy cooking. She is she is cooking
Hey, thank you very much momolo for the super chat and anonymous for the jam
That was that I'll give you that was actually really good. I wouldn't have thought of that myself
And then again, most things don't occur to me, but that's a me problem. Not you problem, you know
Okay, we are gonna give it fertilizer
No, we're gonna go get fucked excuse me
Apparently the fertilizer wasn't it?
Okay, well it worked on the tree so sure. Oh
Oh, we leveled up again. Yay. Oh, so this is a gatherer. She'll pick up everything that from a garden and sell it
I do think she will she posted on twitter that she was done with it. Oh, that's fantastic
I didn't know that's the thing the only thing
I worry when being all these streams is I don't get to catch up until either after streams or I get really lucky
However, I have changed my sleep
So hopefully that means I will sell the second puzzle gum. They're literally 1000 which is insane
Um, oh the share bar. What do you need darlin? What do you need? Has he a jack-o-lantern?
You'll never guess what I have for you. I have something that you desire
I have something you desire look boom
Come on. No, no, no. Come on AI kicking
Yes, come on. No. No, come on AI. You know you want that jack-o-lantern
Look at it. It's so delicious and pumpkin looking
Come on. This is clearly a big bro because it's a pumpkin and Emmy's a wee pumpkin
What sort of fertilizer would work on you?
Pre-ink. Am I allowed to say that pre-ink?
Come on turn around. What are you aiming for? Are you going for one of my pinatas? You better not be
No, don't sell it. I need to wake him up. Go
Who are you going for? What or who are you going for?
I'm telling them to move out the way so he doesn't attack. Yep, right. I was on to you
I freaking had you. Wait, are you going over to the pumpkin that moved?
Right fly over to it AI. Please. Please work with me right now
Wait, what happened to the texture of this bad boy? He's not looking so good
Right, please eat the pumpkin. Where is it? Where did he go?
Oh, is it too late? I can see him over there
Stop going after my freaking pinatas
Eat the pumpkin. Why is the AI not kicking in? Stop
Oh my god, he is helping on trying to get someone sick. I'm literally like stream sniping him and stopping him from doing that
Eat the pumpkin. Can you not see it? Yes
Okay, now land in front of the pumpkin before you time out
Okay, the AI is having a rough time with him
You're scaring everyone in my garden and you're going for the mush, right?
I'm about to start beating him up. Just eat the pumpkin. Eat the pumpkin right now
Are you doing it? Are you doing it in 4k? No, why did you take off?
Are you gonna try and snipe someone in the air? What is going on?
Eat the pumpkin. No, what right? He is bugging out
I think because the AI wanted him to attack someone and I prevented it like all the time
He doesn't know what to do. I think I stream sniped a little too good
Oops, like it was a mistake. I didn't mean for it to happen
Yeah, he doesn't even know how to land right now
Look at him. He's going mental. We'll see a bird's eye view on him
He's like just doing pair of my circles right now. Oh, no, maybe
And he's out of bounds and he's in bounds again
And is he going for the mouse mallow again? I will sell this mouse mallow in defiance
I think he's trying to target it for some reason so I'm just selling it so it's out the garden
Literally the pumpkin is right there point blank. I don't know what's going on. I'll just leave it right
We got a new flutter scotch. I've got a blue and a red one. So we're
Gonna make them yellow
For things being teased of any type but having a stroke
And not the good guy
Okay, and it's my setting day on mine like
You ain't that special sir sir. You ain't that you've got a bit of an eagle
You need your eagles out of 10. I need you to turn it down to a five. Okay. It's good to be humble. It's good to be humble
Okay, right. Let's make this flutter scotch yellow
Oh
And then we have three colorful thingies
Who or what are you aiming at?
Mm-hmm. Okay. Take a right a little bit to the right
I swear if you were randomly going for my butterfly. Yes
stop
Just eat the pumpkin. Right. He's he's starting to upset me. So he's getting ignored. Okay
Do we have a taff light or did I accidentally get rid of them all?
He um, no, I'm not even looking in your direction. You've you've upset me. You've upset me, mr. Bat
Dude knows what he wants can't fault him for it. Literally. I've been upset. Right. We might have more seats that we can
um
Grow for level up a little bit more. Oh sunflower seed
You are my sun flower my only sun flower
You make me happy
When you grow strong
I'll give you fertilizer and you give me an accolade and then I'll level up some more
Yeah, it's not a sad song. It's a good song
Um
Okay, we did it now. We just need to over water the crap of
Although actually, you know what I could do
I could get some help
Mate stop teasing me. I know what you want and it's in the garden
We have a frog. Where's the frog?
Oh, there he is have eaten a tap fly. Oh, we don't have enough water for him. We're sorry
Let me just let me just add some more water there for you. Sorry my good sir. How do he's edging you?
I think oh I discovered uh, uh money in the ground
We're digging we're what are they called when they do the dinosaur bones and stuff from history art architect
No, that's when you design a building
Archaeology I got there. I did it on my own. I got there. I promised I didn't cheat archaeology
We're doing archaeology and we got coins from it
Oh the music in this game is so lovely too
I don't know if I should quickly get a tap fly to make this frog happy
I
Against my better judgment gretchums fetchums more like strong ease
Bonnie's thank you. I'll be here a week
Uh, right we need a tap fly which is blue here he is
Hopefully she goes. I'm really digging this game right now. I'm so glad honestly if you're looking for a chill experience
Yeah, you know what it is a child's game. Am I embarrassed? No, it's a fantastic game. It's well polished
I've never had any issues with it. I honestly think you should give it a shot and try it to the best of your ability
I think it's fun and you get to learn the stuff on your own. I mean, I'm kind of giving you the cheat see doodling
and if you focus on
Developing flowers and getting them all leveled up and stuff and doing like all these wee things
I think it's really well. He is waiting for a tap fly to show up on ironically
um
Okay, I think the most important thing next that we should do is breed all of the sparrow mints
because
um
Uh, we can transform them into something new
What is getting beaten up over there? I have no idea
Is the new get as in new get the thing in the thing
Uh, again, I asked where the dinosaur themed print. Yeah, it's in the mines
Oh, we got nine achievements. Oh, yeah feeling foxy
Foxy
Noogie yes. Oh, did you see his tongue before you saw him? He literally went and I'm feeling a bit silly
And
New yes
Come on, come on, come on, come on, come on Jameleon
Wait, is that the actual words to the song? I think it may be come on, come on, come on chameleon. Oh
Close enough close enough. Close enough. Is the frog still here? It is all the frog actually gave me a chance
Oh, mr. Frog
Guess what I have for you
It's a tap fly all yours
He looks dummy
Um, I made that connection. No joke. Oh, yeah
Wait, oh, I sold the mouse. Oh for goodness sakes. I need to order a mouse as well
Hey, okay. Okay. I order a mouse. I order a mouse. Maybe the snake will still be here if the snake is away
I will get rid of the mouse. I'm not gonna pay for it if he's already gone, right
Right everyone
On the worm team
No house. I need you guys to be just decimated by these
barrels
but not um
Not squirreling and wormling. Okay worm seven. You're done. So
It's the way it has to be okay
We're in the are you guys in the house get wake up wake up. It's humping time
It's humping time. Do you understand? Oh, we did it. We got the frog
Now if I'm not mistaken, I need to feed him
A berry and then hit him when he doesn't feel well. It's rather brutal for him
Oh, we got a fudge hug. I thought it was karma chameleon. I actually don't know
Homeless literally just made them home with sorry
It's
Reeflings after a session
Is that what you said like is the snake still here?
Oh, it is okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Let him get up. Let him get up. It's karma chameleon. Okay
I said come on
My boy furgy it is furgy right you go attack that snake you have my permission. No, you get eaten by the snake
Okay, that tree's fine
Okay, well unfortunately
The birds have gone to sleep. I will give you permission to sleep just this once. Okay
But just this once no other time will I give you permission?
Do I make myself clear?
No, we do actually need another taff life or an achievement, which I'm going to show you
Are you ready for this? You're not ready for this taff life
I'm showing you all the secret strats. Okay. You're welcome. Oh, there's like a little purple berry
Reeflings it's your boss
Would you have per because wait the a more artist drew your mouse
Purple and I'm like does that mean your little boss or purple as well like lord?
Wait, hello. What can I be of service? I see in two worms in a thistle. Okay. Okay. Okay. We're on the clock
It's we're on the clock, but I think we can do it
I think we can do it right. Let's grow a thistle really quickly
But we need to make sure no one walks into it if a pinata gets hit by a thistle
It gets really aggressive for no reason. Well, it gets aggressive because it got hurt and
When you get hurt you lash out. So, you know what? It's understandable
blue berries
Uh a past blue of purple, okay
When you put us in the cage purple balls is the next step after blue then they explode. Okay
Okay, bit dramatic bit dramatic but I get it
Uh see you go away
Literally the first thing whenever you grow like a bad thingy
It like always goes nuts being like do you want to do this? No, I don't want to do this, please
morning
Like no, I don't want you to go into the little thistle when you grow a bad a bad plant, but some
a
Watching you play this and geek out is so damn adorable. My heart just can't take it
Thanks for sharing it with be a good horticulturist and get ready for us to pound that hard soil and plant a seed deep in your garden
And this is amazing see this is why I need you guys to take the helm because you're so funny
And then when I'm like making jokes and stuff like nothing comes out the way I want to thank you anonymous for the tip
I'll be such a good horticulturist horticulturist for you. I'll be the goodest horticulturist of all
Oh, no, wait that did that fudge hog just kill one of the
Starting pinatas the body bear. Oh, finally, right. He must have just bugged out the first time he was in the gear bin
That's fine yet a lot of bugs. Oh, okay. You ready for this? Are you ready?
Are you ready for what happens then?
Don't panic. I've seen it. I'm on my way. Don't panic
Oh
He's going to but he's working through it
Oh, don't worry you can push through it
He so he's gonna come and fix puzzle gum, but don't worry puzzle gum's fine. Right. Watch what look
He made it
You're so smart mr. Ta fly now fly into this right now. Thank you
Almost
Like his little car thing he has to like
Yeah, wait, is that Freddy fazbear?
Oh
That's dardos. No, this is the bad guy. He kills the pinatas if they're left ill for too long
You stink
Let me introduce the star. I think he's the brother of lethal
Sick pinata. I'm stealing their sweets. It's very difficult to stop
If only you could make the pinata well, then he wouldn't try to get their sweets
So you can use patch to heal pinatas that fall sick
But if they're sick for too long, he'll destroy them
Which is a shame
That's dardos more like
Well, funny you mentioned that so that's his dad's that's talking to us now
And lea fos is the sister
So he's not in the family. So that's dardos is a bath dardos. So you're no wrong
They put spinatas out there misery
No
Hi there gardener, need a weedling? I know I'm smolding shoes, but I know how to make any weed disappear
Oh, do please think about it. I'll just be in here drinking milk, but not feeding the cookies. I'm sweet enough already
I'm sweet enough already
Your gardening is improved. I'm sweet enough already. We've just seemed to get
Would you love me if that was my lollipop voice?
We think I'm so glad we can play games together
Oh, I'd be a terrible lollipop
Whoa, this is pinata central. Hi pinata central
As you may know, we supply world-class pinatas to ensure that every party goes with a bang
Oh
Yes
Okay
Okay, okay, okay
We can outdo giardinero can't we rethink this game is pennies against an old man in a wheelchair
Don't go in that water. I need you to turn into a hot scotch. Please. Please hop scotch. Okay. There we go
Oh, he's shaking his booty
Three sparrowman sure. I actually have that I actually have three sparrowman at christmas america. Okay, boom
Yes, this is thank you fanny go away
Okay, one
two
And three where did he go?
Was he not just there mug on cruising
Oh, isn't it was the third one not just there get
Get the
What I'm being trolled
I'm being trolled. No, I can't reach you
Get off the perch get off it and go on the ground
I'm getting trolled go on the ground so I can pack you up in this box right go
All right, we have completed
Uh a challenge. I think we need to do 20 and we get an achievement for that
What do you need has eaten three kind of fruit? Well, there's three fruit down. So please
We already have the medicine. We just need the bird bath for him
The meds are doing well the popstrone would absolutely destroy my heart as if you don't already make me want to hug and cuddle you all day
I mean, I'm done. If you guys are doing a clone
A sour crota
Crola what's the pun in crola's name?
I can't think of a sweet that sounds like crola. It sounds like cruella the
the um
The thing that marines eat
The you draw with them
What are they called? I've completely forgotten what those are called. Oh a cola?
Oh, maybe cola
A quackberry
Oh, we've unlocked ivor ivor is down on his luck
But with help he might be on
Much better term. Okay. Always root for the underdog dog. Why do I say dag?
Man dag don't the dog one dog. Don't wonder it. Are you squid me right now?
Anonymous whether you're a sweet little lollipop or a full-aged scottish whiskey. We will always love you. You're bad
You're bad. I'm gonna call you bombs yet. You're a bomb. You're a bomb. You're a bomb. You're a bomb. You're a bomb
You're all bombs, but you're my bad
Thank you anonymous for the tip and remain to me. I used to see bam. I forgot
What's this a beggar? He must have heard about your ever-increasing garden value. You should deal with him immediately
Leaf boss. That's very judgmental of you. I assure you that most homeless people don't actually want to be in the situation
Most homeless people struggle with mental health and drug addiction
Which makes them say things and do things that they don't actually mean and yes, of course
There's scenarios and situations where people who are homeless say they're better off in the streets because what other solutions do they have
Their family have given up on them
Which is understandable for the family because they're being drug-independent and they've done behaviors that are damaging and dangerous within the household
But leafos you shouldn't be so judgmental. Sometimes um, it's a lot easier to judge
But if you're in their shoes, you might be in the same scenarios and do the same things. Okay
So please be open-minded. It's okay leafos
But you can learn to be better as a person without the judgmental aspect
Did you know that average american is only two checks away from being homeless? That's scary leafos
Think of the economy think of the citizens that try their best and work nine to five and do the way
Do the thing that society told them to do and yet they still can't find relief
Or any sort of outlets for the stress they go through. No wonder people turn to drugs and alcoholism
I'm sorry leafos. Please don't do that again. But thank you for your input. Anyway, we unlocked iber
Boom, thank you. Look look at all the seeds. We're gonna all the sweeties that'll drop from the sky
Look, there's lots of sweeties in the garden now. All the pinatas will eat the sweeties and they'll all be nice and happy
I can't believe it. We reached utopia, but it was in viva pinata. Let's go
Viva pinata devs were so real for that
That was strongy. That was strongy and welcome to my TED talk
Even the language used around people who are drug addicts is quite um
detrimental
No one wants to be called a junkie in passing
Some people are drug dependent and that's okay
Some people's brains are wired to be more addicted to the average person personally
I've never tried any recreational drugs because I'm aware of how much I use gaming and I drink cola as a vice
So I know that I am most likely a very have a very addictive personality
And I like to imagine the best in uh people and that's fine
Oh, they touched the thistle. I told you not to touch the thistle stop touching the thistle
Oh, wait, sorry buzzle comes and reasons hate each other
I don't mind
Being called a strongy junkie. No drug dependent
junkies, uh
Sometimes it's a little mean I guess
It's like calling me
I don't know what you would call me a whore unaffectionately. How dare you refer to me unaffectionately
With that terminology
War in the garden is broken out. I'm stuck in this cut. I can't back out. I don't know if you can hear that
I can't back out. I'm like literally stuck in I have to watch them fight. I can't even interfere
Don't talk about cool ejection. You used to drink 1.5
It's not your fault. They literally lab make that stuff
and
I'm just straight up having to watch them fight until someone loses. Oh
Oh, say the bumblebee's gonna win. I'm actually gonna sell the reason because they always fight in a garden
Strongy calling people a junkie is very damaging. I told you not to touch the thistle
I thought they touched it right what we need is actually just the thistle head. So if we destroy the thistle
We'll just left the round at thistle head. I'm strongly dependent on two tips away from the streets
Don't do that
Whatever you do. I only have a thousand coins to give. Oh iver. I'm so sorry. I don't have a lot of money on my persons right now
Thank you spidey for the tip. You better not be I'll literally start throwing hands violently
Hi iver
You're very generous indeed
I just want you to know that thanks to your coins and goodwill
We'll be different the next time we need for now. Please accept a beggars. Thanks and his oh good. Bye iver
I hope you can land on your feet. I'm sorry. It was so little but maybe it can do something for you
I believe in you even when no one else does even when leafos is being a judgemental
Oh
Dear one of your pinatas is being trampled that will make them unhappy trampled who what where why when?
Where's this reason oh no
Oh no, oh
No, I don't like hearing its little pain cries. Please
I only have 20 coins
It costs 50
So if I'm in a box sign the street, I shouldn't send this
No, you shouldn't don't be in a box in the street. You're you'll honestly upset me some streamers like find it funny
I actually don't find it funny
like it upsets me um
like I always say like please only like
Support monitor really wise if you know you're comfortable. You're having a good time
You know your debts are paid off
You've got savings like all this is really important. I don't want you thinking like i'm a more important than what's going on with you
You know, you know
Hello, you know
Okay
That poor thing. Please heal him
I
Don't want to hear his little pain cries. I feel so bad
No
I don't like his wee pain cries. Oh, you feel better, baby. Yeah, you feel better. I'm gonna sell you for safety
Oh dark dirty. He came out to kill him
We hate you
I like to like tooth. We hate you
Right. I'm gonna sell these trees because they actually get worth quite a lot
Oh
Uh, oh we've got a new color. Let's make them green
Time to go green
Oh mr. Flores scotch
Your green abedy. Oh, hold on. Hold on. I need to grab you. Okay, and then I'll pop you there
Okay, we do have
sparrowman
Actually, I think I need Gretchen to bring in another one. Yes, and then we can make baby able to get a fudge hog
So i'm gonna get one more worm just in case what if my debt is payable in 30 years?
Am I allowed to do no mortgage hate? I don't know
If you put like $50 extra a month to your mortgage, do you get penalized for that?
Oh like dinner off the Ivers opened up a shop
Ta-da
Quite an improvement. What my basic level of hygiene is not the only change for I have also set up a grand news
Oh, that's fantastic
I'll kill with the most special items I find on my many travels. My apologies if I'm ever away
But should you notice the store is open? Uh-huh. I urge you to pay me a visit and peruse whichever items
I have managed to find on my latest trip. Of course. See you soon. I hope
Oh, thank you. Lovely. Lovely. Oh
You can pay extra towards the principal. Yes, if you're ever paying extra towards your
Uh mortgage, please make sure you're doing it towards the principal and not the interest by default
The banks will try and make you pay against your interest
Don't let them win
Don't worry the high table plans will come out soon. You just have to wait refling you have to be patient for me
Soon my sweet weebaw
You will attack
I shouldn't say such things
Okay, we are going to put another worm in the garden
Um
And hopes of getting a fudge hog
You
But bankers make more money the slower you pay off the mortgage. Yes
So if you have an extra $50, don't give it to me you goofy goober
Try and pay against your principal because if every month you did an extra $50
It makes a difference on the interest overall and you're saving yourself tons of smack of your knees. Okay
I will teach you all the tricks and the fun part is if you pay your debt mortgages off earlier
It puts your credit score down. Yes. Oh, okay. Time to put my tinfoil hat on. Did you know the credit score?
Credit score is a complete scam if you have no debts debit cards only no credit and no debts towards anything
Your credit score is considered
shit
Now let me just repeat that again for those who didn't hear in the back
If you have no debts full savings and nothing is wrong
Your credit score will be bad
But if you're indebted to the car dealership if you're indebted via a mortgage if you're indebted
Via a small credit card
You have good credit
Tell me credit score isn't a scam without telling me credit score isn't
a scam
Okay, no
No, no, no, I know I get passionate about the high table
All I'm saying is if you live at home with your family
Guess what don't be embarrassed about it
Why on earth should you move out the moment you turn 18 types up? Okay
Oh, no, we unlocked the ruffian
I think I need captain cutlass
to stop them coming
um
Okay, okay, okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. So a ruffian is showing up. Oh, I've got the achievement for the shovel
Credit scores only exist to stop whamen owning land. They recreate the same year
The u.s. government allowed whamen to get divorced
Stop I didn't even hear that
down with the high table
John wickling. Thank you for the tip down with the high table
If I am not being a silly billy. I think iver has an item called the cutlass and oh, he's not unlocked it
Yeah, I'm not labeled up enough
I'm confident. There are things you could be tempted to buy from ivor's portal
Are you squinting right now?
Thanks for the tips. Wait, why are you saying thanks to the tip for me? Or do you mean against your mortgage?
Oh, don't worry. Whatever information I know. I'll try my best to share it
Now, please do take everything I say with a green assault. I miss remember things and I'm also very silly
Um, so I'm sorry if I say anything wrong. I'm just
Bucket I'm just having a good time and I hope we can all have a good time
But yeah, uh, if you have a mortgage or you're thinking about a mortgage, um, you have to pay against the
principle is the terminology for the loan
Um, not against the interest the interest is where the banks win. Okay
We want the banks to lose as quick as possible
So we're working on
Don't worry. I like spreading misinformation on the internet
We do a bit of tomfoolery on the internet
Did you know that haggis is a an animal that lives in the highlands only and they're very hard to harvest
But you can only hunt them during breeding season because their numbers become like outrageously big
um
So it's very hard. Oh my god. Look at his color scheme
I love him. Thank you for playing every aspect of my childhood days without strony streams feel so empty
Why aren't you glad I'm a daily streamer then, huh?
Thank you logo doggie logo doggie for the a super chat and thank you cam chaos for the super chat
I'm sure if that is your thing that a day without strony feels empty. Oh boy, you're glad i'm addicted to streaming
I know you are
I'd admit it
I'd admit it. Mm-hmm. I'd admit it. You're addicted
Okay, we are
Your friend you will never be alone again
Sorry, just warming up for the karaoke surprise karaoke stream
When when am I doing it? I don't know yet. Let me cook. Okay. Let me cook
I don't know when i'm doing it, but we are gonna grow some corn because we're gonna turn it into bread
Oh
Oops, I actually would like you to survive hold on
All right, I think she's a bit more
You've groomed us to be here every day at this time
Now don't worry if you do have life obligations
You might be a vod watcher right now or you might be kind of listening to me in the background
If you have obligations, it's very important that you do prioritize what is going on with the
texture on the water
It's really having a rough time with it. Honestly
Um
Yeah, please don't write what I want to do. Should I get more red hot? I think I should
Right, I will
No, right first things first i'm the realest um i'm not but uh
First things first we'll do you guys so we're gonna make all the birds hump and then we're gonna make them all yellow
Where if the sparrows would stop being in the trees for five seconds?
So I can deal with you. I can't even tap the tree because the fruits aren't done
And I would waste all that produce right. I think he's about to come in right
What do you want a bottle of medicine? Are you be lining for the medicine? No, you're not. How dare you?
Um
We did it. She's gonna do it
Background scrawny makes work better. I'm glad that like you guys enjoy being the background
You must be like what is this nonsense? She's on about half the time though
Or maybe like gives you a smile and your co-workers trying to talk to you and you're like, yeah, yeah, yeah
You're like trying to hurry up the conversation. So you get more scrawny time. Oh my god
That's so cute. Whoa. Oh wait. Why did my garden value go up? I didn't do anything right. We're gonna turn this into bread
Corn into bread. I don't ask about it. I mean you can make corn bread. Oh, it's an american game. It's corn bread
I never understood why corn turns into bread. We don't have corn bread
in
the uk
Oh, I just got that right scrawny is the type of person who would tease you to make you blush and say corny as jokes
Just to make you smile if you're having a bad day
Then hold you close and give you loving head kisses a best friend and a caretaker all in one
Thank you and all of us. I hope i'm able to make you giggle and stuff
I'd also milk you too to make you feel better. Uh, what who said that right go on the floor
Thank you took you long enough, right?
Number nine you're getting executed
That's terrible. What are you you go execute another one as well
I really hope we seem to have wormling
I don't know if our other worms survive wormling and squirmling survived the assault of the fudge hog feels good, man
Oh
Oh my god, it's gammy
Ah
Yeah
me me me
Yeah, gimme gimme gimme gimme. Oh, yeah, we go again
I love shadow wizard money gang. We love gimme right you two hump
Right now
You need to hump. You don't understand hump hump
Okay
Now he can meet as well, which is good
So how many sweets do I need? I think I need like one. I don't know like five
You my friend so you can buy romance sweets that mean you don't have to do
Oh, the sweets are six quids. They're so cheap
They're so giggily
Giggity basically whizzling giggity giggity. What?
Yammy low
Making us giggle drained and well maintained
That's actually such a good model
Strongly cuddles keeping the reeflings
Giggling drained and well maintained. Wait, did I make that up? Wait, did I mess that up not make that up?
I didn't make it up. I literally just read it from chat. I'm sorry. I'm not I'm not stealing it
I'll steal your jokes though. I'll steal your pump. It's from family
Us watchlings can keep an eye out in your garden for any unwanted visitors and give them the
Is that supposed to be a british person?
Makes you strong. So I'll be in here doing my training if you need me
He went all right gov all right gov need some hired muscle
Us watchlings if that was supposed to be a british accent
No, oh we got tail upgrade we're level 16 already
He's getting milked in there
Nonsense technique and enough expertise to be called a professional gardener. I'm professional. We're not experienced. We're professional
Oh, I got a jammillion. Where is it?
Apparently there's a jammillion. Oh, he's so big. Hi, buddy
He's ours already
Oh, that's fantastic
Oh, I do love this game very much
Oh, look at me. He's just pinching. Oh, we have a quackberry. Where are you?
About we're looking for like a
You're so cute
You want a piece of bread? Oh my god. We get a jammillion and a quackberry on the same day
British accent for american people
Oh my god
Jama jama jama jama media
Oh, he's so cute. He's purple and green kind of like me. I'm pinky. He's purple
Right now. We are gonna sell him
Not him. We need to do something with him, but I don't think I've unlocked it yet
Um, I'm working
I'm working babe
That boy's a singer. That's not the words at all
So we are gonna sell the jammillion because he's a constant money source when he comes in
Um, so we'll keep getting more jammillions
Level 17 don't mind if uh
Right you beat up any worm that isn't got a name
Okay squirreling and wait, is there only is there only two left?
How many are in the garden current residents too? Okay, so we're gonna get them to have the sweets now
Okay, please eat sweet and please eat sweet and then we will turn them all yellow
We'll turn them we'll make them a british chinese and make them all yellow because all the food in a british chinese is fucking yellow
But it's delicious though. Honestly. Sorry. Um, that's one thing I miss about scotland a good fucking chinese
Now there is a word for chinese in scotland
um that's seen as racist
Um, I don't know if you guys know it actually maybe I shouldn't talk about it
But if so you might hear some scottish people use that terminology and people are like oh, that's racist
There's absolutely no racism behind it. Um, there's zero racism. It's literally just what it used to be called
What is it? Well, I'm not gonna say it. I'll
um
Right, I'll sell this puzzle gun for some extra monies as well
We'll do the tat we'll do the spirulments first. I'm actually gonna plant some extra
Um
Oh, we have a new seed. We have a fir tree and a venus fly trap not the other variation. I almost just said um
Right, we've got a fir tree. I'll try and look after it. She said she has no intention to look over it. Um, why am I in the shop?
I have forgotten why I'm in the shop. Okay. Well, that's fine. We can back out something along the lines of a
No
Oh, so no wait, is there no british or scottish person in here?
A venus fly trap real
Real true. Oh, I was gonna make more butter scotches because we're about to just decimate the but oh, did you see the little bird?
So I'm not the only person any any butter room
I'm buttering right now
It's probably the old word. No
Sounds like inky. Okay, there you go. There is someone that doesn't know this
So, um, there's like a big debate if it's racism, but literally all of scotland is like, uh, no, it's literally just what we call it
And so I'm praying I don't slip up on stream
Because it's offensive
But I don't I don't want it to be offensive, you know
Oh my god
Oh, he's getting big. Oh, he's growing. Oh, you're gonna be such a big little birdie. Oh
Your multiply you get so big you're big and strong your little cutie pie
You're so cute
Okay, we have a quackberry. No
I think the quackberry has to eat a night shade
Berry and then I whack it and it becomes a gooseberry
Okay, so there's a lot of berries being thrown around. So if you have dyslexia, I'm so sorry about making it worse
Him. Oh, I'm gonna turn this off because I think everyone's flying into it and burning themselves
Okay, so we're gonna have what a fifth one
and then
Okay, we need one more sweetie
technically
A crack berry. No
I get it now. Thanks for using
an excellent
I know but I'm not gonna say it. Yeah real real based through
Uh
Plap mallows are the best
Plap mouse mallows. Are you plapping the fucking mouse pin?
What are you doing in your your viva pinata gameplay? Are you plapping the mice?
What's going on here?
Leave my gen to train conductor mouse that goes chi chi. Oh, okay
Leave her alone
She didn't mean it. She just got come puzzled. Okay. Wait if I sell bread, does it work?
It's only worth the 60 but she sells it for how much in our shop? Sorry. I need to like water the crap out of this
over water. It's like to filth right now
Over water over. Oh my god. I never even said I sung Freru jacka in the soft spoken voice
And I was like, you know what? This actually is really nice. I might do humming and like
Playing with your hair ASMR or something. I didn't mind it. I thought I was gonna dislike it because I don't feel very confident
But but it actually made the role play like really tie together
Because I was saying to you in the in the pregnant with you ASMR that I'm like, oh
I'm not very confident, but I'll do anything for you
And I think it's important to push yourself like past your boundaries
That make me might make you unhappy or might make you uncomfortable in the moment because if you push past it
Um, you may discover that you had an amazing time and I want you to be brave and reach out to the world around you
Oh, I'm not gonna sell him. He's mine
um
You know, again a moth drop is kind of like income source. So if it looks mean that I'm selling them
I'm sorry. I don't mean it. Look. We got a purple. Uh
Oh, it's black even though he ate a purple seat. Hello
Hello
Oh, he looks pretty cool after that
I've definitely seen he's purple though. I don't know why I gave him a purple scene
May sell this tree actually
Oh, I could probably put some fertilizer on there. Humming is more so good
Yeah, like clean with your hair humming or something like maybe you're napping on my chest
And I'm just kind of like
Well, I wouldn't hum freighter jacko because that would be like why are you singing me straight up lullabies?
Hmm
I'd clap to every pinata's name
Instantly no, I'm not freaking. Oh, they're all coming out now right everyone wake up. It's breeding time wake up breeding time
breeding time breeding time
What level are we 18? Oh my gosh, we are living in
We are leveling up. We are leveling up all the levels all go up
We are leveling. What is this? Is this an incremental game? I can't believe it. They've got me again. Capitalism's grasp is too good
Right, okay, we're gonna get these two and then we don't fly on to I know what you're gonna do
Why are you going back in it's morning? They wake up in the morning. I swear this game hates me
They wake up in the morning
Your garden is legal now
Did you know the age of consent is 16 in the uk rub?
about
Make it 18 right now
Make it 18 right now. That seems really outdated
mmm
It's breeding time. Is that a roll call for refling prison?
Oh, you want a prison scenario that you're in prison and you're like, hey man
I really need some relief and I'm like
Refling I can't do that. I'm on the job
And then you're like
Oh, oh do me a solid. Please. I'm begging you. I'm begging you
I'm like, oh fine. You're just got such a way with words refling. I will love it
It's also 16 in the us
Oh dear
Anyway, uh back to the garden yep level whoa, it's so tall
Oh
Okay, let's go
Uh, you also get less lives you actually can't see under the clock that blurry thing
You see it's supposed to be my lives, but it's not displayed right now
Um, I don't know why it's not displaying because I've never had any issues
Like with the actual hard copy of the game
Okay, the egg is being delivered. We're gonna move it to the side
But if I'm not mistaken, it should say there's five. Yeah, and there's another egg on the way
Okay, and then everyone becomes yell right now
I'm gonna sell this tree because a squazzle hasn't shown up and I'm like, bro. This tree is gonna get old
What do you why are you sad you were sitting on a parrot?
Brian you wake up to strong sitting on top of you wanting your inqua cup refliling. It's breeding time
I will I mean
Are you wrong?
I can't what is going on
The textures in this game. We're having a time
Thank you anonymous. Okay
Can I interest you in oh wait wait wait wait wait like as in the prison and I'm like it's breeding time
Viva pinya
It's breeding time, but to the same tempo of viva pinya as intro. It's breeding time
Filled with
Oh
I'm gonna ruin it. I'm gonna ruin it. I'm sorry. I'm not gonna talk for the rest of the day
I am so sorry to even speak those words
Oh, I am so sorry
I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry
Oh, that's another thing I need to do. I need to do my um
My song cover actually I forgot about that
Oh, I don't think I'm supposed to do an endurance stream right now, but you know what it's fine. I'm having a good time. That's the main thing
I can't make a parody that's terrible
Okay, the tree like that good tree. You gave me a little more. Okay, we're gonna get an award for being a master
Rumensa for these birdies
I am going to sell the house because it's gonna start getting in the way of what we want to do next
So we're gonna break all of the
one two
And three we'll start with three because we already know they're all gonna try and
Oh, no, we need to wait until it's hatched. Okay, we need to wait until it's hatched
But I will plant these again
So we're gonna get the master award
We're gonna change them all into the wee things. Are you squidding me right now? What are you saying?
Keeble, thank you for the extended membership. Why are italians great partners because they can only love one person
Hold on. Hold on. I can't see my fucking
Thank you, I will literally pay for a parody now. That sounds like an incredible idea
Kaidon is cursed though. Okay, we got the master romancer award
Everyone become yellow. No
yellow
Yellow
Plap, plap, plap, become yellow
Yeah, see we got transformation transformation central
We're gonna cheap it as well. We're getting so much gamer score
I don't even know how much gamer score we've gone through
Oh, but we're doing it. We're doing it. What do you need two mouse mallows? I will oblige on
Oh, no, they eat the yellow ones
I don't really want to tell it to go away though
Okay, we need to make them all yellow yesterday not now yesterday. Okay. Yes. I know it's improving. Please. Okay
Oh, he's having so much fun
I don't remember this one
I don't remember that one much yet. Okay. Okay. Okay. This is the thing with the interruptions. You're doing it again
Okay, let me let me fart around in the garden, please
Okay tap
tap
Tap right. Okay
Okay, you yellow go
I will say that's the one good thing about having flying pinata in no trees. They can't hide from you
What are you? You're okay you
You yellow
Can you come out, please?
Release
Perfect right you yellow. Thank you. Uh kaidon for the super chat as well
Okay, we
We're doing it
Can you please eat this?
How many we got I think we're doing it. I think we're doing it. Oh, yeah, I see you come over here right now
Eat the flower eat eat the flower digest the flower digest the flower
Okay, okay. He's the last one. He's the last one. Come on. Come on. Yeah, come on. You can do it. Yeah
We did it
We're gonna get the master romance award for the canaries even though we didn't do a single thing for them
I'm gonna make sure these are okay
I don't want them to accidentally perish because I put a lot of my stumps in them
Oh, maybe we can very quickly put fertilizer on this. Jeez the game is working out
Oh, I think it's kind of funny gardens pretty much just grass dirt and water
I mean
Isn't that technically what all gardens are but in a particular way they have to be a particular way or you perish
Um also reeflings whenever any of my gen mates come online, please do tell me I will tell the
Tell you because because I'm doing endurance stream
You do not have to feel forced to sit and watch me play a childhood game
I promise you. Um, I am not insulted at all and I do love when you support my gen mates
It makes me have a happy happy
Head right. We're gonna order two mouse mallows
And
And we're gonna put them in a box
In a box of scraps
In a cave
The next time it rains we're definitely gonna do a big ol
sale
Because we are very low on money
I do want to like change I'm gonna keep the canaries because because because because
And we might be able to get a buzzinge because of it the snakes we need to evolve soon
I'm gonna keep the flutter scotch because I can make them turn
A pink the next one's pink and then I think we can fully sell off the flutter scotches
As we get new white flutter scotches in
And then we can do the red hots
Right first
First mice then red hots and then we'll do our money try and make as much money as possible
We're trying
You can't just have candy for a meal
What are you man?
My mom
But mom have I grew everything so far?
You know what? I'm gonna grow toadstool in preparation of a profita a profita roll. You need two
um of these
and
When you to bar on them they become like good toadstools and they don't hurt the piñatas
And that's what the profita roll mole eats is after a profita roll called a profita mole
Uh
I don't want you in my garden. So you're gonna try and eat my little
Um mouse melon, but I need it. I need it for piñata central because there's an achievement
It actually might be 10 if I'm remembering correctly. I might be sent 10
Oh
Reflings can I kindly request one of you look up the achievement take viva piñata?
um
Um, what would the achievement be called send piñatas on uh
Piñata sent to sit to a party maybe would be the words and stuff maybe I'm not sure
Uh, I'm thinking
I'm not thinking too hard though. I'm not very good at that
A man, I haven't had a profita roll in ages. Am I making you all want sweets playing this game?
I've had apple pie encustered for the first time in
ages
And it is literally making me cream myself. It's so good. Oh, I didn't know I had one of you
Light yourself on fire right now
And when you walk through the fire, I will turn you into a red hot in the video game viva piñata
And the reason I'm saying that it's because if you didn't know there's AI captions on youtube
And if you upset it too much, it will legit perish your input your unlimited ads
It's really frustrating honestly
They oh
Oh, I literally predicted your cute little butt showing up. I already have what he needs
I knew you were coming
I knew you were coming. I literally predicted your cute bit to showing up
A broly legend could I could I try your cream strony?
I did cream a little bit
Please officer strony you're inking me so much
I am completely out of ink all that is coming out now is inked us now
What I didn't say you had to stop
You go the fact that you're called prisoner 69 is so good stop
You're making me want to make all these goofy roleplays
No one's gonna take him out. Um
Wait, who's ill?
Who's ill?
Who's ill? I don't know who's ill. Oh, no. Oh, no, he went into the flame, but I never took him out
I'm sorry. I never helped him. Oh dear. Oh dear
Oh dear oh dear oh dear
Inked us, please officer strony like literally know everyone's gonna like glance because you can see the titles of what a patreon post is
All of mine look like in shit post. I mean they are a little bit, but that's the kind of stuff I like making
There now everyone. Hey, buddy. Gummy. Would you like to have a sweetie?
You want a little midnight sweet?
Oh
We get oh stop flying. Please stop flying into the lake. Oh darling. Stop flying. Right. Okay. No one interrupt me
taff like
Please do this again. I am on standby. Nothing will stop us
Okay, nope you missed
You want to try again?
What are you so happy about?
Oh
Is he acting like he's on fire when he's not
Oh, he was on fire, but he wasn't
Oh dear. Well, we've got five red tots now, which is fantastic
Um, we just need to get a few more. We're done
Oops, I thought these were gonna grow. Uh my bad
Please
Don't die. I'm sorry. I almost abandoned him for the more literally
Shawnee cooked him alive. Literally. It was a barbecue and he got caught in the crossfire
The game's betraying you by hiding the animation literally. I've never seen such issues before
But I guess it's because we're streaming to uh, um
So the way it works, I believe is we're streaming to an xbox right now and the xbox is streaming the game back to us
um
Which is like really cool technology if you think about it
Please tell me we can unlock a cutlass, please
Please I want a cutlass so badly, please
I
My garden is improving, but it's improving a bit too fast for me to keep up. I'm not even gonna lie
It's it's doing it's doing too well. I can hardly keep up with the notifications, right white flotterscotch
you
Please become pink and he went out of bounds
Right, please stop going out of bounds in my garden. That'd be great
Please become pink right now
Oh, we're level 20. Oh
We've just unlocked a new seed. I don't know what it's gonna be though
Oh, we can sell uh sparrowman as well for extra money
Oh
He's so cute. Oh, I like the eye kind of like the hidden eyes on its wee wings. That's a pretty one
That'll do it. That'll do it. You are pretty boy. Okay. Um, right. We can now spell sell
Sparrow mints because they're just like a free income source. I am going to wait for
What am I gonna wait for
I think I'm just gonna ask her to catch a tap fly
Um, and then we'll turn it into a red hot and then I think
That's the red hot achievement done and then we can sell all of them and that'll be a big money source
We can start investing
in stonks
Not really don't invest in the stock market
Well, don't listen to me. I ain't qualified in any investment advice, but
I think investing in people is a good and nice thing to do. I like to think that the girls
Know that I believe in them and I invest in them and they are doing the best
That's just me being a simp. So, yeah
Invest in dealer
Oh, we did it. We unlocked the the um
The mix fertilizer it's for nine
um nine quids
It always perfectly does it correctly
Which I love I think is so good. Um
Oh, we got a bumblebee that I can sell. Is it you? No, it's the other one that's in the garden
you
Okay, again another a thousand maid didn't have to do a thing. Okay
Uh fair gay, we could maybe sell you. I don't normally do anything with fudge hogs
If I was actually quite surprised and he doesn't really have any secrets other than variations
I don't know. I mean if you guys want to go for a hundred percent encyclopedia
We could but I'm not sure if that would be so entertaining
I've never done it before
Actually, that reminds me. I need to go back and finish slonic heroes
based on it for playing my childhood game
Oh my god, what happens if we played our childhood games together
And then you told me about your childhood games and I played them on stream for the first time
And then I reviewed them and then you can have a nostalgia trip and I can have a nostalgia trip
And we can all just have fun together and have a really good time
Okay, one taff like so we need one more taff like because one of them got eaten by a frog
They turned the freaking frogs. Okay, boom
Okay
Animal
Hey
Every now and then
Brian am I odd for wanting to hear asmr or nsfw audio about a sunday's drony
I think you'd sound so cute with a half the attitude
What you mean
Oh, there's a rugby and please go away. Please fuck off. I'll pay you to I'll pay you 50 bucks to fuck off
Literally, um, I think that's the meme anyway. Oh
Please taff like you have the worst timing ever
Use 50 quid shove up your horse right. Okay. How many six? Okay. We need one more. Oh
Oh, no, what do you want?
I once a far tree. Oh, no, it's about to be a massacre for these canaries. It's about to be a massacre
It's about to be a freaking massacre
I got an award for having it though. Okay
So it's about to be a massacre
He's not leaving but 20 is 20. Thank you anonymous for the tip
All the childhood games on SNES. Oh, I don't even think I was born
I'm like 100 sure I wasn't even born. I'm sorry
Um, right don't fly into this only fly into it if I give you permission to fly into it
Will you ever very visit spiral you barely got to the third world? Oh, I was very ill
I probably um, I could definitely go back to that game if you'd like maybe I'll do a catch-up stream because I need to do
Um, sonic heroes. I was very close to finishing that spirals. I was close to finishing that
I don't know if there's any other games. I didn't finish due to one reason or another
Come on. No, you miss
Get up
Hey you
Is he supposedly on fire right now? I don't know
Nope, I just I just scared him with water. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I can't tell the games has been funny
Please fly into it
Uh-huh. Oh, yeah, no
No, you need a big approach. Give it a wink. Come on. You've got some wingspan on you
Come on, baby. Come on. Oh, come on. He's spinning around it. I'm literally getting teased
Are you stopping before the flame? Right? There you go. There you go. Good boy. Good boy. There we go
Right, we did it
We got a master romancer without even making them do the dance trying strongy, but you need to command it harder
Wait, what did I say? Thank you broly legend for this super chat. What did I say? I wasn't I wasn't
Your gardening is improving
Level 21
Level 21 and we've only just begun and we've only just begun and we've got a tight all upgrade
We've got a tight all upgrade and then we're an expert gardener. No, we're an expert gardener
Gardener I barely even door
You know, you guys are just rude
Oh, we have max garden capacity. We have max garden capacity
Gargle her
That's not yeah one that can okay. Let's master land on. Oh my god
What we're gonna charge rent now or something?
No, no, we're not we're not going to charge rent to the low we've open hours
Make sure to keep the square of hard dirt for the dragon to make it golden golden brown
textures like sun
Okay, my pinot is about to be in who
Who ate what
Oh, it was a mouse. Okay. That's fine. We actually need two mice
Stop flying in the flames. Oh my god. You guys are blind. Seriously
Right, we have two serpents
We're gonna make
a house for the serpents
Because we do want them to hump
A serpent home, sorry, I could not for the life of me see that I was having to go through it
We've gone through it for real for real. Okay, boom. We'll just put it over here. Wait. No, we won't because there's something in the way
I don't know what's in the way, but I put it there anyway
Uh, have you considered adding chat sends like if I set number of people use the lap and won't attract please?
I don't actually know what that is. I'm so sorry
I've never heard of that. Is it youtube compatible a lot of integration is like twitch only because youtube's api
Is slightly behind
But I have faith youtube is gonna get there unironically if you look at like every year how streaming has improved on youtube I
Gonna be controversial and say that they're just better right now for any streamer
Um, like twitch is cut for subs is like
Oh, we can sell you
It's old gets old gets old home
I think there is a taffy as well
God, they're all buzzing about
You can hear them
Oh, there's a profanum rule. Oh, hi. Hi seedos. Give me a new seed, please
Yes, you can
Sunflower seeds are a great source of something. I don't know what but they're oh tilly seed. Thank you for free money
Oh, right. You're only giving me one today. Jeez talk about being a stingy
bastard
I hope they accept other payment methods for membership or chat because only credit is raw
Wait, did they not accept debit cards? Ah, I gifted a red flutter scotch
Well, you're lucky. I even have one in here somewhere. There it is. Well, your days are numbered little guy
I
Pave a debit card. I gifted memberships to she be when um, the
Herum were given like tons in a row
and
I just saw that can you oh
What is that? I saw that it was something. Oh, I was like in the pond. I don't know if you can see on screen
maybe
Why are you? Why are you drowning? You're swimming in that water?
What's bouncing?
Uh, I don't know. Maybe it's getting old. Oh, well that flutter just got glitched out. I can see it
Aw, gamy sleeps so peacefully
And it depends what country you live in the world is unfolding. Oh no, I can use PayPal. Yeah, let me use PayPal for me
Oh, we're gonna sell him for a little bit money. Oh, he's doing it
He's being so sneaky
Oh, he was rubbish
Wait, why are you randomly attacking my flowers? Don't do such things. That's stinky
You'll be a stinky boy
I know you can be a good boy
Oh, and I'm killing my trees. Hold on. I've not even grown them properly yet. Hold on. Hold on
Bear with me bear with me
Okay, you better be a hunter a better hunter than my friend
You may just have to set it up through your google account rather than youtube
What's that more private personally? Oh
Not main I meant from the corporation's point of view. Sorry
I'm afraid I am sad to report
I can't show up to your house just yet
But soon
soon
um
Yes, I also did my research on voice packs yesterday on how
VTuber agencies offer voice packs
So I didn't actually know what it was like or what they do or how big it is or how short it is
But um, I got some information divulged to me. Um
So I will work on Azur's voice pack with her for her donathon
um
I just need to work on the tears. So what we're going to do is I'm going to propose what she does
She's going to show it on stream. Oh
You know you such a good boy now. Oh
That thing popped
Can't pay with PayPal on computer but can on youtube app, but iOS takes 30% that's insane
I think wasn't there
Oh, it was oh my god, that's so cute. Oh my god
I fucking love it. I fucking love it. It's getting named
Profita moling. I know you're supposed to drop the e
Was it i before e unless it's something something but no
What the fuck look at the way it moves
A profita mol gen 2 girl confirmed because oh my god, I love it. It's so cute
Okay, what do you need? You need to eat licorice. I'm not ready for you to do that yet. Okay
Uh, I guess we don't need the mushrooms
Wait, it didn't eat the mushrooms. It just wanted two of them in the garden
That's very specific
Oh, it's a monkey
I love my moon
Look a new kweefling. No
No
We are not doing kweefling. Okay
A pinata vtuber is something I haven't heard of before
um
Maybe gen three should be
Uh stuff that hasn't been done before that would be an interesting concept
I don't know
Oh my god strona, you've now made it to the two month mark and you're already talking about gen three
brov
Brov it takes so long to plan this stuff behind the scenes. Please relax. Okay, please relax. It takes years
It takes small. That was a big glitch there. It relax. It's not that serious. Okay. Goodbye. Mr. Tafly. I don't need you right now
Okay, we're starting to get our money up a bit. This is good. I'm needing a rainy night and I need to do the
Or I need to unlock the flowers actually if I can unlock more. I a monkey. I'm finally in the game
Do you what what viva pinata? Do you identify as
monkey
I if I had to pick a pinata
I want to be like, oh, I'd be like a cool mysterious one
But to be honest, I'm probably gonna be a jameleon because I'm silly and I like a bright colors
Oh, no, the watercress popped its clogs. Well, you've done me a great service, mister. Oh
Well, I might as well sell the watercress head
Because you get more money for that. Are you just floating on the water?
Wait, the cinema key is already in my garden. Wait, hold on. You just caught here. You are monkey nuts
I'm gonna have to buy monkey nuts to try and get them
I have to admit my luck in this game has been really good. Sometimes the AI like refuses to work with you and
Pinatas that come into your garden will like straight up ignore you. Grab us that one two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight. Go
Inhale them all
Oh my god, beaver vtuber confirmed
I can't handle this
My heart's gonna explode
My heart is gonna explode
There is a pink pinata. Yes. Are you a hungry refling?
I can feed you
We're level 22. We're doing it. We're doing it. We're doing it. Oh my god. He had one
Okay, I want to see all seven of these monkey nuts going. Do I make myself clear AI?
Uh, I'm actually gonna check my book
Because that buzzing
hasn't come back
To eat the rip. No, not that one. Sorry
uh
player award
for the pinatas
That buzzing never came back and I don't know why
I might be a requirement of the garden for him to show up and do something
I'm looking I'm looking
Oh
There he is. Sorry. Sorry. Oh a cinemunkey's level seven. We actually want the cinemunkey. Jeez. We're already blasting into the sevens
Right buzzing. What is your show up requirements?
Have five canaries in the garden
Okay
I'm like 99 sure he only ate two hold on where's a buzzing when you need one because if he ate three he would have been mine
Yeah, he's got six
I guess that the game's trying to give us the new pinatas that have also been unlocked. That's the only thing about
The game it can only spawn in so many pinatas that are interested in your garden. So we've got
Like a licotode coming in right now. So it won't spawn like another one
There's only a set amount and I think the buzzing isn't being spawned in right now. Oh
I spoke too soon
It's gonna be a massacre, but I'm gonna get a buzz inch from it. It's gonna be a
murder on the dance floor
You better not get in the way
Any other pinata? I want this buzzing. I want it
Golem time golem time
How many monkey knots four get eaten. This is a mukbang turn around and eat the other four
I want to see you gain weight
I want to see you struggle to eat that last piece and say I'm full and then continue
That's what really gets my rocks off. Keep eating
actual mukbang for real
Gonna burn this goddamn health and red
You may not be a girl
Her architect how dare you
Okay, is that three? No, so there's one more eat one more. I double dog dare you
I double donut dog dare you eat one more
now
Right the second so I can collect that juicy xp when you become a part of my garden. Do I make myself clear?
Can you do that for me little buzz inch?
Go attack someone right now
Look, there's so many and the monkey's walking away from the peanuts. Yes, AI you better kick in and turn back
Turn that butt around and eat those peanuts. Do you understand me? We didn't unlock and you see even the light leveled up
Lawy you're making me work for you. I want it
And he's not locked the gem seat either. Okay. We're probably gonna do petulia next if I can get this cinamonky
And this buzz inch to perish one more
We might have two new
Residents which might push us to the next level, which is what I'm wanting. I really want to start the
Flower farming because that's like really you make a lot of money a lot a lot of money
What's that? We're talking capitalistic strategies and a child's video game about a garden. Yes
Okay, maybe you'll give me a new seed seed us
I can identify every kind of seed with my eyes closed
Just by touching them with
With mine and your nose
What's that? That's a sunflower seed. I don't need a sunflower
Yeah, bam. What else can you give me?
I don't think you want
You should have seen me two days ago had pizza for lunch three days in a row
I was feeling very sick. But how else am I gonna get fat for you real?
Real how else are you gonna get a big tum tum?
Real true based. I don't care what anyone says
Oh
Actually a reflin sent me a marrow and they were like, oh, I'm losing weight because it's not healthy for me
Now, I don't want you to be unhealthy
I just want you to have some trouble on you so I can like jiggle it around and I can feed you and stuff
But I don't want you to be unhealthy. But to the refling that sent that marrow about getting your health together
I'm very proud of you. I know deep down inside. You can do it. It is very hard
But once you get into the rhythm you get you'll get there. So please don't worry. Have faith in yourself
It's a scary journey sometimes as well because hunger
Literally kicks your brain into overdrive and makes like your body be like no, no, no. I need this now. No, no
um protein
Chicken cook chicken fantastic vegetable maxing fantastic
um
All these kind of protein things eggs fantastic that stuff is gonna help you with losing weight for your health
Okay, health first
Health first kink later. I know I'm an architect bro. You can make as much fun with me as you're like
I don't care. I like it. But I want you healthy and happy strong is an architect because she likes to erect things
How are you guys so good at coming up with this? This is annoying me
I'm a scrawny guy, but I got a bit of a belly. Am I handsome enough for mama?
naturally
I like the idea of like jiggling your belly and feeding you and then it's like, oh, what's for dinner?
And then I go take away and then I feed you and and then you order your like main meal
And I'm like, okay, but what side are you gonna get refling?
What side are you gonna get and then I'll be like, oh what drink do you want a milkshake for no particular reason other than
the most calorific
dense drink
Well, you don't need a diet cola refling. Don't be silly
come on
Shawnee wants us to be so big that we need to depend on her to survive
No
I don't want you to perish. I want you I still want you to be healthy and happy, but I do want to go on you
Cartoffel of doom. Thank you for the
The tip and as well as anonymous. Yes, if you've got a little pudge and don't worry if you've only got a little pudge
I'll handle the rest of them here
Watching you grow bigger alongside me
Watching you stuff your face next to me
Okay, I can't talk about it too long because I can I can like kind of imagine it and I like
Ooh, I want it. I want it
Can I want it though?
Kind of real though
Shawnee can't it be mutual? No, I like my small boobies
I don't want big boobies
And if I put weight on I'll get boobies and I don't want boobies
Mama can feed me all she wants, but she better be dessert
Oh
That was smooth. I like that one good one anon. That was smooth
How do you guys keep coming up with this like I want to be able to do that off the top of my head
If you're lucky in one stream, I probably get one good comment that came off the top of my head
Like I don't know how you're doing it
But you do it so well, right? We're gonna sell the blue bells
Because we're making more
I'm
making more
Okay, no, buzzle gum is ours. We're not getting rid of them. Oh, you're awake on your own be a little bit
Is wearing bald glasses. Oh my god. I'm putting glasses on him right now. You can't tell me is it you that do accessories
Oh
Yes, hello pitchy. Yeah, I forgot your name. We are putting glicks on him right now
What glicks do you need? Hold on first select. Uh, what glicks this one?
Wait, that doesn't look like bald glasses
Ah, whatever. Okay. Um, and then done
Let's see where your glicks on. Oh my god, you can see now. I didn't think that you were blind
Poor thing can see now. He's got the drip
Mouth to mouth feeding though. That's peak
You do it with babbies people get surprised
But if you didn't know back in you old days before baby mash food and mash blenders and all that
Um, it's really common for your mum to chew the food for you and then put it in your mouth
Like like spittle it into your mouth
And it's actually good for the baby because it helps with um
Digestion if mum is the dessert. I want to put the icing on her cakes
I want to fill my cream in her twinkie. I want to glaze her doughnut. I can do this all day
What the fuck?
Can you like can I just shrink you down and put you in my ear like giant tests and then you just whisper this stuff
So so then everyone goes like wow strongly really upped her streaming game and I'm just sitting here like yeah
I mean while you're like my little tiny sleeve and I'm a giant test that has you harboring funny things into my ear
Haha, thank you anonymous again for the service. We'd know
No, would you figure it out? There's something like I'm being fed like stuff to say
They're like what the heck strong. He's like coherent and actually making sense. What's going on?
That's funny
I can't believe it. I can't believe it. I have such a tell
I almost watered him by accident there if that monkey can come back or if that um
What's the other one a buzz inch can come back so I can get either one because I want to get them
And then I'm going to do the petunia level up cheat. Who's feeding you?
I mean, I don't I don't mind your spit
Oh, please
No, don't just stare at me come in the gear then you're welcome into my gear then anytime
Honestly, the worldly gigs over there if you need to hang up your clothes and you come
Haha, literally the sun is shining. Please eat one of my birds. I'm begging you
You should just share in brain cells you can shrink me down and put me somewhere else real true giant test Johnny went son
I think I've recorded a giant test one already
Oh my god, he's just standing I'm trying to play it cool and like
You know in pokemon when you want to catch one in a ball and then you pretend you don't
Want it so the rng like works with you. This is literally me like oh
I'm not I'm not looking at the bird on the side of the screen. No what buzz inch
No, I don't care if you join my garden. I'm playing it cool. Okay the desire
Sensor red hot number five is very unhappy. Well red hot more like red shape
You want a shelly bean? Of course you can have a shelly bean. I'll go order one now. I'm order. Sorry
Please tell me you get you know what? I'm actually just going to download the ticktocks to show you them
Instead of being like oh refline you need to go look out for this and this and this. No, I'm just going to straight up
Force you to watch the tick tock. I keep referencing on stream. It's becas take away
and
Okay, I'm going to sell the red hots because we got their achievement. We want it
2000 per red hot is
Oh, we're doing it. Oh my god desire
Oh, you're doing it. We're doing it. Oh my god. We manifested. Oh my god. Maybe manifestation works
Maybe all those girls that believe in it aren't wrong
Oh
It's so hard to get a buzz inch because they're so pernickety. Honestly, you keep saying what you want to do to us
Of course, we can keep coming up with these besides can't come down. Don't want to make a mess on the floor
Oh, yeah, I'm trying to translate that what does that mean? Hold on. I think I'm a bit too slow
Hold on. I don't want to risk me a second. I need to reread that
Keep coming up with these things besides you can't come down. Don't want to make
Come down
Hold on. Wait. Oh, I don't get it. Come down
Come to the floor. Oh like pop play. Is that a pop play reference?
I'm so sorry. I'm not smart enough like come down to the floor
Come on the floor. Oh
I get it. I get it. Okay. Thank you. I don't know. I'm sorry. I didn't get it
Thank you for the tip. I'm so sorry
Oh, look at brown. He is
Oh, you're so bright. Look at that beat. Look at the schnooze you're on that way
You got a big young a big cute note has eaten. You want more birds? You're so vicious
I'm gonna wait. You're only worth 2000. Are you selling because I'm buying give me the nod if you're ready to sell
I thought they were going to be worth way more. He literally destroyed how many birds and he was worth 2000
Rubbish anyway, right. I'm going to sell the birds. I'm going to sell the hops culture
Um
Oh, she caught the shelly bean already. Okay, so the garden's going to be a lot less cluttered, but it's for a good reason
Um, because we're about to do a message
Of
Hello, it's Johnny. How you doing? I'm doing you. We're playing childhood game. I am rambling. I'm also
a misunderstanding um
Things that reflings are telling me because I'm dumb, but like a good dumb not the bad kind
uh, right
What was the plan again?
What was the plan about? I've already forgot. I she forgot um, um
Okay, so we got the buzz inch. We want that monkey to show up. Where is he?
Does he live over here in the forest?
Oh, wait, no, doesn't he climb down? Oh, he climbs down from that hot thing up there. I think or maybe not. Oh, I can't recall
I can't recall a little refling. What's up?
Strani, I am more than happy for you can feed me feed me all of your cake and I will give you some cream
Okay, that's good. That is so good. Thank you so much. Strani cake connoisseur
Uh, I just want to check in and say I'm actually getting a lot of donations
Please keep your money or maybe consider supporting the girls. I don't know what this is a lot of money. Okay
Please do consider supporting them because the girls are putting me right now
Hey strani are you with garner because I'd love to get in your plants
Does that one work as well or am I just um
You want to get in my plant
No, you want to plant something in me see
Did I just did I just out do a refling?
A momo. Thank you for the tip and strani cake connoisseur. Thank you
Strani first world problem. Please give money to the girl. Please hold your money back for azure's donathon
I'm very excited for her to move out smile
Smart shranny. Thank you. I I out I out did a refling
Please clap
Oh, I don't have wait. I don't have clap dot mp3 yet
There's clap dot mp3. I've just played it. Well, I didn't I did that in real life. No
You can't prove it. Why did I hear dinning?
Am I going crazy? Did I not just hear dinning? Is there something bad in the garden right now?
I sounded like the sweet played so close you should have should have said in your bush. Eh, I had a bath. Sorry. Look, I'm not being funny
Just just to prove it
See how there was see how there was no muffling or anything. Yeah, I had a bath
I had a bath
Um, I'm hairless. I'm literally a hairless cat. Okay
There's not any hair on my body right now other than my head and my roof
You know, I could have sworn I heard a bad sweet sound, but I guess not
All right, get rid of the red hawks. You're the red hawks are miserable. Honestly
Sell that and that and that. Okay
Oh no
I knew I heard the doonan. Oh my god, you're being so dramatic though. Look at the way he's like floating in the water
It's okay. You'll be fine
Even though you're right outside his house, which is really dangerous if we don't get there in time
Thank you, mr. Shelly Bean. I will sell you
Thank you
Okay, we got the liquid to it
So you have a smoothie of clam helia. Oh dear. Don't say such things. Oh god my tentacle
Wow
Brian, you must be a top tier gardening tool cause you're my favorite. Oh, okay. That was a good one. That was a good one
That was a classic. Thank you. Kaidon
That was a good one. I'll give you that. That's a classic. Come on. That's a classic. You can't you can't say no to that, right? You
You two are gonna hump. Okay
Okay, you're gonna hump and then we are going to
Watch the egg and as the egg hatches, we're gonna beat it. Okay. I know that sounds bizarre
Why would you want to beat an egg from a piñata that's hatching?
Trust the process. Okay. Trust the process
You have faith in me, right? You trust me. I said hump
I said hump. Did I not want to make myself clear hump right now right in front of me
Oh you
Whoa, we got 20,000 coins. That's so good
Oh
Are you squinting me?
Sean, you're like the most beautiful fields for all
Hi, strongies. Well, uh, Brian. Are you gonna do another fitness stream again?
Yeah, maybe you should partake in some yoga. Don't worry. I'll stretch you out nice and good
I genuinely wholeheartedly thought you were
Wanting another fitness stream and I was like, yeah, of course a bit. Okay. You got me. You win
You win. You got me. Thank you anonymous
Genuinely got me there. I was like, yeah, of course. We'll do another ring fit stream. That was so fun
I just won't overdo it too much this time
Someone pointed out they were like strongy. You're on hard mode and I'm like, oh
That might explain a few things. Yes
um
I've been very silly about uh, yeah, apparently I was on hard mode. So I'm gonna next time we play. We're not going to be on hard mode
Okay
Hey, let's go for another actually fitness stream
Thank you and on for being 15 reminder that snakes have to be what I didn't know that
Huh, that's rather odd. Oh, we get the romance
Oh my god, it's hypnosis. Oh, uh, this is a pinot. I would be are you ready?
Wait, I thought
Is it the other ones that are hypnosis?
I
Could have sworn the snakes were hypnosis. Maybe I'm making that up
It's a serpent like serpent
Want to come to my place and watch corn on my 52 inch mirror
We have a 52 inch mirror. Wait mirror. Oh, it's not okay. I get it. I get it. I get it. I was like
I was gonna say you have a 52 inch tv screen and then it was a mirror. Okay. That was good
Thank you for the tip. That was actually really good
Holy crap
I like the way you keep trying
Even though you don't have the natural talent that I did
Your shovel is even stronger now. We're salty old man. You can't use it properly or you could end up breaking something important
We're salty old man. I'm sorry to say it old man, but you're dust
like too
Um snakes often look like they're fighting when they mate. Wait, is that right? I didn't know that
Yes, I got my comeback
Can you beat the evil people with the shovel? No, you can't there's no way you can prevent Dastardos other than the
Sour pinatas, right? I am going to aimbot this guy right here
Do not look away when he's ready to hatch we give him one big whack. Okay
Snakes can mate for many hours
What why is it?
I feel like in nature. It's like so quick
Like whenever you see like a documentary it's like boom it's over and like if you've ever seen the way fish do it
Fish are literally Hail Marion
The female and the male will go side by side as fish
And then the female releases the eggs and the the male releases the ink at the same time
And then they just hope that it works via water. It's insane. Honestly
Um, it's quite funny, but I mean, you know, evolution will find a way. Whoa. Look at the yellow guy
He's actually really cute. I like his pattern type
Nature comes in two forms. Wham, bam. Thank you, ma'am or four hours later
Some species also have huge snakes
Oh
Well, we're getting educated in this stream getting
This game with no, no, no, no, no, no, no in the middle of the egg growing
Please I hope the garden's paused. What do you need? I think he needs five
romance
Five
pinata romance things I think
Okay, we did it. Oh my god, we did it. That was the worst timing
That couldn't have gone any worse
Don't ever do that to me again
Oh my goodness
I had a heart attack. I knew that was coming. I knew that timing was awful. Right, we're gonna make
We actually can't go to the next one. So I'm gonna sell the serpent
So I know they just like had a child and stuff, but it's time to go the banks are winning this one
That's terrible. Don't stop joking about that
Well, actually, you know what?
Sorry, but as commoners unironically have to make jokes about it as if like it makes anyone happy
That the fucking banks get to win everything. So I was I'm going on around again. So stop. Stop. Stop. It's Johnny. I can't help it. Okay
Something's annoying me
And I oh no, I've gone the wrong place now
I'm getting so distracted. Right. Hold on. Let me focus up. What what's up, Johnny?
Uh, viva pinata
Oh, she's actually hosting a sale for once. Thank you
Oh, we got a nightshade seed these take forever to grow
So we're just gonna plant it let her do its thing
It we are gonna do the chili myth
Do we need to do it? I mean we have a lot
You know what? No
We're not gonna do the chili method
What we're gonna do right now
is
Be good boys and girls
And we're gonna do the pitch
In your method. What's your name paper pits? Well, no, that's not your actual name. What's your name again?
Oh, you startled me. No, I wasn't sleeping on the job. That's not a bad idea
She's actually a nick of each of you
Uh, right. Okay
We are gonna get
seven
Chickens, okay
And then we're gonna get an award for master romancing them
See just like that. We didn't even do anything. They just showed up in the garden another here
Look at them
And then we got an award for having them as residents and then next
We're gonna sell them. We're gonna sell five of them and then we're gonna make them hump
And just like that you get insane xp. You can do that with all of the paper pits in her shop
Okay, this is how you throw yourself ahead with xp
Now with a cluckle, there's a secret achievement
Um, where if they hatch an egg
They give you an achievement. Okay, so we are gonna make them kiss. Okay, so we need corn
Which is fine with me. It's calm
Speaking of food items, I'm actually getting
A bit peckish. Do we need to get some food in us riefling?
And I need to I've no said hydration check. I hope you guys are hydrating as well
I've been hydrating via a can of cola. So that doesn't count
That doesn't count. I've not been doing very well in the the older cola. Um, who where's that bumblebee?
Sweet little bumblebee. Give me a thousand chocolate coins. Oh, I'm rich and I've fallen down the capitalism pipeline
There you are. Thank you for the thousand. You will help us with future endeavors. Amen. Um
Once those corn grow, I can't remember what else the chickens need
A bit peckish just after getting chicken. Stop. I love chicken
I actually have a subway sandwich in the fridge right now. I might grab it
But yes, please do remember to hydrate. Am I allowed to quickly go grab it?
Mmm
Rant and straw. No, please don't stop. Grape for me more. I mean rant to me some more
Riefling you're saying the quiet part. Rooster maxing a bit peckish. Honestly real. Oh, sorry. My cursor went on screen there
How unprofessional is this?
Do we have monkey nuts or do they expire?
Now just so he's no being a weirdo. I'm gonna buy a few more monkey nuts
I know it's expensive. I know we're getting charged out the wazoo
But I'd rather we unlock him because it's a level seven pinata
We don't actually have it or a tier seven or a rank seven. I don't know how you want to say it, but
But um, yes, he's coming
And if we unlock him we'll get quite a lot. Oh
Please go away. Please go away. I'm gonna pay you 20 bucks 300 to go away. Thank you. Please don't ruin my garden
We will get that cutlass very soon. I don't think we've unlocked it yet. I do a pot. Where did that monkey go?
You're attacking the tree when there's monkey nuts on the ground
Don't be so selfish
There's no bread in my garden. Sorry little guy. Okay you eat the corn and tell me what else you need
Wake up. It's the first of the month
A pumpkin seed. I can do that. That's not a problem at all
He's what monkey return to monkey
For the first time I have sent a spicy marrow. I didn't inspire you real true
Oh, what audio am I doing after stream? I don't know
Maybe I'm just going for it. Maybe I should just send it. I'll just send it
Wow
Unless you guys want me to say something. I don't know
Okay, then eat the pumpkin seed
We got the monkey return to monkey return to monkey and we leveled up and we leveled up
Level 24 I was gonna say 23 right you two kiss each other right now on the lips
That's right. You better kiss. Okay after we've hatched the egg. I'll go get some food. Okay
You do inspire. Is that what we're calling it now? Oh, you've inspired all over me strongy
Okay, so we've now just added an element where we can get blown up to
Are you squid in mirror? I'm going for it
I just wanted something your eyes hypnotize us, but I can imagine every part of you can make reeflings addicted
Your drool tasting sweet from a passionate kiss your cream from your plan being an addictive treat
That honestly sounds hot. Oh
Oh, this is for the audio. Okay. Okay. Okay
Wait, you want me to make it not just an audio you want me to like
Show my model at the same time
No, because the face is going to be like
I can't show the model at the same time because my face is going to freaking show it. That's too embarrassing
I can't do that. That's too embarrassing
Thank you anonymous for the tips. Oh my god. I don't think I can do that
Me right now
I'll do the
Strongly do you need help in the garden because I would love to plough your back field and fill it with seed. Yes
That's it. You did it. Wait, you called yourself field worker
Oh
Oh, they're doing a little dance together
Are they cutting all their country bumpkin chickens? Oh, this is so cute
Basically whiz. Thank you for becoming a member. Please enjoy the emotes
That you have access to now and thank you field worker for the tip of the hilarious thing. Okay. Okay. Okay, right
Don't forget strongy. Don't get distracted. I'm a little bit distracted, but don't get distracted. Okay
This chicken I need to select it and when the egg comes
Where is she there? She's coming. She's coming. Okay
The chickens can hatch eggs faster
That's their like secret ability a few pinatas have secret abilities like the taffy can make fertilizer from fruit
Um only not vegetables
But they can make a fertilizer. Okay, so move the egg
Select the chick. No. No, they're both trying to go in the house right now. Nope. Not happening
You need to
Let me select you and open up this egg right now
Set on the egg and open up and then give us that achievement. I know it's coming
We got 20 G's
We bro, we are swimming and gaming's gamer score
We are swimming in it. Really legend. Thank you for the faces would make me ink hard. No, my face would be like
Like no, that's silly. You didn't even see me
I'll be frog blinking so hard because my eyes are like rolling into the back of my skull
I'll be like frog blinking. I don't want to frog blink. That's some bad way. Oh, they have each other to cuddle
Uh, right. Okay. Oh, I just remembered
He eats
cluckles
Oh
Look at the bees. They're so organized
I'm like 99% sure you need to eat a cluckle if I'm not mistaken. Mr
Don't think I'm not on to you darling
I'm gonna leave the cluckles in the garden because my brain is telling me that they
Another day of zero action. Okay. Yeah cat snakes. Okay
One two three four five six seven
go
Give me that achievement
Resident award. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go
And then master romancer so we can sell five one two three four five
And just like that
Hi strony. I just started subscribing to your alternative audio
I listened to the one you did with your team quick question
Does your mouth actually get wetter when you stick something inside it?
When I record I can use a prop or I can use my finger
But when stuff enters my mouth my saliva glands
Actually, some of you might have this or maybe it's just a me. No, it's not just a me thing because I looked it up and I'm fine. Um
I
Actually when if I don't eat for a really long time
Um, and then puts like food in my mouth my mouth squirts out like so much saliva
So quickly that it hurts
Like so, yeah, it's actually like a real thing with me. I'm actually gonna sell sin a monkey
I feel bad because he's just been chilling on his own, but
Uh, what do you need has eaten a ball eaten? You're gonna get a fur ball you you figure
I'm imagining things now
We got a cake loss home and it's less than a hundred points. That's not bad price. Well, I don't think it's a bad price
There we go
Uh, did that guy enter the lobby enter the lobby enter the card in
I thought that was normal. No, like it hurts so much. I guess we both have it towels towels everywhere when recording
You're laughing. I have two towels in my recording booth. I'm not even kidding
I have two towels to wipe everything
Like after I record
I was actually as a donut on reward. I was gonna take a picture of my recording booth
There's so many things in it that it would have to get posted on the alt
But the recording booth has like a lot in it
But I do genuinely have two towels for any stuff
That made did he really just go home the evil?
A pinata
Where did he go? You were here is that is he on the perimeter?
No, that's a fudge hog
There's two fudge hogs tonight. No, I don't need a fudge hog
Hmm
It's trying to how much for a bottle of saliva. Oh, you're gonna drink it. No, I don't
I mean, it's different if you open up your mouth and let me spit in it, but
Drinking and my spare you want to drink my spittle
Okay, this is a flower so we can overwater it and then we can put loads of fertilizer. Maybe a little
replaying
I must not encourage you to do a bad thing
But well, if you're at work anyway, why not?
Um, thank you so much anonymous for enjoying the alternate of ideals
um
Hope last night's one went well
It was a a unique plot. I do like my unique plot. Um
I definitely say probably in the later months. I might kind of calm down on doing like a really specific topic
But I like that because then I was like, oh my record is one minute 58
I can't I'll need to find the freaking video and share it and then you guys would be like
Wow, you really do like the back door and I'll be like, yes
Um, you've been encouraging us for like an hour. Stop you. I'm such a bad
I end up spitting while talking to my friends. It's so annoying
my pool
Pool I know I love it
No, when I get excited, I'm not allowed to talk because I start spitting everywhere
But that's the best thing about being a youtuber is that you can't watch the spit flying at my mouth when I get excited
Ah
So I don't have to be embarrassed when I get hyper
It's so easy
Oh my god, did you fucking see that shondal got bloody banned seven day suspension on twitch
Bro, I'm actually fucking heated so I'm actually region. It's literally her birthday as well
Sorry, sorry, my brain just kind of like flashed that in my head and I'm like, oh my god, you're right
Let's get region read against the machine saw his twitch
But uh, she better been on ban. I better finish the stream and then twitch is like, oh, sorry xd. It was an oversight xd
That's what I want to see. It's literally her freaking birthday
Let her have something. Oh my god. She just came back after a break. Like I have something anyway
Seven day down on her birthday seven day ban on her birthday
At least let her fucking like enjoy her birthday week god damn
Wait, it was her feet that did her in
Stop really?
Oh, no, there's a pretzel, but I don't want them to come in the garden
It's eating a mouse malo right. I'll go get you a wee mouse malo
She just got back from a mental health break too. So I don't want to do her any good
Hopefully she just sees it as frustrating and not like a negative thing like against her. Does that make sense?
It's not a negative thing against her. It's the freaking thing just being silly
Jeff Bezos let her earn money
Just Jeff Bezos on twin
Hold on a minute. What do you want? I knew it. Oh my god. We're literally so far ahead
Oh, he's so angry
Honestly, why didn't they just hire me to voice act this?
What was the game 2006? Did I even have vocabulary? No
I was a sore child as well
Okay, right. We're about to get him
Amazon on switch. Okay. Okay
There's dogs are doing gamer subs flavor strongy's sweet saliva. Honestly
Gamer yes, come on strongy for 10% off a gamer subs. I forgot to add the little graphics
And I think I'm covering I've accidentally covered up the ubu market one as well
I refling tweeted me their ubu market merch and oh my god. I'm gonna cream
I'm like, bro. I want to wait. Are you in two cluckles for a friend? I'm gonna sell the other ones since we don't need them
You just killed two chickens for any reason. Yeah, I'm not bad
Make that sound while you are with me
Yeah, she remembered wait, what did I remember?
Oh the code the code. Okay, sorry
Oh, that's what I should do. You're you. Oh wait, I need to message them
No, surely they don't care how you promote it
Surely it's like a
Oh, just promote it how you want because like if I made an audio where I was having fireworks
And and saying use code strongy at gamers
Could I in trouble for that or would they be like genius marketing sales are up keep keep at it you slag
They pat me on the back. They're like I keep up your slag. That's great. Keep going sales are up. I mean in theory
I mean that reminds me I just bought him his keychain and their sweater. Oh, thank you for supporting the girls
As always all the merch goes to them
Oh
Yeah
This is you canonically it's not you're a war type but canonically
It's yeah, and I love you so much
I don't want to pinch your little cheeks and I want to pet you and touch all over you
Cause you're so cute and I give you a tail and all that and I give you little cheeky wikis. Look oh
Oh
You're playing maincraft looking for diamonds. I'm in the same main looking for mainers
New idea sponsor gamers like oh, oh, dude. Honestly, yeah
Oni viva pinata
Fine
But I could cough on you and you'd fall over. Why are you so nasty?
Wait, hold on. I need to change the name. Give me a second. Give me a second. This is wifling
E
l
n g and then right bumper. Nope
How do I do a love heart?
Oh
Oh, no, it doesn't register the the the symbol right? Okay, hold on
Let me get rid of the number then because it just looks like I've called you wifling number three
That doesn't make any sense. Oh, oh wait, hold on dragonfly time
Oh
I think I know what seed we just unlocked a brussel seed a brussel seed
Seed the the brown one the brown ones in the background. I think we've just unlocked that because a dragonfly likes them
Brustle
Trying to strike a chord and it's probably a minor. Hey, that's probably a minor
Honestly wiflings. It's time to go to a party. Are you ready wifling?
Off to a party you go
Where you going? Where you going? No one's no one. Oh, no, you're at a party. I hope you're having fun
What happened to the first two I R worded them too hard
They look like the meme for that ladies at the side of the bed and there's like wrappers on the bed
That's what happened to the first two during their life force
Oh, it's my little wifling. Oh wifling
You can't
Please my heart can't take how adorable you are wifling
I can't handle it
Look how happy you are to be next to me. Will we pimp you out? Let's see if we can find any outfits that might
uh attract
Which might make you more confident. You're such a confident boy. Would you have a little daisy in your
Oh my god, whoa, we got the deal. What we got the dlc dress up
I didn't know there was fucking microtransactions in viva pinata
A conquerific helmet because it's both by rare studios
Oh my god, we have the dlc
I didn't even know they had microtransactions in the game
Okay, I don't think there's a hat that complements. Yeah. Whoa, you can just be a warrior. I'm like warrior
Okay, we're not gonna make you the police
We if anything, you're the one who needs the police. No, you're not having giggly eyes
Uh, my glasses aren't here. Could maybe put your butt caterpillar eyebrow. No wifling. That's not what you look like
You silly billy
um
Would you have an ear pierce thing? I don't think you would have an ear pierce. No, I don't think
um a nose
You have a mustache. Why why yes, I'm just an innocent wifling
I don't do anything naughty. Maybe the mustache
Maybe the mustache not that I see you with the mustache, but I feel like
I feel like you would come back into the asmr booth and be like, oh, I'm a completely new wifling
Please don't kick me out. Oh, do you want a bow in your butt?
No, I don't put your bow in your butt. I might give you an accolade though. Yeah, I'll give you an accolade
Yes, okay. I bought that one. What about your feet? See you see you need shoes. He's on. Oh, you got them fresh day
What is that snow shoes? No, you don't need shoes
Flaming co shoes. What is flaming co? I don't know. I don't think you need jays. I think you're fainter shoes
Uh
I've got bracelet. No, you don't wear a bracelet a prisoner bracelet
I mean if you want to do the prisoner hopefully
a bing a bingo bingo
a neck
Oh
Oh, I'd put a collar on you so fucking quick
Uh
Oh red. It's either the red one or the bell
I'm tempted for the bell. So I know when you're awake to come and milk you
I'm tempted. I think the bell suits your purple better. Okay. I'm gonna put the bell
So I know to come and get you when you're awake
She knows when you're awake
She knows when you've been good or bad. So be good for goodness sake. Okay. You definitely do not have a girl
What was that one thing I was considering the mustache? I'll give you a mustache. So it's like oh, oh no
I won't I won't okay. I think I've given you an accolade and a bell. So I know when you're awake. I think that's you
The milk and why not the collar and the handcuff?
Anya. Oh my god, look at you
Refling do you want to show me your party trick darlin?
If he goes and finds a romance sweet we get 20 g's. Good luck replaying. Uh, oh
You've you've phased out that rock real quick
Now night shade takes forever to grow but we are gonna hopefully try and get the thing done in one
Oh, hold on didn't starting want to fetch something
Oh food for me. I'm a wee bit distracted. Hold on
Uh, right you have you eaten a mouse mallow? No, I've just inspected something. I've inspected a happy sweet my bad
right you
Wait, you've not drank a bottle of milk or killed or eaten not killed
Uh, let's very quickly plant these and hopefully they grow in time. I need to pimp out the garden again
It's getting a bit
Oh, there's a you you're in my garden. Wait. Why are you are you in my garden? Hold on
Are you in my garden or not? Are you just are you teasing me?
You need 20 square feet of water. Have I not done that?
I think that is about to be eaten good
What about you have a bottle of milk you milk now
You why are you not? Oh, you need a mouse mallow as well. Oh
Oh, it's no one had a mouse. Well, okay. I'm learning ring my bell
Okay, okay, no
No, no, no, I don't need that
I promise you I went over one. Ah, well, we'll just have to release the catch and release
Well, it's called catch and release. Okay. Did you know that the statistics of a fish surviving after a catch and release is really low
Because it's like the roof of its mouth has literally been destroyed smile
Most people don't know that I think uh
No, that's bad to do it or anything
Oh my god, reflin
Oh my god, I need to make your house
Okay, refling darling. Can you go try and find a roman suite for me? I'm gonna go build you a house. Okay
I'll build you the farm you
My baby, there's my baby's house stretch and hydration check
First I must make your house. I have made your house. Okay. I'm gonna go very quickly grab my subway
Please grab some juice or water or whatever. Uh, I don't need to mute
Because well, I'm not going to the toilet if I was going to the toilet of mute because the toilet's right other side
I'm looking for diamonds or something
No, see I got you
Oh
Thank you broly legend for the stretch check stretch after stream got it
I have subway
I don't normally probably that much. Thank you. I poor. Ah, you're too late. I poor. I'm already back
I am back spitting on the
Let me get all comfy in my blankie again
It's willy
Hi, willy
Oh my god, my b.o. Is fucking honking
It's mariny and every time I lift my arms up. I'm like, I'm getting a shower after this one
Uh, honestly, don't mute for the toilet. Ah, no not until is there does her little peeler
a moment
I shan't be the one
Uh
Don't shower
Showering because she hates that. No, I reek. I literally reek like I cannot stand the scent of myself right now. I'm so bad
Like it's there's funny ha ha like oh, I've not showered or whatever
But I forgot to put deodorant on and it's been marinating and and I'm like, oh
Oh a badge sickle
Oh, hello little guy. Unfortunately. I don't have what he wants
I'm opening up my my sandwich. I can't remember what one this is. I have two signatures
Oh, okay, go go go
learning learning
Okay, the hunters caught the pinot. Let's go grab it
band from shower
Oh, wait, I don't want to sorry. Wait. I forgot
Why send me to fetch it release it back into the yes. I'm sorry. I meant to click the mouse
Refling's love when you girl stink girl stink girls are stinky but in a good way
Any stinker didn't oh I had two moth ropes without realizing
Unfortunately, our money has gone down considerably because we're doing the patchouliah
Thing it does cost quite a bit. What does your home look like?
Oh my god, you have blankies outside of your home. Oh weflin you got cookies you want me to make your cookies
Oh what you got is that a speakey? What is that? You got cabbage you want me to make you some cabbage?
Oh my god, you eat you eat animal food just like me remember that time
I confessed that I used to eat cat food as a child because I thought it would turn me into a cat
Refling you did the same thing
I didn't know that
What's inside your house? Oh should I send you into your house or are you not? Oh refling
Hey wakey wakey refling you need to go in your home so I can spy on you inside your home for no particular reason
Oh, baby
And you go, huh? Are you climbing into your home?
Oh you in your home now you're gonna have a nice sleep in your home. Yeah, let's look inside. Okay
What you doing?
Oh, you're not asleep yet. You silly belly. You need to go sleep and don't get your tail on fire either
Okay, I'm gonna be scared for you. It looks like it's fine
Cat food story I confess that as a child I ate wet cat food
Um because I thought it was gonna turn me into a cat. Don't ask me why I just thought it was so I used to like eat
But it wasn't like I've replaced meals with it or anything. It wasn't like that
It was just like a few bites here and there until eventually, you know, I stopped the behavior
Hey wakey wakey cats. I know you're tired, but up you come
Someone needs to eat a mouse. Is it you?
It's you that was incredibly lucky
Please be up this mouse right now
That's the only thing about the
Wait, why is this taking so long to grow?
You're a rubbish hunter. Try again. Go again. No. Oh, she's going up the tree
Okay, I just kind of parkoured up the tree a little bit but it's gone away again
She's so testing
But what if you're one bite away from becoming a cat? Stop because my dumb ass will be like, oh my god, real
Oh reef and I need to send you out on another journey again. Okay. I need that little sweetie
Try again. Okay. I believe in you. Oh, no, don't get sad because the piña is about to be eaten. I need it for romance
Right, I'm gonna take a bite of my food. Okay. I'll be a saja. I'm gonna do a big bite
That 99% of autistic girls stop eating cat food before they become a cat. That's terrible
Oh
Is it thank you Mars?
Did you manage to find that reef one? You're dead
Oh
Oh, I'm choking but
Right, okay. I'm fine. Um, you're dead. You got this sweet dropped it and then went for the candy. You're so fucking cute
You're like hell, yeah, I deserve the sweet treat. Of course you deserve the sweet treat
My little baby back. Okay
I'ma I'ma keep eating
You're total to be eating the cat food. I think I was like four years old or something
I was quite young
How about a cat food eating stream?
It's not fit for human consumption apparently
I mean, maybe I don't a thumb reward would be that. How was the cat food?
Controversial take it wasn't that bad
I don't know what cat nibbles are like though. I never ate nibbles. I ate the weight food
Hmm
Usually I'm off the opposite opinion, but scrawny absolutely can talk with her mouth
Oh, yeah, you should see me when I've got your tentacle on mama. It's still easy
The texture of the wet stuff terrifies
Is it like sure not no I had a I think it was like either chicken or beef cube type thing
Hmm
It's meat waste so it tastes like meat. Yeah, basically wait what grew
Something grew. Okay. Watch half live. We've got a oh we grew this snap dragon flower. That's lovely
I
Forgot how hungry I was until I started eating whips. I always do that like I'm like, oh, yeah
Wait a minute. I need help. Oh the cats gonna do something together. Hold on. I'm playing one handed. So sorry if it's a bit funny
Okay, they're gonna do their thing
Oh
How's Gimli and Beagle?
Gimli
What am I to do? Oh my god, can I do this one handed or Danny to
Oh shit. Oh my god. I'm so skinny. I'm so skinny
Oh, I did it. Um, Gimli's actually really distraught. My dad is gone. She was behaving so funny
But she's had up. She's like doing her big sleep right now
and Beagle
wasn't too bad
And but they were really they're really unhappy that my dad is going and I'm like, oh, sorry
Him
Mommy you need to listen to your tummy before the clam. I just don't realize I'm like, oh I'm having so much fun
I'm like, oh wait a minute. I need to like hydrate and eat. I'm like, oh, I'm always dehydrated also
Me has like one bottle of water for an eight hour stream
I've had one sip out of my water
Wait a minute. I need to survive honestly real real true in me
Okay, I got a word. Oh level 27
We're starting to drink and eat get those nutrients
I can imagine Strani coming back from her workout and the refling wanting to get a taste of her clam after it
Has marinated inside a yoga pants and her sweat
Thank you for the tip Arnaud. No
Imagine the smell literally
Hmm
I knew I had an extra mouse
My game is being salty clam literally though
Oh, I finally grew a pinot is about to be eaten who?
Who
Who is he in oh a task life
Why is it so
I've seen some good quality tools in my time, but yours is really impressive
I don't think your shovel could get much stronger. It's tough enough to break almost anything. Okay. Okay
Um, right
Uh, okay. Yes, it was a task life. Oh, no, I don't have the thing for him
He wants a swan
Sorry, I keep talking with my phone
He wants a swan, but I don't have it. So I'm actually gonna be a naughty boy
I'm going to the shop and buy the tower of sorrow piece for him
The opening hours of pay off and we got a new seed. What did we get? We just got a banana seed. So what's this seed?
A bull rush
Is that what this actual name is called?
I'm gonna shove a few around here. I'm gonna pimp the swamp out a little bit
Marinate is such a strong word strong air fresheners
I don't think I'd be freshening up anything
I'll be adding to the stank of the the the room you're in
Or your car wait sold out how?
Because he's not entered my garden yet
I'm just drawing a gap in about the game while the reeflands are hypnotized by the accent real truth
No lies detected. I'm gonna level up all these little brushless things. Oh, I should do the banana tree actually
Well, it's not ready for it. The trees are a bit different
They have to you have to like do it at a certain time for a tree or the trees like
No, I'm like, oh I was a bit too early there
That's good enough as long as it covers my own stink. Oh, not all of us for one max and hold on a minute
Okay
I'd finish
My half sandwich. I'm sorry for the rustling
You said bye for freeze cuttlefish crawls. That's so good
Hmm
I have seen this candle company because they partnered with hi, baby
They partnered with
Fua
the Neko
And I've seen it like about and I'm like, oh, I'm sure it's like
All legit and that it's just like such a funny concept because mine would be like what lemon
Uh, right. She is going home. So unfortunately this banana tree is gonna perish without me
stepping in
So I'm just gonna over water it on purpose
It would be called cuttlefish clam slam real true
I could not wait to play Elden Ring again
Um, I'm actually needing to play a game with sin. We need to pick a game, but not pick one
I may tell her to pick are we smart if the millionaire stream goes well
I'm gonna tell her to play our a us like we'll play. Are you smarter than a fifth grader?
Or whatever the other equivalent was
um
And
Then we'll shock each other if we get it wrong. I think that would be an easier
All of you fighting over the clam and I'm just back here enjoying the
real
Thank you
Actually real. Thank you sleepy fan ink
The clam slam is a blessing before you go into war. Oh, no, everything's popping
The only annoying thing about stuff popping is because you have to like
um
Refertilize it if you want it to be like a big one. Does that make sense?
Is that english? Should I just speak english there? Actually, I'm gonna replant a third one
Um
Thank you for the super chat
Are you smarter than a wiefling? Is it cool up?
Can I play with you guys and we like answer the same question? I will go feral
I will go feral if that's true in real
So I'm itching my face out of itchy face
um
If if if
Um
Azura normally starts at 10 a.m
At time
So it's a two hour warning. Amy if she's streaming today should be starting
When I don't know in five minutes
When will we find out the chest stream?
Uh, it must be next week. So I'm gonna there's a multiplayer game next week
I picked fortnite, but if you guys hate it, I can swap it
I didn't know what to do. Amy isn't on today. Okay
Strawny being a feeder and about stuff. She wants to shove things and the reason's not that we shoved something in another end realtor
Amy's off today. Okay. Okay. Okay. Um
Well can redirect into mercy anyway because it's a endurance stream or well
I mean, it's been a while since I've done actual endurance stream
But like this is just uh, let me ease into it. Let me see how it goes ever played stardew valley. I have it
No, I have and I tried to get into it
but
It was
I don't I think I was playing it wrong or something. I don't know
I think it's one of those games where I couldn't stream it because I would be too quiet
um
Like it's one of those kind of games
As I'm fucking dying right now
um
I'll warm up endurance stream
Yeah, like it warming me up to our 12 hour marathons again because I need to get back to you
Uh, I will say one thing about the shorter streams
Like I could go to the shops with my dad and all that like I didn't feel too tired
And like we made some like really yummy food together like we had a chicken pie and veggies
Like the second last night. I think he was here. Um
And it was just like really nice
um, and like he made me steak and that and
Obviously when I stream long, I'm like, oh, but I don't have time for anything
Like I don't have the energy to go out say because I'm like trying to you know help the girls who do this or
the stuff behind the scenes and
Type thing and I don't have like enough time to like do that all for myself
So I just end up ordering like takeout and that which isn't
It's not very good for me, but
A chicken pot pie. I think that's what you guys call it
It's just like chicken in a pie
Is that what you call it pot because it's like a pot
I don't know if you're gonna play no build just play it FPS
I was gonna do no build fortnight. I think I can get you into my lobby if I'm not mistaken
Or did I make that up?
Right, we'll sell the kitty cat. What was that? I saw that. Um, I'm gonna sell the kitty cat
um
And then we'll do the next animal in her shop. It got peas and carrots too. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I had that good stuff in it
Yes, I had like vegetables inside it too. It was very nice
um
I think you have to add people on friends the epic game
Uh, I know people love to shit on apex, but apex have lobbies like no way that turns rot in the moment
I hover over it. Don't be so red
Don't be so red
Okay, let me get rid of these monkey nuts because I don't want them to go away
Actually, I might sell the trees the trees have
Have done their purpose which was to get me a monkey and I got it so
I hate when they get sad when I sell a tree like brov
You are not that like you are not that in love with the tree. I assure you right. I think we need
One more tree. It doesn't really matter what it is
Maybe I need two banana trees. I might need two banana trees. Can I interest you in something seedy?
Have you tried that healthy food quick service that ships to you?
um
I think they're um
Isn't that much cheaper, but I think there's something about them being like a really big don't
I don't have 16
16 water 16 percent water
I'm gonna have to extend the pool
I thought I had 16 percent water
um
Oh, I know how to create a reefing and spore stop. I will place spore. I'm not even kidding you
I will add it to the roster if you know how to tell me how to make a freaking reefing. I'll go absolutely mental
I'll go feral
A really big what I don't know. I've already forgotten what I was talking about. I'm sorry
Why why are you who are you to tell me why are you squidding me right now again? Yeah
Strongly after a hour of very sweaty exercise in a warm room. Oh your cake would taste divine
I
Think of I think I've got you under a little too good because oh my lord
If you think sweaty cake tastes good
I've hypnotized you too hard
I've broken you a little bit with that one have to I cooked a little too hard with that one chief
Okay, we're gonna just try and expand the water to see what this crocodile. Oh, he's who are you fighting with you wet far?
Oh
Oh, that's right. He sends workers home
As if a rough a ruffian is no no as if you are showing there's two of you
Just as
Just
Wait, I thought there was like a cutlass thing
As if two ruffians show up in my garden whilst I'm having a fight with a freaking sourpina 300 quid
Fuck off you 300 quid fuck off. He's literally gonna spit dirt in my puddle. I'm not even kidding. Oh, no. He is going away
Yeah, there. This is what they do. They like randomly freaking
Bro, what have I got? Sorry. There's a there's a pinata here
14 percent. I don't even have 14 percent. I'm working on it. I'm working
14 percent gosh, you're so
I've got a jameleon out of nowhere. It's all breaking out now. It's all happening now
This is what what you thought the exciting streams were when people are on fps shooters and going crazy and getting all these crazy kills
No, it's viva pinata, baby. When you get notification after notification, how can you possibly keep up?
You're trying to get a new resident pinata. You're trying to deal with the fight. You're trying to turn
Uh, a sour pinata into a good pinata. I mean come on. What more do you want?
The excitement the rush the thrill of viva pinata
Good afternoon, my friend today's just race by hasn't I love it. I love it. Thank you for entertaining me
This isn't this isn't something like such a goof when I go
Right
You cats you're out. I've done one. No, right. Buzzer gum. You're out as well because you're in my way
Right, we're gonna get make our money back
On the cats and we're gonna sell the cats hoos
So the cats can't cry that sold their house because they all get we sad
Right, you're currently eating. What is the last item he needs? I have no idea. I cannot tell you
You want a shelly bean again
What's so popular about shelly beans at parties?
Don't have any idea what's going on. Oh, no, you never had a chance to play it
You know have
It's just chaos and level I'm just trying to level up the petals because then I can get more
pinatas unlocked
um
And all that jazz eat third. I don't know what the third thing he needs is and I'm getting nervous. I don't have it on standby
Oh, look, I'm standing up on his tail. Oh, you're so pretty. I love
You're goofy boy
Oh
Can someone look up let a toad
Transformation and tell me what berry is because I don't want to poison him
If I don't girl you need to water this tree as you walk away from the withering tree
Yeah, you're you're in trouble. You're done for
I know there's so much stuff that needs watered right now, but oof you're challenging me
Farmville but with an animal crossing twist
This came out way before viva pinatas more hardcore than doom eternal. Exactly. Thank you
I'm gonna pop that there. I've actually just seen we have a girl you walk
You are walking past all these things that need it. Okay, you are getting sold because you're a wee bit of money
Which I need because we're about to do the next thing. We need a jelly bean
Did I order? I did order a jelly bean. I can never remember feeding a nightshade berry and then hitting it got it
Right, what do you want has eaten three water lilies? Okay, you'll never guess what I have in the garden
Please don't walk out of the garden
Please attack the plants and eat the water lilies because I know you can do it. Um
A nightshade. Okay. Oh got an award for growing a banana tree
Okay, okay nightshade berry nightshade berry nightshade
I doubted myself. I shouldn't have I can't believe it. I doubted myself
But deep down. I know I'm an absolute dweeb when it comes to my childhood game
I'm sorry. I ever did that to myself
Okay, and then basically
And then walk them
It's a very strange transformation
Oh, whoa, he's like is he the hypnosis one?
He's a lack of tongue
And we're level 30 in the garden for
You want to eat how much?
Four that's
Insanity
I can't believe xbox is too scared to make a leap up now funny. You mentioned that I saw whispers of it when there
Is that convention that went by? I don't know if it was an xbox only convention. Oh, we got the achievement challenger
I think this has done all the boxes. So we don't have to do the boxes if we don't want to
um
Are you I was about to say are you mine?
Hi, baby
Are you coming aboard all aboard the reef link farm?
Not to be confused with gen 3's mouse conductor from wheeler
Little roast head. Oh, yeah, give me that head
21 achievements
I forgot about my other sign which oh, this is why I can't play my game. Hold on
Well, that's a messy sign which oh my god, there's like cream ever bed. No ranch everywhere. I've got ranch on the sign which I'm so american
Oh, let me get a the salad and then push it on a ranch on it and then negate the whole point of the salad
Yeah, let me go
Me if I'm in america
Actually, the girls were saying if I ever came to america they're taking me to azura in particular
It was like I have so many places to take you if you ever come to america and I'm like, bro
I need to grow some balls and stop having to be wrong. Okay. I'm gonna take a big bay. Let me rotate the camera
So there's stuff to look at in the garden
Oh, look at that beautiful. Oh, it's done. It's very dark in the garden, but don't worry about it. Okay big bay
Oh
Hey level 31
You got a cheese piece, what does that mean? I got
spicy chicken cheese with salad and ranch
And just normal bread. I know people go a bit crazy over the bread, but I just like normal like plain bread
There's a fan made successor to biva pañata
Being made called return to parody. Wait is it on it right now?
I will boot that set up
Thank you for hanging. Good night. Please rest well again if you're
Lurking and hanging on by a thread. Please don't worry. This is an endurance stream
Please get the rest you need to do or do that little activity you need to do
Do you need to go and make your bed or change your sheets? I'll still be here if you go do that now
You need to get yourself a glass of water. I'm still gonna be here
Do you need to open up anything you need to do for your college assignment? I'm still gonna be here
I'm not out yet
Can you hear the cucumber in my toes?
Oh
Are you eating that foot long because I can give you one foot free
I want to be here. Anyway, I'm tired and strongly recharge his name
I love when the reeflands are like currently watching you in 1.5
So I can catch up and I'm like, oh my god. The dedication isn't saying like, thank you
I'm so glad that like I can appeal to you in that way
Oh the big jelly beans right there in the screen
No, this game really is fantastic
No, do you want a bite too? Do you want me to spell it in your mouth?
Baby bird video
Oh, it's a funny flavor in this one. I'm not sure I like it as much as the other one
No
Feed me like a bird
Two times speed strongy is a tree. I feel like it's just nonstop. Yeah, but
Like if you speed me up the funny thing is you can probably identify when I'm making an ink joke
Because my voice will be
Like that's how you'll tell in times for like fast forward
That if I've got like a joke coming out of me like that
I've actually not had subway in years. This is like the first time going back to it
I had
a really bad subway in Scotland
And it just completely put me off it
for ages
But it's a bit healthier than like deep fried chicken and
Chips so I was like, um, hope that it's healthier anyway
Chipmunk strongy can't hurt you
strongy had time soon
You are my favorite
sir
How am I supposed to recover from a comment like that?
Story time what happened? Oh, it was just a mingin saying which like it was just minging and it was like
I don't know what was wrong
Uh suspected someone maybe dated something wrong or like none of it was fresh like it was fucking minging
It was just like a really bad. Oh
Randomly unlocked a fizzly bear. I'll take it. Hi fizzy bear a fizzly bear. Sorry
Okay, minging
I bought a calypso and it's fucking minging
Okay, what are we what are we doing?
Is that banana tree die?
No, I didn't thankfully jeez. I was not paying attention. Uh, right
Fazzly wazzly bear wazzle wazzle
I saw that any pictures who sees the starving their pictures on your leader phantom by the meter
Somebody point me to the best ass eater. That's your wavelength. I tell him
I tell him
Wait a minute
If a quackberry eats a gooseberry, oh no, we're doing capitalist simulator
We just got an achievement for well called wealthy for getting 25k coins
If I give a quackberry a gooseberry, he changes, right?
I'm like 99% sure
If I give him a gooseberry, he's gonna change. I'm not fuzzy
Come here little duck
Where are you no get off the trees right now
You've become what you saw to destroy
Can't believe it
Land already. Geez
Well, there we go. Whoa, I didn't even buy it
All right, please if my memory serves me right
Eat this please
Are you gonna change?
Yes, I remembered. Okay. That's what I get confused the liquid to it and that I get confused because they both come out
Hey purple
There we go. It's a juicy goose. Oh my god, guess we should be confirmed. I'm gonna call her juicy goose
Oh, I like that
I like that
Hello bosom gumbling. Oh, there's another one in the garden. You're gonna destroy all my flowers though
I don't want you to destroy them
Well, uh sell the ones that kind of come in all the time so we can do the money
Right what I need to do
I don't
I guess we'll just focus on more of the pets and then we'll level up a bit more
Oh, we unlocked a cow. Okay
God, I remember everyone's like as there is a cow as there is a cow
Think of another milk go for now. All you know is go look
Happy as a biggie. Hello biggies
Hello
Oh, yeah master romancer. Okay, we got it. So now we sell five
two
three
four five boom
And then we go get the piggies ahead
She's like she's like good to your bum. Oh, she's like go to your bum. I was like what she's like go to your bum
No, it was just really funny being like, oh, yeah milk and then everyone was like, oh cow beach ever
surprise
goat
And fertility got it
Yeah, we go
Okay, builder's gonna make them that I need to
They want a rotten hazelnut
Oh
If you want to make any item
Uh, rotten, rotten, it's fucking me
And you just tap
Oh my god, we're gonna unlock a harry ball
Like unironically we're gonna unlock a harry ball
I'm gonna put a few of these around because these are absolutely stunning. These are stunning. These are called birds of paradise
These are stunning. Right. I'm gonna say something really controversial
I didn't know birds of paradise were real flowers until I came to Australia
because
I was like walking past houses and I saw someone with it and I was like, oh my god
That's like viva pinata and I was like, oh god the gamer brain rot
It's obviously based after a real flower
Yeah, mop bucket because of it the plant doesn't thrive in a scottish climate. So I had never seen it before
So I was literally like
Oh my god, it's like viva pinata and I'm like, no, that's obviously what it's about
Nonsense, it's nonsense the gamer brain rot is real
Okay, what are we looking at? What are we looking at?
Okay, we need the piggies to have hazelnuts. I repeat the piggies need to eat hazelnuts
So again, if you want to make a rotten food instantly just tap it with the shovel
Don't beat it with the shovel the shovel will pop it. Okay
Just a little tap like this
But you need to make sure the pinata is nearby because the fruit will expire and basically explode
And no one wants to like waste their money when trying to buy resources for the pinatas to hump
Okay, now they've eaten that
A rotten chili. Okay, we'll do the chili
This is a bit expensive, but I'll allow it because it's giving me points. Okay, so I'm strong. Okay connoisseur. I'm sorry
I don't think I said thank you for that
To be honest, I forget what the reveal is well
Um
I've already forgotten what I am I was supposed to buy
Is that a vegetable?
Oh, it's a chili. I remember me
I'm sorry, you know the reason why
That's sorry that you
A 17 for a seed
This game is a bit too real to capitalism
I said starting to hurt my soul a little bit. I think we need to plant corn and pumpkin as well
So I'm gonna do it. I'm just gonna do it. I'm gonna send it
I think it's corn and pumpkin for the pig
I need two pumpkins and then that's all the stuff they need
A rotten chili literally inflation again. It's like horror bro
What do you mean? They can just inflate stuff but not raise wages
Oh, but if they raise wages everything's gonna be more expensive
Wages do not even increase with inflation. So what logic is that?
Anyway, that's just me when I see that argument
But anyway back to the capitalism
Did I wake anyone up that was sleeping?
I literally I see that arguing all the time and I'm like
Well considering they don't even do that. What's your point?
What is your point?
What's your point?
I'm trying to find ghosts again actual um actual um like you should seem oh
A platypus vtuber would go hard. Did you know the males have venom in their back feet?
Platypus or mammals that lay eggs and also produce breast milk and the males also have poison on them
Our platypus from
Dinosaur era unironically because they seem to do everything wrong
In terms of like what a mammal is and they don't really seem to care
Oh, no, oh he wants to eat sheep
They're pokemon superior, but modern currency is not real real
Preach to the choir because I'm singing oh
Keep preaching because I'm the choir. Hello
You're preaching to the right person
They're aliens also me by the way don't a fun gen to smile
Ha don't a fun. Well, uh, is there a don't a fun. Let's remove out smile
Look, I swear actually you know what I'm about to pull up a fucking meme
I swear if anyone is typing if the shadow people are typing anything right now
I'm about to pull up a meme that will absolutely dismantle everything you're about to say in your ignorance
In your ignorance
Oh, I don't know if I'm going to recall the meme enough to get it to come up
So
Right, okay. Hold on now. Let me just preference this by saying
You are allowed to complain
And see the problems you do not have to offer the solution as the fucking tiny
insulin insulin
Um tiny not insulin. That's wrong word tiny little
Speck you are on the map. You do not have to change anything. You're allowed to point out what's wrong
And whenever someone says oh, hey, this is wrong. This is the fucking argument
We should somewhat improve society
Yet you participate in this. Yes, motherfucker. We're stuck in it
All of us are oh my god. Sorry. I'm about to put tinfoil hat on. Ah, yes. I'm very intelligent
Literally go back down in that fucking well and don't come back up again
I know no one's are literally fighting with me right now, but I'm fighting with myself. I'm fucking losing it. I'm actually losing it
Uh the ton of food. Thank you for the two dollars. Uh the super chat. I rate the thumbnail 5 at 10 for effort
Thank you. Thank you. I did it all myself
I too am very intelligent
A goose bit. Oh, I'm gonna have to actually buy a gooseberry. Are you joking?
How are you today? She won
I thought I didn't need it. I'm shadow boxing real hard right now
Real true throwing hands with the air
That's me punching you can't see it because my model won't track my hands, but that's me punching
No way that pig woke up ate and went back to sleep that honest
Summed it up. I'm purposely holding willy hostage right now because if I open that up all the piggies are gonna go
and
It's gonna I willies like break the damn shed. I'm working on it willy. Okay. I didn't mean to make corn or pumpkin
I just made that up apparently
Literally, he's waking up and then going to sleep eating and sleeping
I was just drifting off. What was this about being part of a platypus society? I hope I didn't wake you up. I'm sorry. Please forgive
What if we all stop participating at society at once? Oh
If you want to start getting theoretical so once upon a time in britain
When greedy greedy greedy government was in power
They introduced what was called a window tax if your building had windows you would get taxed
So everyone retaliated by barring their windows closing their like patching up their windows
Um, and there was also another tax in the uk
That was everyone was like you must pay it. You must pay it. You must pay it and no one paid it
And then they got rid of it
Now if you want to come and tell me
Shawnee if everyone does some sort of boycott or anything like that. It's not gonna work
bull
fucking
shite
I sorry this pig is drifting
absolute nonsense
Do not come to me and tell me that none of that's if you told me if everyone went to work
But collectively every single person obviously in theory
Um, it's not actually gonna happen. You would actually need to amass like a
Revolt of the current government and all that it's quite hard to do
You know koo koo's are quite hard to do if you told me every single day. So tax season is what someday
I don't know when tax season is for americans
Um, whatever the day was and they're expecting everyone to pay tax. You're telling me if everyone collectively said
Mmm, no
That major change wouldn't happen overnight
You're trying
You're trying to tell me that if if everyone collectively said
Um, I'm not going to use the conglomerate of supermarkets anymore. I'm going to use
I'm going to start growing my own stuff and using independent markets that the supermarket prices
All of a sudden would start actually
lowering
Me you're trying to tell that to me
You think they'd rather let that stock rock
Then to sell at a much more affordable price and not artificially inflated
You're talking to the wrong person
Okay, how do you get 90 percent of the population do?
Do
First we tell everyone to watch fight club
That's where it begins. We plant a seed
Just like that
Um strong a yes, that should be your first mutiny global hypnosis technique to reach half your power honestly
Things work until if people go along with it if people but that's the thing
That's the thing can
Can today's society come together?
Because we're being uh, I mean fuck it. I I won't put the tinfoil hat on but
Why is there a dragonfly in here? I didn't do anything to attract you have 12 bushes in the garden
Not this bush
Uh, right. I need to expand the water because apparently that dragonfly wants to stay in safe
Stranny, how long have you been in Australia the cause and willy situation there?
Oh, I'm fully fucking aware of what them two have been up to
Right, okay long story short, Australia has two major supermarket brands willies and coals, okay
They both come out and say oh, there's there's no co- well
We're not artificially raising our prices and all the farmers have come out and gone
Um, well, that's funny because my prices haven't changed because you know supply chain's been fine
And then the supermarkets are like, uh, we didn't artificially cause
People to suffer. You know how people need food to survive and shit. Oh, they need to figure it out
And it's like bruv our education system doesn't even teach you about seeds other than
Fucking water temperature and oxygen is what they need to grow
You're lucky if you get told about the nitrogen situation in soil like
At
The amount of evil if you look into it like I'm sorry
I'm so sorry if you are ignorant to these things. I think it's best you remain ignorant
Because when you start to see how bad you have no idea how bad things really are
It's so bad
It's like I don't mean to be dramatic
But sometimes living in ignorance is the best thing you can do
And I don't blame anyone for not even trying to scratch the surface of what's going on behind this
Don't do it. It will make you depressed. Okay
Protect yourselves a lot of reefling find what happiness you can the passing of time is imminent. Do you understand?
Anyway, that's my two cents back to Viva Piniara my childhood video game. We're currently trying
I
Sold all of my red hearts. Wow
I sold every single red heart. Oh my god, and they're like level six. So it's gonna take forever to show up
I don't even get me started on what we should be taxing
Anyway, did you have a oh they had a baby it's coming
Hello, little baby
Hello, little piggy
Piggy wiggie wiggie
Why whoa, I never noticed the texture of this place is messed up
I don't think it's that wait is inside of it dirt. Is it pure dirt?
Learning about Viva Piniara overthrow a government
Is it overthrowing a government if you just
Just
It's very hard to get into the subject
Because I start being like oh, but I need to mention this. Oh, but I need to mention this
But I need to mention this and he mentioned this before people start fucking hurrying me
I'll shadow box harder than you can ever imagine. I'm throne. I'm going left. You fade right?
But I'm already going boy. You just fucking straight into my fist. Okay
It's basically don't have a voice for government concern probably too late. Don't well so long story short
Scotland wanted to leave the uk, but the vote was
45 to leave
and then as
Uh an an insult to injury they publicly declared so it's called holly root
Which is the place where like scotland government's commands from but scotland always has to get
Approval if you will from the united kingdom
i.e
england
right
and after the referendum
um
The united kingdom came out and we're like, oh, we'll totally give scotland more rights over what they're doing
Ah
And they gave them about
Like it was just pish. It was just pish. Don't get don't get started. Don't get started. Don't don't do it
Have fun on beaver pinata be free play childhood games
Lead into the nostalgia all is good in life. Okay. I promise you give yourself that happiness you desire
That's rough. Yeah, um
I was quite fun learning about politics in other countries though
Like when I came to australia, I was like, oh surely it couldn't be worse than the uk
Oh
Oh, no
Oh, I was gonna buy the crocodile thing
What does he want a sweet tooth? I don't have a sweet tooth
Oh, there's a swan. Hi
Why does everyone want water? This isn't a water garden
This isn't a water garden
Unfortunately, the clock has ticking the hours are going by the past increasing in future receipts possibilities decreasing the rents mounting
Do you understand?
Yeah, like saying that series don't worry about it
I do like that meme though, but that meme's a little too serious
It's a little too serious
Right, I'm gonna pop this and I'm uh, no
You're welcome to hang a boot in my garden, but didn't he be spitting up all these naughty seeds?
These are bad things, right? Okay. Where is that flutter scotch? I want to make him orange
Where's rick
Where's rick don't care. Where is he? I just
I got the notification. You're mine. You're somewhere here
Oh, I already had a sweet tooth. Oh, sorry buddy
Where I don't know where it is
Okay, you've eaten it. What do you want now?
No, you've not eaten it yet. Hold on the game's not registered. He's eating the sweet tooth
I don't have one
How do I get one right? Okay. Let's make the garden really watery. Okay
Oh, this has to be 20% water. Come on. The whole thing's water
I'm literally curving around the bend to get more water into the garden
I
Shawnee doesn't even have one never mind two literally
I have one in the garden, but it's not mine and I don't know what it needs
I don't I don't even see it. Where is it?
It might have got scared away by the crocodile. You know that
I don't see it
I don't see it hanging about I don't know. Can someone look up
Viva pinata suano requirements
Because I don't know what the third thing it needed was I said it wanted water
Right, I'm gonna have a red hot so it can fight a dragonfly whenever that boy shows up again
I don't know what the requirements are. It says like 20% water. I'm working on it. Okay. I'm working on it
The whole map is going to be water just for the water type
The crocodile is
Oh, it's the ring everything
He's about to fight my yeah, I was gonna say he's about to fight my worker again
I saw that
Shopping behavior, what's this? Oh
I see it. Oh, don't fly. Whatever you do. Don't fly you
Here now
Get orange
Get orange right now. What are you? Buzzle gun seven you can be sold. Thank you
You the value you have added to my capitalistic garden. Come on eat it become orange
Show me that transformation. Oh
Transformation central
Oh, you're ready. Oh, check them out. Oh, look at this like oh, I like that
Yes, yes, yes
slaying
Posing on them stailing on them. We love it here
Oh
There's another reefing out there
I'm afraid I don't have what will interest you into the garden, but I'm glad you're hanging out
What do you like and what would make you come over? Oh, it doesn't tell me
Why didn't they tell me
Most valuable replaying hell. Yeah have appearance requirements have one in the garden. There are five serpent
You want to eat three snakes?
25% water and eat two sandwiches
That's so specific. Okay
We'll make some corn
And then we'll get bar to do this thing
Oh, wait, no, it's bro. Oh, we would have to send bar out twice for a sandwich
I mean, it's cheaper than buying her astronomical prices
And
Oh wait already have corn, huh? It's a small world. It's a small world
Girl
Well, I'll sell you. Yeah
Well, the garden is like
Please wait, I'm pretty sure no no not start wrong one
If I check the journal it will tell us the land mass and if we have 20% water
Okay, that'll look like 20% water. Is it 10? 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10. Okay, we have 20% water
1% golden soil
Brother come inside and she will let you come this time
I don't remember what I said to prompt that but you're still here for that. Okay
We'll do petunia because we have 23,000 which is more than enough
Okay, now it's time for the doggos
1 2 3 4 5 6 7
Give me that master romance reward
Okay, we got resident reward first that's fine. We're level 33
Yes, please
Oh two of them are awake
I'll just make sure it registers. Okay, there we go. I wanted to register the
I've got master off as well. Let's go
1 2 3
4 and 5
Okay, we'll do the same thing as we always do. We'll go build the doggo's house
And then
I don't know what I said to trigger that now. I feel like an mbz. No, I don't know I don't I forget literally five seconds
After sit like whatever I thought so I'm sorry. It's nothing to do with you. It's me. I'm the problem. I promise you. I'm the problem
Got house right. What do you need?
Has a caller. Oh, that's it. Yeah, that makes sense. They need calling and then they'll be happy
The second
That's not a bad idea. Oh wait, hold on. I'm putting it together the second reefling appeared
and then you said
Better come and say she will let you come and say, okay
I put the pieces together. It took me a second
And took me one whole second together hitting it took me a lot longer, but I get it now
Oh, wait, we unlocked more accessories
Was leveling up. I thought you just like unlocked all the accessories right away
Okay, and then we'll put it on another one
Little caller on the other one
And then
We'll see what he wants. I don't know a bone. Maybe he wants a bone
I think you can get a bone from the shop. Don't worry, strony. You're a watermelon. You can't
Ah, I knew you wanted a bone. I knew I remembered
Sorry, but I'm actually just so mlg this game like honestly, we're gonna get a tuna corn so quickly
Unicorn is like this mysterious
Okay, now if we tell Bart to go on the bread
He will turn them into sandwiches then we can get the swan and then we can get that a bad one
Oh, what does the mallow wheels do?
I don't have a pixie and I don't want them to hurt my animals
Oh
Leave reefing alone. Do not hurt my reefing. I'm so sorry
Right, this is going to be really mean, but we actually need to get a few achievements
Um, and we need Dastardos to come out. So you see the the the bat and the croola
The cryola pen or whoever it was
They need to come they need to scare Dastardos
Does that make sense and then we will unlock an achievement because of this
Cerepina is unlock achievements. Um
A mummy saved me. I was so scared. You're asleep. You couldn't have been scared. Did you work? Um
What
He bit he bit my ass. Oh no, Danny kiss your ass
Danny kiss it better. Wait, why am I here a bone and I've got a bone to pick with you. Give me a bone
Thank you
Well, at least they're a little bit on sale. It's not why is the bone so tight? Why am I paying
375 smacker runes for an atom of a bone? Am I going crazy and saying that's tiny?
Like what the fuck are these growers not shores like
Why is that so tiny?
Okay, I'm so sorry about that little wolf guy
I'm waiting for Dastardos to wake up
Okay, gammies on standby
The bat is sitting here either one is going to give an achievement. I just need them to both do it at some point
So I feel bad for this mallow wolf, but
An eagle air as in an eclair
Stony you're gonna have them have a complex all correct ruined my joke again
We say the joke again
Yay
I'm experienced. I'm such a good gardener. This is like the 800th time I've played this game
Right, please don't fly. Thank you
I need you. Why is there a magical in this garden?
Where is it and what do you want to become mine? I don't have a new get. Okay, it's fine. We don't have to do it
right share bear
I can't make the dogs romance yet because
Um, that guy's gonna come. There he is. Okay
Game positions everyone game positions gammie you're on standby. Do you understand me young man?
Gammie you're on standby
Right now right at this very second you have to show up parry ball
Right at this very second
Okay, the game pause gammie gammie gammie here here here boy gammie go
Gammie and the freaking thing go
Share bear you need to hurry the fuck up
Let's go right gammie. Okay gammie did a delay dance. Okay now share about do your thing
Do your thing that's right him with the that's right. You stun and you stun on him
No, no, i'm not done yet go again. Okay. Oh, we did it right. We got it. We got it. We got it. We got it. We got it. We got it
Very well played very well played. We've got two achievements back to back to back. Oh speaking of achievements. I've just remembered one
Uh, where is it?
I'm like 99% sure this is an achievement if you rename them and you can literally go. Oh, it's already called laying
Yes, I remember. Oh my god. I wonder if I could do this game without
Like older achievements without looking them up
24 achievements we're getting a juicy juicy dance
Real true delicious
Sacrifice for the greater achievements. It was a several pinata that we couldn't get yet. Oh speaking of several pinata
One shitting up my garden right now. Oh god. Don't eat it
Oh as if it's the bark that fell ill
Oh my god, wait, what's going on? Go home
What's going on at our chaos in the skirting actual chaos is erupting in the skirting
Stop it. You're upsetting me
I need that cutlass. I need that cutlass come on
Right, give me that bastard. I didn't care if it's 10 grand you that now put that shite down
I think that stops ruffians from entering your garden
I'm like 99% sure get out. Why are they coming in pair? Wait, are you?
What are you doing?
What is he doing?
Right, okay
Oh, the dog never left us. Oh, they're called bark bark. Wait, what food would be bark bark?
What's the sweet name that repeats twice?
Yeah single pinata hell yeah
You can have a piggy. Oh no reefing. Do you want to go for another party?
I know you get nervous being the center of attention, but are you a brave boy?
Oh, you're currently in your house right now. Aren't you be honest? Yep
All right, I won't wake you up then
What is that noise?
Can you hear that noise as well? I think something's glitching out in the background
Why are we in a trash can? Oh, that's your house
That's where you're nice and comfy. Oh, okay. We've got a parable
10 bananas you greedy fuck
Do you know how expensive it's going to be to pay for that?
Oh, I leveled up though feels good man. I'm maybe having new seeds 10 banana
So 280 quid. Oh, you're having a laugh mate
I'm sorry. Do we need to open up like an anti-capitalist shop? I will do it. Sorry. I will get on freaking
Hey, what's the game called?
Supermarket sim right now that is extortion it
I think I'm gonna have to start like growing flowers and selling them
Oh
Would you go dancing with me or would you be too embarrassed to dance with me?
Oh, look at the wallpaper in the background got all the other piñatas on it. Oh, that was such a cute romance dance
Oh, they're a doggy mad dog diner
Oh, can we open up a viva piñata cafe, please?
Please I will go feral
I will go feral. Oh my god
How many of you had I've got five bananas down to have any bananas in this I do
Right. I'm sorry. The bird's just gonna. Oh speaking of banana
The bird's just gonna have to eat some of the bananas for free because I don't
Oh, but I don't want to lose it in case I can get it
I can't believe it
The system is winning again
I have something I need and they're selling at an extortionate rate because they know that I don't have the resources
Get it right now or to make it for myself. I can't believe it
We're falling for the pitfalls. We are we are falling for the pitfalls, right?
What do you want? Are you mine yet? Has eaten two sandwiches eat up your fat bass?
Please
I am begging everyone eat horrible eat swan eat a glare
I don't know even know where you are. Oh, you're in the corner. I just spotted you right now. What do you want?
A fully grown oak tree. I haven't even unlocked that yet. Why are you asking for things? I don't have
We're in the pin pinata was there
What do you do silver baboon?
You're gossiping
And then you make pinatas fight each other. I have no idea what a baboon wants
Oh, it has to lose a fight to a member of the serpent family draught. Okay
Okay, okay
I need to grow an oak tree and I have no room at the end for it. I'm going to wait until this swan eats
this second sandwich
And then I will patch up. Okay, perfect
Become mine like right now
Right this second now
I'm getting stressed. Oh how the mighty have fallen literally
I've become the very I actually love when we play games and then I become the very thing I swore to destroy
Okay
Now that will no the crocodile can show up and I'm going to order another one of you both of your canon fodder
I don't care. I said what I said your canon fodder
Okay, we are now going to grow a freaking oak tree
Okay
We're going to grow an oak tree
right here
But we're going to move the whole over just a little bit because the tree is
Very big
Very big oak tree. I surely have unlocked the seat for an oak tree. Okay. Thank you. They're not giving me a freaking
That's not oak tree
Well, I might as well just plant this and I'll sell it off
There's a fight between a reason when did I even get you know what you to knock off right now. I don't care knock off
Yeah, you're both getting rained on because you're fucking terrible don't do that again
I'll actually spank them with water
Stroney, what is my purpose to be canon fodder? Oh my god
Um
Okay, let's level him this plan up
This badger cycle keeps coming in
But I'm not actually
But oh, oh, you want to know what you win for that fight being fucking sold off. Fuck you
Don't do that to buzzle gun
Buzzle gumbling. Okay, don't do that
Oh bonus growth already. I am doing anything
Eat up strongy. Are you a feeder?
Billy Billy
Oh, look at how happy they are to hatch their little pinata
Oh, oh, I don't have what you see
What does he do does he eat what does he eat?
I don't have a pixie yet
Oh, but I can make one
Hold on I'm having a memory
Hold on a second. I am having a memory
I've just unlocked the swan. Oh god. I'm so pure though
I don't have any money
Right, I'm gonna sell the dog soon. The dog should give me some more money. Okay
Well, and to see you. I see you. I'm selling you
I'm selling you
We made 1000 from that. That wasn't insignificant
Core memory there is a thing in willy the builders place called a like a weird house or something
It might be in the other one
Oh, no, it's not
Uh
Maybe it only unlocks after swans have shagged
I hate much real estate
Why were you
Wait, is this my patch of gold?
No, I have a big gold patch also
Okay, once the swans have humped each other I can make a pixie
Because there's like the strange building you make and then you send in a romanceable pig and swan
And they go inside and they create a pixie
Does that make sense? I'm actually gonna it's a thousand for the bird of paradise is leveled up
That's very big
Oh my god, they're little baby puppies. Yeah
Sparrowment run capitalism coming for you literally moth drop easy 600 right there
Okay, I don't mind him lurking around if he isn't gonna do anything to upset me
But he's gonna upset me. Oh have a pixie. Oh wait. I have a pig. Okay. I'll just keep the pig
Uh, I will
Oh reefling are you awake reefling darling? Oh reefling party time. Let's go
Thank you for waiting at the box for me. I may have forgotten the box was even there
Oh, please don't eat it right now. No, you're not gonna
Okay, no, he's just going home. That's fine. Did he even spit up any bad sweets?
I don't even think he did did he learn his lesson from last time
Okay, little reefling. I need you to pick up a romance suite and I'll give it to the pig and then I'm gonna get another swan
And then I'll make them romance and then I think we can progress to get the pixie to make the mallow a good boy
Okay, we're doing it
I don't even have enough money cover the cost for that. I guess we'll do a standard fetch quest of two
You thousand eight hundred. I'm definitely gonna need to start making plants because
Actually, where was that plant I was growing? Did I just kill it? I might know
I don't see it
Uh, I think I accidentally killed that orchid plant it may have lost this
Too much hydration like I may have lost hydration
Oh, like it was an honest mistake. I wasn't paying attention
I'm gonna purposefully grow a few and level them up for money because we're getting low on funds. We're getting low on funds
Stranny, you've been a good girl and calling us darling. What you like when I call you darlin? Oh darling reefling
Honey bun reefling sugar plum reefling
Pummy yummy up and you're my sweet
And I want you to know
I'll always be right here
for am
streaming childhood games
because
you
are
So why did those not plant?
My garden's too thick. Oh no, this can't be
My garden's too thick
I
Was drowning with the pet names my heart can't take it. Oh, what other pet names could I call you?
Milk the fuck out of that reefland call them an inkling
So I don't that wasn't even a pet name. That was just me getting on the mic. Um
Sugar, I think food names, uh, you would say that fine. Um
I think food names
are
cute pet names like oh sugar. Oh, honey. Oh
like
cupcake
I like food pet names. I know architect goes when I am
Um
Splitting when someone said it's not a good stream game apparently and at the extortionate prices of what nintendo offer
I'm not really inclined to
Uh, if you guys don't recommend it I don't
Calamari muffin goes hard my little muffin
My pudding my sweet pea or sweet and sour calamari. That's very specific
Right, where is my red hole? I need it to beat the fuck out of this gunfly
Where is it?
I don't need to make a new one
You
land
Oh, this is when they actually do my tips in
My nipples have inverted in pure frustration. Where is it?
There you are you sick. Um beat him up
Have a fight right now and lose
Have a fight and lose do you understand me?
No
Get so angry. Oh, I'm so angry. Oh, how the fuck do I make you angry?
Yes, I did it. I did it. Okay, right. What is this swan house and why is it so
Extravagantly big
Well, we all know what party they vote for jeez who is puking
Not now now's not the time to puke in my garden. I'm currently trying to get a dragonfly
She has a bird in it. No when I get frustrated I have inverted in it
Okay, the swan survived. I don't mind if the swan gets eaten because I think the other swan's gonna come in
Um right I need to sell something
I mean, it's not like the the garden's like freaking ready to pop its claws. I mean, I'll sell some stuff, but
I'll sell the birds. Oh, no, that's what attracts the harry ball
I've got a sour baboon as well. I don't have time for all these sour's coming into my garden. Right. What do you do you twat?
Right, where's my jewel snakes? Did I get rid of them? Oh
I've got rid of my jewel snakes
No, don't fight. Stop it. Don't listen to his lies. Don't listen to his lies. He's lying
He's lying
Did I sell? Oh my god, no, he's beating up the swan, but I don't have another swan
I can't handle the stress of this game. I don't have another swan
She gets so heated the bud nips us to her head. That's what she was. Remember when that person called us?
Oh, honestly. No, no, no, actually no having it
I um
I could see because I'm blocked
I couldn't see like I saw some replies and I was like, oh, that's a really strange reply on twitter
Like no one really says anything like that, but then it then I could see who you were applying to and I'm like, yeah
Yeah, defend the fucker me. Yeah
Wait, I already had two swans. What?
Well, the crocodiles ours apparently
Please lose the fight. They're still not finished
Yeah, and I knew I didn't sell you. Um, are you strong enough to defeat the absolute loving daylight set of this baboon?
Wait, they just stopped fighting. Oh, did one of them get trampled?
I think one of them got trampled. Okay, right you
We can sell you guys could you guys pump pump?
Okay, we've got a bit more money
Okay, jameleon now is not the time really glad to have you buddy, but this garden is absolutely packed with
things that are trampling each other
Please okay, we are gonna sell the orchard orchards orchards
Who won
Okay, the dragonfly won. Okay. Okay. Let him get up. Let him get up. Are you mine?
You're mine
I'm gonna be your wait. You didn't attack the baboon
The star of pinatas is red
you
Attack this baboon right now
No, no, don't let him get away
Oh, we got a dragonfly. What color do you become? I forgot
We've got pain
Oh, he's got a rainbow tail. Oh, that's very cool. And we got terror terror upgrade and we got an achievement on top
Hmm, what what happens to pinatas when they get sold they explode into
You've been awarded a piece of the tower of sour. Yeah
Each piece you have
Okay, oh he's green
Oh my god, a cocoa dial
Snappy the client a coca-dee
Oh
I'm gonna name him snappy
I'm gonna spell horribly wrong
snappy the clutch in
With snappy have two peas
snappy the client a coca-dee
Actually, no, I don't want to sell I want to try and make we'll make the fucking money
Hi refling. Oh you so tired you run over to me, but you fall asleep because you so tired
You watch a man during streams a little too much. Do you need to rest a little weakling?
I think you might need to rest
Oh, hi
You want bret? Oh, oh apparently I'm down for my 25% closer
But hey has been a good day for
If we have a crocodile vtuber, uh, that'll be her cover song at debut
Is my water gone home
I think she might have but that's okay, right so we have a bee
Uh, we just need to get another two swans
Did you bring me that sweet darling? Or did you forget?
Did that just grow right before it was about to pop at sweet cogs? I think so
Oh my god 1.8. That's pretty considerable
Okay rolling around like a pig in
And what you ask, I don't know. I'm gonna get my shelly bean
my
Taff lye, I don't need a red hot an elephanilla
I can never get enough strone though. Never enough strone
Refling is tired because he's got work and fiber and still has to sleep
You should go to sleep because I'm still going to be online when you go to work. I
Honestly don't think I'm kidding
I would be very
careful
What do you want a squazzle? I actually don't even have a squazzle on pop
Unbelievable if I can't even upgrade. Oh, oh my god the claws
That's gorgeous the colors are gorgeous
So any house all that pent up gaming energy to let out honest real truth
No lies detected
Oh my god, that's a huge bitch. Um, that is a quote by the way whenever I say that that's a quote
It's a damn. That's a huge thing. I'm not saying that to be malicious. It's a quote
Okay
So I just needed to clear that up just in case uh, I'm starting
Someone's feelings. Anyway, I'm an architect. So fuck off. Fuck off my dick
Okay, I'm gonna sell these
We're making so much money back
Are you gonna come in the garden or do you not want to come in?
Repeat the mulling. Oh look at you weak lick
Yes, I'll do it all night or you are going to be ill at work. I urge you guys
Now when I lose sleep because I'm working that's fine. Okay
But when you lose sleep
That's nori
Wait, are we back to endurance streams? I'm putting off food and shower until after stream is on the sake
You can go food and shower and I will still be here
Oh, it's a bit. Look there's a baby perfectly. Um
I think what we'll do is we'll redirect into mercy, which is four hours away
So if you can handle four more hours of viva pinata, then
Uh smooth sailing after that
Well, buzzle gum number eight more like buzzle gum into the crate to be sold
May I'm out of on about dad have the whole floor today?
Oh
Well, I guess you're all just stuck watching me. That's right snowberries. That's right bleeding hearts. That's right harem
That's right snippets. That's right pin pals. You're all stuck with the oh, oh, you're not watching because you're
You're oh, she isn't okay. Well, I understand. We'll have anything
I played this for almost 24 hours straight one time. It's such a good game and to
I chose
She owns all of them. Yeah, sorry. I needed a break from doing the voices today
I couldn't like my voice is quite sore today. So I needed a break from doing all the voices
I hope that's understandable. Have a nice day
Right we're kind of playing a waiting game right now. I need her to come back with that freaking thing
But she's not and I don't know if I should put all my song
Into the next pinata
Oh serenity. Thank you so much for the redirect
Thank you
How is stream what game are you playing? But if you're exhausted, please don't feel forced to talk because
There's no worse than redirecting after a really long and eventful stream
And then the streamer is like, what were you up to and you're like too exhausted to even type out what you were up to
Walking dead season 2. No spoilers
I'm just glad. Oh, wait, weren't you not collabing with someone as well?
A speedy bunny raid. Hi
Sweetie bunnies. I'm strongy. I'm the scoosh. Yeah
Feveal we're gen one. Hi
Uh, unfortunately, mercy isn't on today or I would highly recommend mercy coming on soon
Love you. I was with mismar. I knew it. I knew you were collabing with someone on it. I knew it
Why do you don't have the wrench either?
Why is it when I am midstream I have to put the wrench
How do you I knew you had a club I knew it. I'm like, I'm such a firefighter. I must have seen it and I was like
Add as a moderator and then
Boom, she's got the wrench as it's over for you reeflings and you speak
What? Oh, there's a naughty piñata in my garden right now. Hold on
Excuse me. Just need to fix up my garden. I am playing a childhood game called viva piñata
And I'm currently being stressed out
To high heavens over the game, but in a good way like in a humorous way. What do you need?
A pixie. I still don't have one for you
Um, but we're currently doing the it's not cheatsy doodling
But it's the speedrun strat where you buy loads of
Piñatas from the shop and then you get loads of accolades for having them even though you didn't really do anything for them
But don't tell the game that we're doing that, but we're leveling up quite well
We're five hours in it's a bit of an endurance room. So please don't feel bad for clicking off or anything like that
I understand. I'm not your cup of tea
However, the evil ones always look so much cooler. Yeah, we've been transforming the sour piñatas into the good ones
um
This is some weird ass plants versus so
It's piñatas
We're currently making a house for the sheep. So the sheep can do what's called. I can't even find the sheep
It's called a romance dance
Read in between the lines if you dare. I can't even find it. I think it's not registered that I have sheep yet. Um
But yeah, like the so this is a sour piñata we're trying to get but I'm waiting for the
The hunter that grabs more piñatas to come in and help us but she's refusing to come back and
Oh, we're having so many issues. She has power now. Hey
I think you can make a pixie without meat in the composite species below before. Oh really?
No
They need to be able to be
Romanceable, but I can't feed a romance sweet to it
I can feed a romance sweet to the piñata. I think that's fine
We're currently trying to make a super awkward combination
It's just nonsense on it play. Oh, we have an old tree
We might be able to get in a clear the eagle layer thing
Okay, let's pop it in
Now this thing's gonna take a hot second to grow
Which is fine
Sorry, I'm late. Don't worry. We just bing ching. Don't you want bing ching?
Um, we actually just unlocked uh, unicorn tree, which is
Um, actually kind of big. Um, so I'm gonna make one over here
Although the problem with this game is
The garden runs out of memory. They limited it
So you can't have like too many things all at once. I'm getting a forehead
I just need to get unlock a squazzle unbelievable a level four piñata squazzle. I've not unlocked
But
Okay, and now we've got a unicorn tree coming in as well
But that oak tree is so beautiful
You can kind of see it now, but it has like all the piñatas on it the designer
Cooked when it comes to this in particular like they did insane
How well they did with the the concept of that tree
New leaflings are discovered every week. Yeah, we're getting more leaflings in the garden
We're doing the perfect farm life, but we just need to get these sheep to hump
And there's no other way to say it. They're going to hump and I need them to eat this flower in order to do so
I don't know. It's like an aphrodisiac put some in the middle or something. I don't know how it works
I don't question sheep
Sheep's ways
Where is the other flower?
I've lost it. I'm just gonna plant now. I've lost the dying flower. That's the only thing
Well, it should be there somewhere, but I guess not
All right, we'll break this plant in order to get it your garden's getting very full
Yeah, see this is the problem. Oh, and I
Just broke the flower that I needed because everything's popping up all at once. Okay. Okay. Yes. Yes
Okay, take well take snappy on a holiday because he's
I'm gonna have to sell some of this stuff
Okay, one more time
There we go, right you
Where is the other
There's not you
What was I feeding it's disappeared. Oh a sheep. I was feeding a sheep. Sorry, right you eat a water lily flower. Yeah
Times like this we need the insight of a will smith
Reef land
Come on in big spender's welcome window. What am I supposed to respond to that? Oh wait, what was the flower one?
That was kind of funny
To poison ivy flowers. Okay poison ivy flowers
Well still mention poison ivy flower
Poison ivy seeds
And it need two flowers. So I need to plant four seeds now. Everyone. Please evacuate from the that you
Get the heck out of here. I don't want to see anyone walking in this direction whilst the nasty flowers are growing
These are bad flowers. They're bad for your health. I don't want anyone getting sick
Because you got too close to the poison ivy flowers. I need them to grow
So they flower like the wee head of it flowers and then we'll deal with the rest. Okay
Sweet bun red. Yes. Thank you again, serenity. I hope you have a good rest
After your stream and misma too actually, um
I have some exciting news about misma guys
Oh, I have some exciting news about misma. Oh, but you don't get to find out until next week. Oh
I am horning in on these weeds so deeply and harshly
Please
Once it gives the achievement for them being grown. Oh my god, you can literally see them getting ready to poison my purpinatas
Oh, they're coming out
Oh
See dos not right now. Please don't please don't admire the weeds in my garden. That's rather embarrassing for
For like a plant connoisseur. That's quite embarrassing right once they see the flower on the top once that blooms
We are beating the crap out of these weeds. Okay. I just need it to bloom
Not now raison. It's gonna end up having a fight with my bubblegum
Everyone stay away. Are you joking?
He went to sleep in between the poisonous flowers
I'm getting trolled. He went to sleep in the poisonous flowers
Is
Coming back for more
You see the ai in this game. I could actually fart on it. I really could
Wait, I only ended up getting two flower heads for that
Did two of them not come up? Am I going crazy?
Oh dear
Right, I think I need three birds of paradise to attract the haribo again
So I'm gonna plant two more because it'd be shame for all these bananas to go away
But of course the pinyas elder fighting back there and I'm trying to do 10 things the one
Yummy poison literally they're like, oh that smells so good and like their lungs are being mustard gassed right now by these poison ivy plants
Please get out of the way. Please get out of the way. Please
Do I need a fir tree anymore? I don't think so. I'm gonna get rid of it because it's getting in the way
um
Right you have served your purpose. I'm gonna keep gammy sherbet. Thank you for your service. You've done fantastic
We're super happy. What are these?
The bananas that are going through has eaten two poison ivy flowers, right? You eat this right now
And then I'll see what I need to do with you
Gamble no the sweet embrace of poison. I'm pretty sure in england. There's like this uh location
That's dedicated to um
Poisonous plants and like people pass out when they visit it and stuff of long grass
I don't
Long grass
I don't I've not even purchased long grass. Hold on a minute
There we go long long grass seed packet. Oh, it was only a thousand anyway. I was in big deal
Yeah, there's like somewhere in england. It's like got a garden that's specifically for like the most poisonous plants ever
Right, we're just gonna spray this down
And then hopefully the sheep will be happy
It doesn't really matter where we put it at the end of the day
I'll put it around your home little reefland so you can be camouflaged and then you've got extra privacy
And no one can peep through your peeping what you're doing
It's real. It's a gardening museum greenhouse place. Yes. See and yeah, I wouldn't yeah
Whoa, I forgot the the sprinklers away. I'm sorry. Please forgive. Please forgive. Please forgive. Please forgive. I'm not done yet
I'm not done yet. I'm not done yet. I'm not done yet. I'm not done yet
I need to go do the oak tree. I completely forgot
Oh, please don't be perishing. Okay, you're fine. You're actually not doing that bad after admit
You're doing pretty well. All things considered you're doing well
Okay, and now I'm going to put the fertilizer on both the gem tree and the other one
The place is Alton wick garden
I
I'll take your word for it because I actually don't know what it is
But you wouldn't tell me several times reefling. Don't eat candy. Just because you find it on the floor. It's dangerous
Don't be a silly Billy
Okay, I don't have a picture yet. I'm working on it. I'm working
See, this is the problem. If you don't get expressed
She is out for like days at a time. It's ridiculous
My gardening level 38 broken pina
I'm going to say something controversial. It was a reason that just got broken. Um
Oh, he's like singing to himself
Yeah
I think he's losing it
Oh, please candy. What if you take it from a child? No, I'll just buy you what you need reefling
Oh, you picked up some candy
I need to get you uh
A spider
Whoopsies I forgot about these two
Uh
Do you think the game forgives me for being really bad at playing it?
As soon as the sprinkler girl goes home, it's over for me
But this is gonna be a big boy. Look at me
Uh
What I need I need a sheep's home
Surely the sheep's home's there now. I couldn't find it last time. Hold on. Let me open my eyeballs
Oh
I'm a dumb dumb. I was looking for the white color, but oh god, this is too big
Is there anywhere in the garden that will fit I mean not really I had to make everything freaking water
Um
Yeah, I kind of had to make everything water
because someone not naming names
A dragonfly
Was being so specific with the requirements. I had to change
You've made more space so you can continue to grow. I mean did I?
I don't really recall making more space
I sold a few plants and stuff. I don't know. Maybe the game's being pernickety
I mean, you're also just not running any water upgrade. True. Shoot. There's the sprinklings doing all for me
Okay, have it now is this enough room
Is that a two by two in terms of we've up now one two one two a little bit more on this side
Okay, and then we can get a sheep home
Okay
Award for growing a gem tree. Oh, it's a gem tree a tree of gems
Goobah looks good as goobah
Oh 39
Don't mind me lucky 39
I'm getting there
Ah, yes
Right, we're gonna fertilize the tree
But we're yeah, I mean like come on. Look at the stunning magnificent gorgeous
Uh bonus for award
Right, what do you want? Do you still want tons of grass?
Okay, we just need you to eat poison ivy. So I'm going to grow
Two more poison ivy and everyone is going the ai is not going to lock my pinatas onto the poison ivy
Because the ai seems to be loving it. Okay, so we're gonna do it
Over here where no one is lurking. Okay, we're gonna post multiple
Okay, we're gonna sell you
And we're gonna tell you
you
No, go over here
Leave this area alone. This is for the sheep only
Sprinkling maybe you can come over as long as you don't start. Why not make an island for the poison?
I just need the flower heads so I can't like bring it over or anything. I just need the sheep to
bump uglies and then I can move on to the next thing
Once this freaking hunter comes back. She's still away. This is like day two
She's been away for trying to get this swan
No work for the sprinkling how much do these trees sell for a thousand?
Hmm
The plants honestly do better than a tree
Only upgraded at once with a fertilizer, but still
I can see wait, uh, uh, uh, oh
Oh, everyone's super interested in this corner of the garden all of a sudden. Hmm
I'm wonder if it's to do with the ai and all locking onto the freaking you freaking bricks
I don't want these plants a roryl. Oh an orio. Okay, that's a good one hydration chain
I'm not gonna guess any of my pinyas
They're just the ai's help in on getting hurt on a plan
Restive of gardeners can attract a roryl
The roryl will only appear and there are lots of different types of pinyasas living in the garden. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay
Is she coming to water these yeah, I didn't think so go back
Okay
So I guess they don't have a hundred percent drop rate, which is fine
They don't as if that I swear if that butterfly was about to like drop right next to one of these poisonous plants, okay
Okay, there we go. I can see the flower head on all of them
Okay, that one didn't drop one that's okay that one didn't drop one. It was a 50 50
Is this how I'm supposed to do
Oh
Yeah, yeah, yeah, gammie wait
That's literally why I planted four we just lost like a 50 54 times in a row. This is why we don't play belcher
That was uh, come on
Well, look do be in the air
Luck me in my ass tonight
Luck be in the air tonight
Oh wait the garden literally is refusing to spawn anything more. Okay
I think that's why the flower heads didn't spawn there
That was a meme. I just quoted. I did not just randomly come out with that. Please understand. I just quoted a meme
I am so sorry for the confusion
That is a meme it was like that game show and the quote was like luck be in the air tonight
um
and
It looked like
F me in the arse tonight or something like that
I'm just selling like all of these flowers because oh everything is complete exploding in front of me
Uh, uh, okay, everything's getting too old in my garden
I
Break the shed. I'll break it in a minute when I'm ready. I'm not ready yet
Oh, we can get a brown flutter scotch actually. I need to remember that
Um
I um my garden's falling apart. You're tearing me apart. Be open. Yeah
Please tell me the game registers that I have made space now
Kind of be arsed with it being like you've got any space but expansion. I have you be all bad. You've made space. I'm right. Uh-huh
Oh, I need to buy freaking bananas for this bird as well
She knows all the memes because the brain roll. She's just like me
Okay, I'm getting ready for belch roll. I actually don't know when we're next gonna play belch roll
Oh
Right, what's that like three bananas
One two three four five six seven
Eight nine ten. You're welcome
Gorge scaven
I call beaver. What did I do to erin it?
I don't really know but as long as you're happy
I'll sell you little chris room. Oh
And we made a bit of pocket money
I did not hit her stony. I did not. Oh, hi
Oh, hi mark. Congrats if your name's mark
Mark mark mark
Right poison ivy
Let's try
Again, wait if I plant the poison ivy and this harryable
Uh, sorry parable like b-lines to the thing and gets itself sick. I will be even more regional
I would read even harder actually. I'll read choices hard
I still need the pig. I mean snappy does the game think snappy's taking up a lot of room
Maybe they think your house is taking up a lot of room reform. I know I don't want to get rid of this one place yet either
Because when this hunter day three this hunter has been away never again
Honestly
I'm afraid up with this world everyone betrayed me
You seem to be genuinely enjoying this game. Oh, uh, it's my childhood game. I adore it. It's like
It's such a gift and a gaffe but trying to get the ai to do what you want sometimes is rough
Sometimes you are pleading with the ai over level 40
Did we unlock a seed for being level 40 please tell me we did
She's gonna victors. No
Geez how many we grew a plant we didn't really do them
I was gonna say it gave us like five rotations on who goes there on the clock
um
Oh, I just want this parable to join
I actually want to keep him because he's so colorful. So i'm gonna add ling to his name dragon sly ling
what
No strany you can't just add i and g uh, you can't just add ling to the end of everything to make a reef ling
Yeah, watch me
I don't know if snappy needs to go
I don't know if the game considers him taking up space because he's thought he is a big pinata. There's no doubt about it
I did not hit her. I did not oh hi
I mean the garden is looking a bit bad and to be honest other than the plants
Right you
Welcome to the club. Goodbye. Thank you for coming
Right you right poison ivy right. We're gonna do the poison ivy that harry bull is long gone. Let's
Get these sheep to touch each other
produce a baby sheep
and then
We will get rid of the sheep and then we will get that freaking swan
I don't know. I'm like dab fucking plant a fifth one as well just to make sure
Surely the drop rate of five
is enough
Surely are you awake at night when everyone's asleep?
Are you at night? I will refund
Oh, hi, mum
I absolutely love the who goes there to the burps. It's just my humor. I was so childish
I was like, obviously I was the one who burped. So why am I like identify yourself as if you're like some intruder coming to like
Ka-blam or me
All I heard was touch each other. Oh you zoning out, but that brought you back in. Oh, yeah
Ah
Oh
Maybe bubblegum should get his own house at one point
It's funny. Thank you. Thank you for enjoying my terrible humor. It's good. I'll be here all week. Thank you. Thank you
You know, I'm gonna say something controversial
I think I'm actually getting a wee bit tired
Yeah, see this is what I was worried about if I stopped doing endurance
That I would start getting tired and what are you perching on gammy?
You're sideways
Oh, someone's spitting up in the garden. Hold on
Stop it. I still don't have a pixie. You can hang out, but please stop it
I've lost my stat. Literally. I'm like, oh my god. I'm like getting a wee bit tired. I don't want to disappoint you though
Imagine strut tired stroney. I don't even know what's wrong. Literally. I'm like, oh my god. This is what happens when you don't
Are the flower heads there? It must be
Just because it's night
Drop rate. Okay. Drop rate confirmed. It was literally because our garden was full
Literally because the garden was full
We have learned
When stuff stops, but so seeds and flower heads all add up. Please don't come near the
Oh, well, I mean, I guess if you really wanted to right, okay
We can make the sheep pump. I repeat the sheep are humping and pumping
Okay
Break the shed will he give me one second. I literally need to tell the sheep to eat some flowers you
Go eat that
And you
Go stand next to them. So you's are ready when I'll break the shed open
It's one of the things we got build back up the time
I honestly think so like I was going to be like, oh, well redirect into mercy and then I think that's roughly like nine hours
Which I think is a good warm up endurance stream type thing
um
Oh, hey you
Wake up
Go to your boo, right? He's asleep there with the spine and then you have already eaten that
And then you just need a house, right? That's fine
Okay, then you
And you kiss right now
Oh, because you can't shake when you go to bed
That's so smart
This game is just so loved and created by the development team
We need to train mummy little by little until she gets her stamina back real and sure
I literally I'm like, I need a nap before I record the audio for you. I'm not even kidding
Right, okay, what's going on here?
Oh
Okay
I'm I'm I'm trying I'm dumb. Okay. I'm so dumb
Okay, let's just make sure we get the the romance and out the way
Astronomy you can do literally anything. We'll love you for a couple years ago. I could go with three-hour sheep nerves
If I don't get eight, I feel like I'm dying
It's hard like I guess it's just like a tame thing
I've got an ojisan reefling. I'm kidding. I'm just teasing. I'm teasing. You're actually not that old
Hey
That's so cute
And are they having like those floating dreams lucid dreaming was that what that was
Start floating
Oh, is the zero in 30 minutes? I thought she was
On to do am I going crazy
I'm not losing it. Oh, is there's gonna membership anime stream?
Okay for any bleeding hearts is there's gonna membership is uh anime
Watch long stream something with number eight in it
Yeah, it's a member only stream unfortunately. Oh, so technically I'm not the only one
My achievements
You have earned a new rank
ultimate gardener
So that's the max level
We're not gonna get anything more like we've unlocked everything we could now at this level
I don't know
At least it's dreams when you're aware that you're dreaming mid-dream. Yeah, I have never
Had one
I don't know how you induce it, but that seems pretty cool
I feel like you could do anything you want and I'd probably go straight for sex
I'm trying to kid
Now go straight. Oh, oh, I thought that was the size of the sheep. I'm like, oh my god. It's tiny
Right. Don't complain that I'm selling your house. Okay
Don't complain of soldier house or I'll cry
It makes me more upset
She day four and she's still away
Bruh, I ain't gonna want the damn swan by the time you come like with it. Jesus
You want a sweet tooth?
I actually can't help you because gretchums fetchums is refusing to fetch them
So I'm stuck here with nothing for what you want
Please just eat the bananas. I've bought you so many
I had it once but woke up almost immediately
When the bank takes away the hoops. Oh, no. Is that when I sell their hoops?
No, scrawny. Why did you invite this?
They're sheep. You're not sheep
You're this little guy. Where is it? Is he asleep right now? Oh, you're asleep right now
Let's take a peek at your leaflin
Oh, you're showing me your tuckus
You sure? Oh, look at the way you're looking back at me leaflin. Come on. If that's not consent. I don't know what is
Look at those eyes
scrawny that azure stream says you're a part of it by the way
Sorry, hold on
You can't be I'm not sure anymore
That is nothing
I don't see I can't see it because I'm not a member
I'm not a part of azure stream
What hold on
Does she actually think I'm a part of her stream? She's doing a membership stream
Is
It says was scrawny I'm watching anime with her. No, I'm not
Like I can't watch anime with her
Hey, is there a
Hey, is there a I'm not watching anime
Anime with you and your membership stream, right?
I think we might have gotten confused
I'm not watching anime with her
Why why why does she think I'm watching the anime with her? Hold on. I don't need you
I'm waiting for her to reply. We spoke last night
Who's fighting now?
Um, I am so nervous right now about disappointing her. I'm ready to fart
My stomach is twisting because I I think I might have miscommunicated and she thought I was
Maybe a copy and paste from her collapse the other day
I'm sorry
Bleaching hearts are telling me the title
says with scrawny, but I don't know if that's just uh
Coffee and paste from last collab stream
She's not replying to me, but she's one one
I think she made a coffee then paste
Okay, we've got a boobin
Oh my god, it's naked gross and will right now. Oh my gosh
A bonbon well, I'm gonna sell you your work
Okay, you have done your job. What do you want a squazzle? I might make you two or four
Is that parry ball mine yet?
You thank you for telling me that by the oh the parry balls mine. Let's go
Parry ball
Naked oh, that's such a good joke if you didn't know a baby she was called a youth
Actually good 37th the K coins. I'm actually
Oh, look at it. Oh, it's quite big colors
Well, I can sell these as we're about to pop their clothes. I'll sell them there
We were using them to attract
Right now let's deal with these ridiculous swans
I mean to be fair azura hasn't messaged me being like hey see you in an hour or like
Because whenever you do a collab with someone if you didn't know you actually show up an hour before and just hang out and chat with each other
um
Right, we're gonna do oh a parry ball is a higher. Oh a bond boom and a parry ball are actually higher tier than a cinemunki and a swan
Uh, right you you want a fountain in order to meet
Okay
Like oh, I can't do the woman. Oh, she's typing. She's typing discord leaks discord leaks. She's typing
I
I swear if she turns around you she's like I thought we were watching it together. I'm gonna be like
I'm gonna cry for you. I love you, but that's not
Okay
Okay, she said no, it's so misty. Okay. Thank god. Okay, bless. Okay
Okay, bless your cotton socks. I'll
I'll
Go back to streaming love you. Love you. Have fun in your anime vibes. We love you. We
Love you. Weep head pat you. Weep
Weep and then put in a bracket affectionately
Oh
What was that in the background of my game?
Don't ever say that again. I've just closed this girl down. So she talks to me. Sorry deserve can't see it. I closed this gourd
Night
Kai g number eight
What the fuck I thought you were drinking
No, that was like her in the background right the swan wants a diamond choker
Interesting. Why would you want a choker?
Choker hardly even know her
Okay, then I guess I really am trying with you. I really am
Right
Oh, you want water lilies. Yeah that thing that I don't have that's specifically what you want
That's specifically what you want water lilies that I don't have
Okay, I'm gonna plant these
I'm gonna fertilize them so they give me three flowers each
This one what's the color like you mine still hasn't come through I'm waiting for it
Ah
I decided to get one version strongy one version roofland
Is that okay?
Some paper
Yeah, right I've got two flowers for the swan
Which is currently heading for its house. So maybe don't go in your house like right at the second. That'd be great
Okay
And then next no no no no no eat that one too
and then
Then that should be you okay, and then we're gonna over water the f out of these plants
So they don't perish in the middle of the night
And then that means when the next one shows up
We will have the water lilies and then we can put a romance suite on the peg and one on this one
And then we can purchase the mystery house and then we can get a pixie
And then the mallow wolf will become one of us one of us one of us
That thing I sold 15 minutes ago and I was waiting on the downhunter
Use whichever one makes you feel best
It's never bad to get a backup thing. Yeah
That means I can change it out because I can like do pov stuff and it's like you and your caller
you know
Or like I wear your name type stuff like you can do it the way you want, okay
I am
Going to get rid of one banana tree
And then we have three trees in the garden one of them being a big oak tree which is absolutely humongous humongous what?
And we can sell the sheep because we no longer need the sheep
Um, oh my god, it's so tiny and cute. Look at the way it's spread out on it's me leggy. Oh the parents do it too
It's so tiny and clean
I think we're just kind of waiting for stuff to happen unfortunately
So we better if I wait again. I've still not got your pixie stop throwing up naughty sweets in my garden
Please it takes so long
Okay hydration check
I will have your pixie soon, please
No, you made me hit my tulip
No, you made me hit you
What's better than roses on a piano
Two lips on your guard. Oh fuck two lips two lips on your organ
The deal I fucked up the delivery but the joke's still there. Okay. I'm sorry. I fucked up the delivery so badly. I'm sorry
I I put myself on the spot and I made myself scared
I
I fumbled that so badly. I got so excited to tell the joke. It always happens
Whenever I have a good joke to tell I always stutter my way through it and ruin the the freaking delivery of the joke
Oh, why am I born like this?
Oh wait, did I just buy it the next thing?
Well, oh sell. No buy it. Yeah
Sure, okay. I think I just bought and sold them. I think
Shawnee's
60% a joke is in the delivery. I know I know
I absolutely twatted it up
Couldn't have done any worse if I tried. Oh, we're at 30k. Hello. This capitalism simulator isn't actually so bad
I'm not fuzzy
Is
I think the oak seed is the last one. So if we want to make more money, I think we need 100k on our pocket
Oh wait, wasn't I trying to go something? Oh, yeah these I'll grow these first
Uh
I already checked the thing out
I did you go on that
Honestly delivering certain is great for shoo men our little girl failure
I wondered why everyone was saying that she's a girl failure. I don't really know what the terminology means
like
Uh on the cookie clip someone was like, oh my god, they're all girl failures
But in an affectionate way and I'm like, I actually don't know what that means
Oops, I don't know what I mean
I
Heart for strong a little she beats the girl failure. She recalls herself one. She was on twer's 100% of girl failure
What does that mean? What is it translated?
special terminology I should know
Or is it just like a kind of one of those things where it's like, oh, you're doing
Hey, thank you again anonymous for that tip to tell me about that. Yes. It was a namey
I thought maybe because I spoke to her yesterday like just in a voice call. We're just chatting away. Um
and
I was just helping her out with a few things when it comes to planning
And I thought when you said that she maybe thought I was going to show up on stream with her just to help her through it or whatever
I was like, uh, no
Oh my god, that's the cocoon that that looks awful
POV me after the reflins have had a go on me
Just a gape
Girl failures or girl failure is a slang term referring to the opposite of a girl boss
Simply defined as an absolute loser of a female character via a viral tweet sent in january 2023
A girl or a woman who is
adherently pathetic or an
You don't like anime. No, I do like anime, but the problem is I
Need to watch things that don't have a billion spin-off episodes and all that stuff. Wait, where's your fur?
Are you feeling grown?
Oh, maybe it can like
It spur grows and you can like harvest it
I think that's what it is. You can put them through a processing plant and then they'll come naked
There we go, we're at 37,000 smack a rune
Please keep that alive. I need it for a lot of feed them stuff to grow fur. Okay
Um, I wanted to actually watch anime streams with you guys
and
because
Uh, there's like lots of anime that I've been interested in but I've just never had the time to do it
so if we ever do like
Oh, you'll never guess what's gonna happen to you
Time to turn brown
Go go go
And then that's all the colors of the flutter scotch unlocked
Um, but yeah, whenever we have like an endurance stream where we want to watch something in the background
Or maybe we could just straight up watch anime together like an endurance marathon anime kind of thing
I'm so down to that like so down to that
No work for the sprinkler. Oh boy. I have good news for you. I've just planted a new seed
She helped with the brown noise
Yeah, I know you're watching would be so fun. Yes, you can watch me turn into a weeb in real life
I flash before your eyes and I'm like
Oh, yeah, we want me exactly think twice before you consume anime
I'm teasing
No, not the thing. Ah, you can't say that
um
Right, I'm waiting for these plants to grow stems
Eh the flower heads and then I'm gonna bring
a bumblebee
More than just a fantasy
Do puru puru
Are you going back inside?
Well
I mean, I kind of don't want you to be inside right now. Yeah, I was gonna say I'd rather you guys are out here
Because I'm about to unlock these flowers for you
Wait starting doing the cute and funny boys. I mean if I ever get a lollipop model, I'll just fuck around with that boys
I
Need to try a bit better strony clothes
strony cuttles stays
That's a bitch again voice to match her hobbit. Hey, you're done modes. I want this man. No, I'm just gonna
The day that happens is ogre pin pals. I get it now. Oh my god. I get it
No, that's so funny
Dear god, I get it
We're gonna send you off. Thank you for your contribution to the farm
Uh, can you grow already?
Turn into leaves right now
Give me a flower right now
I love when you trample around and then you just fall asleep like wherever you find yourself
You're like, I'm exhausted after streams, please
Mods remove that reefing not the jar
Mods lullify that reefing make them a lollipop right now
Mods unwiggle his balls. What?
Our balls wiggled
What did he mean by that
Unwiggle unwiggle what does that mean?
Okay, I need the swans to come and eat the flowers
Unwiggle his balls. What the fuck is this like
Boys, let's confuse the girls terminology and I've just been pranked because I'd believe it
I'd a whole heartedly believe it right swans you
Right, we're gonna have this freaking pixie for this mallow wolf. We're so close
Okay, then we're gonna be the fuck out of this one. Hi one more
And then no not no jameleon
Uh, did I not just tell two of this ones to show up over here? Are you squiddin me right now? Reefing Brian
If you got a lollipop model you should call her strani cutel ls
And if you made a milf model, she would be strani milkers. Maybe
Anyway, I may be off for a bit. So have a good rest of the stream. Oh, thank you so much tiny spiny. I mean
Uh, honestly, that's not bad strani cutels
I'm cute and funny. Oh, no, there's another thing they need. What is it?
Oh, it's just water that's fine I can handle that right let's go though
Water out
Oh, no, I don't want to do it over here because this is actually my golden patch
Uh, oh, that's another golden patch as well, right. I'll just do this corner again
50 shades of cuttlefish every flavor on tack real
Uh, were you the one who hasn't oh, no, you're the one who has had three. Where's the other one you?
Do as a favor love eat that then you can go bed
I'm trying to get you on a night out in the town
Oh
Do you think testies were unable to move about?
I mean
I thought they could only go one way or else it's
torsion
And you have to like go to a and e like immediately if that occurs
Because it's life threatening
Bro this garden's come more of a swamp. I know look
Like as if this isn't enough water
Why do you need so much water just to like do a little dance with each other?
You don't attack
As long as you don't twist the tubes
The delivery tubes from the testies to the spout
I'm gonna be honest. I know about female reproductive but not really guys that well
Can you please link to the unwiggle your balls video?
I'll make the role play for you girlfriend unwiggles your balls in the middle of the night ASMR and this is what I'm like
Uh, what do I need to get rid of exactly? I don't know
But as if he's back for more give it up buddy
Am I going crazy and saying my garden honestly isn't that full?
Okay, is this enough for the dang swans? I won't know until they come out if they're not out right now
It looks like they eat it. That's all that matters
I'm gonna sell all of these peshy things
I'm starting to think the pinatas are making stuff awkward. You know what? I'm gonna sell this bird bath. We don't need it
And before the game's like thank you so much for selling that bird bath. You did amazing
There you go. Are you feeling?
Oh
Reefling
You cannot just eat candy you find on the floor. Is he coming?
Oh my god
Don't give me a heart attack. I would be distraught if you got freaking perished
Reefling you cannot just eat food you find on the floor darlin. It's so dangerous
Oh my god, thank god patches is so quickly don't that scares me so much
Oh my god, please feel better hurry up patches. Jeez save my poor boy
Oh
Please tell me please tell me that resets the timer
And patches is out right now. Please tell me resets the timer
Please
There's no way you just did that. I literally just fixed you and you instantly eat the candy again
Oh my gosh refling
Where is
Where's gammy? I'm gonna have gammy on standby. I'm not having the
Reefling I couldn't even get the candy that was under you you flattened it. So I couldn't interact with it
You literally you feel better and you instantly go. Oh piece of candy
refling
No lesson learned honestly
I'm not gonna lie. Mommy. I think the truth one's kind of a re okay. We're safe
Okay
There you go
Reefling don't do that. I wasn't paying attention. So come to deal with all this stuff
right
You two wake up and come hump
Wake up. I'm sick of this marsh mouth
This guy keeps coming into the garden because he's wanting you to be ready to go. Do you understand what I mean?
Okay
Please tell me I have enough water for you
I still don't have enough water. What do you mean?
What do you mean?
Oh
When you nod your head yes, but you really mean no
Please stop
How is this not enough water seriously?
I'm not laughing anymore finally go together right now
Please and then I should be able to unlock the strange house
Or whatever it was it's something strange in willy the builders, please you too kiss
Do not go back inside
Oh
Oh, he's looking down a little peacock thing
You're a risk that they're reciprocating
architecture real
She yelling at us for eating honestly
Hey, I'm kind of e
I'm cute
Right controversial
We could just blunt force this
Oh
It's very controversial and not recommended. Here we go. See we did it
What does the inside of their house look like?
I exactly what I thought. Yeah, I know what you're putting
Mm-hmm
Ireland stream you need to punch stomach so I can squeeze your tours like stop eat and replay
What you want to be as
Be like hagas or nah
I just don't want you hurting yourself. You I'm poison
That's like saying you're lactose intolerant and then you're huffing like as much cheese as possible
Like come on replay and be kind to yourself
I'll be pooping
No
Oh my gosh, they're so oh black swan
Is that a black swan like a ballerina reference type thing because they play that play
Oh, sorry
You
Actually, I can't believe it. I can't believe I've lost my endurance state. I think I'm gonna have to hand it to a zero on ironically
I'm starting to feed. I'm starting to crash
Okay, so now that they've meted
Does the game acknowledge the place I need to buy
Morning
Mystery home there we go
It's humongous of course is
Uh, and I can't just place it here because I need to freaking fill in all this
Oh, I know it's getting full. You didn't need to tell me wait. Did I not send you to this?
What was the instructions?
Okay, just anyone. Okay, that's fine
We'll send that now so everyone can get their sweet
Your endurance will come back. You just need to get your edge back. Yeah
I'm sure I'll feel better after the audio. I'm sure
I just need to do the audio first
I'm going to what I'll do is after the stream I'll take a nap because I got a lot of stuff done yesterday
Like that's why when I popped up on stream, I was like, did you see did you see
Emi Azura's stories, audios all got uploaded like their patrons got updated. Ha ha ha. Did you see because that was me?
I didn't edit them, but I did like the little cringy descriptions of them. I'm so bad at doing them
I'm so bad at doing tags as well, but I'm learning. Okay. I'm learning right. Let's start filling out this garden
I've had enough of water
Fricking animals coming in dictating how much percentage of the garden has to be water
Like you're gonna need to give it a break this entire garden is war
It's not a good garden for
land
anything you
How is my
Yes, I mean I've kind of said so many things had to be put on hold while my dad was here and it's caused such like
There was a few issues in the background anyway with like timing and stuff
um
But it's all dealt with
So things are gonna even up and I can go back to doing my ASMRs
And I can go back to doing a few things in the background for the girls like if they want to do like
Thank you
Um, if they want to like do ASMR stuff and that like I've gotten ASMR youtube roughly to edit from mercies
Probably the next thing I have to do
I can just sell these flutter scotches because I have all flutter scotches now. Thank you. Um
Right now if I'm not mistaken
I just need two sweeties two of the love sweeties
Sorry, I'm burping wait every time I burp I can taste the way. I'm not sure I like that
Um, I'm gonna put down two sweeties. I'm gonna have the pig have one and one of the swans have the other
And then once willies built that hoose
Uh, I'm gonna tell them
That he
What you want bananas to I'm not buying any more bananas whatever's in the trees what you can have
you
While you're waiting for your child to hatch. Um
Wait, that didn't work
No, you guys have made it before
Did I know mate pics I did
I don't know why the games acting like I didn't make them
Huh, okay, that is what we're supposed to hunt the pig it didn't work for I don't know why
So I need the idea to catch the female audience is to get us out the seven eighth actually
I have terrible news for the female audience. I'm sorry
Maybe another streamer. I don't think that streamers me but not in a mean way not in a nasty way just doesn't I like
I don't
I don't got guys they pay my bills and I want to be nice in the content focus
Because the fast art randomly go in like female for female content
My entire established fan base is gonna be like, ah
well
That's not for me. I'm no longer supporting
So I don't really get like the demand of like hey change up everything you do right now for me
Female reeflings and shamblings the three female reeflings are absolutely perishing
Actually, I think if there is any reeflings that are female
They genuinely wholeheartedly get it and don't like say anything. They're like, yeah get it
Like there's nothing else to like yeah, yeah, I get it
right
I may have forgotten to make the pigs hump
I didn't because I remember I got them to do all their thing
I'm wondering
Right one we're selling this fucking house before yous are all going in it
Okay, so then who
You right, okay
Oh
Where is she there she is right land
No, is this
That that's right cheat in front of your wife and child I worked
When pigs fly
It's why gatekeeping can be unfulfilled
Hey when something turns up somewhere and demands change to sit them
And then they get the change and everyone's literally like I have to be like
Oh, sorry the piggies are really wobbly like he's twerking his way in between these
If someone does something and they tell you to change it why not look for something else
Yeah, I'm on that fence have been like I can't be I can't be everyone's favorite streamer
It's not possible and I can't make content that everyone's gonna enjoy that's not possible
So I'm not gonna like hold myself up to that
What's it say so it's like what a palace
I mean just looks like oh that looks so cozy with the heavy feelings. I just want that for ourselves
Imagine being at a fireplace every night and it's a bit cold and we put the fire on and
Maybe we're reading books like our own books together like we're sharing the space together that kind of thing
All right, I'm gonna sell you
I'm gonna sell you when you pop out you're freaking
Rest well those who sleep. Thank you for hanging swan and
It's like going to mcdonald's and demand the cashier for
plate the pasta
If you try it, please everybody you please nobody exactly
Okay, so
Pop you away make we're at what 45,000 next time it rains
I think I'll do the orchid approach. I think we need a hundred key on hand
In order to order and sorry. Holy crap. That is uh one little voice line and a half right now
I think
Um
What do I think I don't think about much often I've not got much of a brain but that's okay. Um
Oh my god, what am I trying to say? I can't even get word out right now
You don't have you don't need everyone to enjoy every
To enjoy you for you to be the president
Oh
You can still rule them all
I am your leader
Yes, I am your leader
I'm not
Please do not actually do anything. I see I probably give the worst advice on all the land
Hydration checks little reeflings, okay
I
Vote for strong eight. Oh, I'd be assassinated long before I could put any change in place
They would absolutely the I would straight up be gone
They would not have me big oil would not have me because like my first line of duty would be like band single use plastic
It's now on the manufacturers to pay an
Extortionate fee if they continue
Uh producing what like single use plastic non recyclable plastic
um
I would be gone down and out. I'd be a goner
Like before I could even start changing anything. Oh, I'd be gone
They wouldn't have it
It would be
It would be oh strongy couldn't handle the pressure being president
So she popped her clogs and I'd be sitting there like in my grave like you all believe that
Disposable hate
Literally do not put the problem on the consumer, which is what they've been doing for ages now
Oh my god, the egg hasn't even hatched and he is going for the hunt. I'm watching you you poisoned my reefling twice
I'm not taking my eyes off of you until you cough up and I break all this week
I'm not taking my eyes off of you
Yeah, mm-hmm. Mm-hmm
Right don't inspect your handy work. Right. That's what you get
I almost hit you. You almost made me hit you. I'm that's right. I'm victim blaming for feet. I'm all no
You don't want that. It's not good for your tummy, darling
Right parry bow if I remember correctly
If I pimp this parry bow out with clothes, we're actually gonna get another achievement. We just have a pinata worth 10 000 points
So basically we just need to give it really expensive quotes. I think that hat was 900 back there
It doesn't matter what you put on it as long as it's expensive doesn't have to look good
Okay, that pirate hat looks like the most expensive one
Okay
Yep, perfect. Love it eyes. Let's put most expensive legs on six hundred
Eyes six hundred right a wee eye patch. Why not?
Mm-hmm. Why is the pirate stuff will hydrate later? Why not? No
Uh most expensive six hundred that's cool. We are pimping the crap out of the bird. He's gonna be so many many
comedic nose. Why not? Sure
Yeah, that
Yeah, that looks great. It looks awful. I know it looks awful. We just need time to be expensive. Okay
And we're Gucci maxing right now. I don't understand like clothing brands like I'm one of those people that like I don't get it
I'm sorry. I'm too dumb to understand
So we're just Gucci maxing right now. Okay. Oh, he saw him
I put a rose on your mouse
I
Remember
Are you in the garden? Oh, there we go. I'm putting you out of value
What is his value after all that?
Total value eight thousand accessories
Four thousand. Okay, there we go. Where are you? I put a rose at your mouth because you were so irresistible
I
Just remembered seeing that I so remember I put a rose on your mouth
Hold on
Because you're so romantic
Oh, you're complete. I saw something was missing. No, come here. I want to see you
Oh, don't are you so embarrassed that you want to scurry home? Oh, baby
You're embarrassed, but oh don't be embarrassed to show me a fiction. It's so cute
Oh
There's my chance. Okay. I'll let you sleep. Okay
Goodbye little you go. Oh, you're awake again. Oh, you're just you're just checking yourself out
Check you out though. You got a color
You got a little accolade because you much bit your boy and then you've got your little rose because you're so romantic
Oh, oh my god, you're going up on your hand legs
Oh my god, I love it. I love you
Wait, why is the pig crying? What's wrong? I'm just gonna sell you if you're greeting your eyes. I said what I said
I don't know why it this one was upset. I think maybe because the
was getting trampled
Spread this is why I don't like oh, what would you like anything you want?
for
buzzing Joe's
Nobody hunts in the morning, but I have to be here to take orders for buzzing Joe's
At four grand each
Oh, she better be on them pronto
I've got one. Oh
Oh going to cheap. Oh, there is when pigs fly
Oh, he's a bit wonky
That's okay as long as you're enjoying life
Well, you do we bet wonky
Are you okay?
Is it okay sorry, I'm gonna have to sell your house. It's not your fault. It's because I need you to be
um
I see I think he's an abomination. I think he's a bit mashed together
Are you okay?
Oh as we like doesn't work that well. Well as long as you're okay. Are you happy though?
Will I give you a wee sweetie?
It's no surprise to that gardener of your staff
Here let's put some joy sweets then everyone can have a wee bit of joy
Me when I upload a new audio to patreon. Haha. Sorry. That was a good one
Oh, I'd put one in the water. Here you go. Here you go. Thank you. Uh, where did he go? Hey, buddy. Do you want one of these?
Have a wee nibble
You like it
Oh, you like it. Oh, you're growing up. Okay, right
Well, we'll see what a fill size one of you looks like then
Can I hatch your cocoon? No, it's too early
Did that mallow wolf go home already?
Dracked. We're too late, but that's okay
Um
Enter suffering. Oh, is he suffering? I don't know. He seemed happy. I gave him a little treat
He's quite happy, quite chuffed himself
um
Right now that we've done that we can get a mallow wolf. So then we're just going straight back to petunia a farm
Hey pal anything exciting happening out there? No. Yeah
Okay
So these bams are all gonna fly everywhere when I buy them just to warn you now
It's gonna be so hard to try and sell them
Because they instantly fly away. Okay. We have the master moments. Don't fly one two three four
Five
One two three four five. Oh, we did it. Okay. Now. There's only two in the garden that we need to deal with
Okay, I don't know where the other one went by the way
Okay
But we're doing it. We're doing it right pigeon now
Pigeon home. Oh, it's a pudgeon as in fudge. Oh, that's a good one
Okay
Oh, what do you mean? My garden is full. I'm so there's three trees one decoration. I mean
Bruh, what do you mean? There's like four flowers
Have the audacity to have some flowers
I don't know if the oak tree is like taking up insane room or something
I don't know. I'm gonna reduce the flowers again further. So this game can't be like it's the flowers. It's the flowers
I'm having enough
We have like native flowers honestly
If it's because them or pop. Oh, you just stood on that. Um, if it's because they're like popping the flowers, that's different, but
This is the only thing about this game. I must complain about I must I must I must I can't hold it in anymore
Is that the game's so dramatic like your garden's full your garden's filled like it's not
There's nothing in it other than a few objects. That's why I think houses must like anything
It's trunnies garden is full that's a sense. So
This is after hearing an audio
Lauer I'm just blaming the flowers. What do you think right hunter caught the piñata, right? We're just gonna go all out on buzzing
buzzing
Buzz engine what food item is plus energy?
I don't know but uh, they're all perishing whatever they are. Is it down? Yes
Four thousand a pop
Maybe once we get the eagle will do the plant technique and get 100k and then we can get that achievement as well for 100k coins
You know wouldn't water actually kill the piñata? I think so in a technicality, but
How much are you worth it says you're only worth 8k
Hmm
What is bouncing
That is right. Okay. That eagle's going for the buzzing. Look, I'm trying to play coy. No, I'm not going for you
Oh, well, you're right at his house now. He's gonna. I think he's gonna spot you something tells me he's gonna spot you
Oh, there's a lion
Hi lion you want to come into my garden? What's that you do?
Right, what do you want to meet you want a camera?
Are they paparazzi? I think they're paparazzi
Yeah, that's a funky looking bird
Your garden is filled you do your challenge
Right, we need a camera around his neck
No, yes, okay, it's around his neck. Yeah
Okay, what else do you want to eat? Is it
Two ears of corn. Okay, we're just gonna grow them. I refuse to give in to cost a lot
More like good evening. I have enough time to go see
I don't know the other thing he needs those but we're getting there we're getting there
And then that'll be the pigeon's done and then we'll go for the next achievement, which is do
Is that shite? Oh my god, it's bird shite coming out of the
their house
We'll do that hundred coins achievement next
Oh, they're pooping on the bad guys statue. Okay, that's actually pretty good a government drone
Is that how far back those jokes started?
That the birds are spying on us
Hmm
Well, he's eaten one
So i'm actually going to open up his encyclopedia to make sure I have what he needs to show up again
Level 33 gardener bird have five different species in the garden, which I definitely do
The
Resident is eat four and have 15 different species in the garden. Okay, because we have the flutter scotch
We reach that with ease
Um because flutter scotch count is four a seven
I think there's seven colors so that easily counts. I just need more buzzing just
Are we sure that statue isn't a fertility totem?
Oh
It's bird poo poo
The pigs hiding in the tree. Well if that werewolf comes into the garden floor, it's getting tapped down to the ground
Right you want corn that's fine. I need to find your buddy though. I can't find him
Is he sleeping here? No, he's not actually
I build a house for you guys and you don't even use it
That's definitely him
Oh wait, are they not eating the candy until I tell them to they're not hey buddy snappy you can eat that
Everyone can eat the wee thing
You guys can eat the wee things, okay
I bought them as a gift for them. I don't think they'd be too scared
I'll get you in trouble. I'll make a little like an iphone
I won't eat in trouble. You can't be in trouble for me actually so difficult
Keep going
Uh, did I plant something that needs watering or was that like from easy to go?
I'm thankful
Right you go eat some corn
Oh, he's so cute
They're all so adorable refling. Did you get a candy refling you silly gopher that's for you
Oh, I found the other pigeon
I'm gonna put some coals on
Oh
Margin people's dinning in the marshmallow boy. What's the marshmallow banquet? That'd be that right?
Oh, no, I'm sorry. It wasn't that accessory. Yeah, that's why I'm getting distracted
Actually, I'm getting a bit tired. I'm like, oh my god one coin
But no one else is coming on and I'm like, oh no, I don't win. I don't want anyone to feel bad
Hey, buddy, can you come eat this corn?
Your your pudgeon buddy's one in there to
Eat the tasty poison candy the other reflings took my candy. No
You guys don't steal from each other, you know how to share, right? Or do I need to teach you how to share?
Don't think I won't do it right stop flying. I need to know what your other requirement is
You do not have to do a 720 around the item that I'm asking you to eat. Thank you
Okay, what do you need a snap dragon seed and something else
Wow, okay, it's raining. I am going to do the orchard orchard
method, okay
Let's take advantage of the rain or is the rain gonna take advantage of us we'll find out
We just I need to tell them to eat those candies though because they're taking up space in the garden
I mean that might be enough for now. I know honestly
I'm waiting for her to go. Whoa your garden is way too big
That one
Okay, this is enough profit farming
More than enough right you plant
you plant
Now to get the fertilizer out. We're gonna sell this entire batch and it may get us to 10k. I'm not
Maybe not
But because it's raining we don't have to worry about any
aim
like water in them
But we do have to now do this method of fertilizing every dang thing
Awesome
Mommy likes it wet. No, I have the rain in order to do this trick or else you're gonna run out of time like trying to water all the plants
and
fertilize them all for the max income when you sell them
The sprinkler is gonna come in anyway
First you get us in trouble for eating something and now you will get
And now you give get us into trouble for not eating this is
what
I had a stroke trying to say your sentence. I think your sentence is fine and the problem is me
I'm gonna be honest. I have a feeling the problem's me
So please don't worry
I think that was all me
Now I need that eagle to come back. Oh, are we finally gonna get a freaking mark? Uh, um the wolf
I think we're finally gonna get the wolf
No, no, no
Cal Cal Kerr, thank you so much for becoming a member. What did you just do?
Go go and annoy the freaking
pig thing
and beat it up
Hunter caught pinata. Not now. Not now. Everything's happening at the same time
This is the worst part
I think we're finally gonna get the wolf. Thank you again Cal Kerr for becoming a member
We need another buzzinger
And then I'm gonna go back to iver to fertilize everything. We're running out of time
I'm trying so hard
I'll need them to eat the freaking candy that's on the ground
I thought they were just gonna eat it because they normally do when a pinata comes back from a party
So I was like, oh, they're gonna do it right surely surely
Oh dear
Oh dear my running out of time already
Well, I thought we could get a hundred coins from this batch, but there's no way we're getting it. I refuse to believe
Where does it it's not gonna stop us though. We have got a ton of achievements
I wish I knew how to open up the dashboard to like show how many achievements we've got
But if we come back to viva pinata to like try and a hundred percent it
Um, I'll like do the thing that we're gonna do with skyrim when we go back
Is put all the achievements that we need to get on screen
Like you know how I did it with the last elton ring stream where we got the coconuts
Basically that and then we'll do it all together. So there's no parts where you miss out on it
Um
I yeah, I definitely think that's the best method for doing
Is the pixie gone yet
I don't want to see the
wolf thing
Oh, no, there's the pixie there. So the wolf is already at the garden. He's so temperamental honestly
Already having a go
Spits up seeds and then doesn't even go for the pixie
Have you beaten any pinatas yet? No
I think a walloped one at the wolf by
But like on purpose. No
Okay, we're getting there
We're almost done and then we can maximize our money
It's because you don't have room
Oh
I need a mod this game like right now
Um, I guess because so this came on xbox 360 and the xbox wasn't that powerful the 360
So I guess they obviously had to limit everything that was going on
Um
I'm trying my hardest everything's hating on me. Okay. There's two buzzings in the garden
We need one more and then that eagle will have done it the eagle has landed. I repeat the eagle has landed
Uh, is that everything? Oh, no, no, no
Don't turn into a flower yet. I'm not ready
I'm not ready. I'm not ready. I'm not ready. I'm not ready
I'm not ready
No, there is one more. How could I be so foolish?
It's an experience being up your favorite
Cartoon as a child on ya
I can't be mean to the pinatas will come to find refuge. I say that as if I'm not buying
Um, buzzings to be eaten by an eagle
Okay, I think that's everything
One more
And then we will maximize our funds and see what's up
I do need the pinatas to eat these freaking things though. No one's everyone's scared to eat you eat my darlin
I see the eagle
Can I'm going to tell her to go get another buzzings just in case like it reset or whatever
Honestly, I'm glad I never got people. I wouldn't be able to sacrifice any of the work
How is it like going straight for it?
Okay, we still have a
We're waiting for no, I don't want to pass fly. Okay one's going down. So I should technically be two
Like I'm making room. See I've I've disappeared this ear of corn. Oh, wait. No one of them needed to eat an
I need to sell the plants before I can grow anything else
A pinata is about to be eaten. Good
What we looking at two more. I only have one more in the garden
I need the the thing to
Save us
I like the harp music there garden value master
Oh, the plants are popping. Okay. That's why we got that achievement. All the plants just pop
Wait, why are you not? Wait, what? Only one flower popped on that. I don't get it
Oh
Filled with fun
30 achievements
That old achievement noise give me a hit dopamine going straight for the way
We did dairy achievements in one go. Oh, no, I got stinky
Yes, you can most certainly have a singular
Can you have a refling party time? It's time for your fourth socialization
Where are you? Oh, are you asleep? Okay. I'll send snappy out. They like snappy
Oh
Right, let's sell these flowers and pretend that we're going to make all the money in the world
Oh refling you were hiding. Did you not want to go to the party?
Or did you want to stay behind so you can eat all the sweets that drop?
Okay, money money money
Must be funny
In a rich refling world
Whoa
We're almost at like 50k
For that batch
I don't know why that one is being weird about it
You're full
I must have just I mean you can't ask them all to be perfect
Okay, there's no sweets that everyone can eat. I no need to wait
I think I'm out of
Bugs and juice
For the eagle to eat. Oh, no, there's one more if it wants to hunt him. That'll be three
And then I just need
One more which Grinchum is away getting
Oh, he's hunting
The eagle is hunting
Hydration check my voice is starting to feel a bit sore. What do you mean three three six hours of continuous
Talking is bad for your throat. How dear you?
And I recorded an ASMR before this room
If Grinchum can hurry up we may be able to grab this eagle before he goes
But it would have to happen now like right at the second
As long as you're still trucking along
Then that's a good
Please don't fly out of the garden mr. Eagle. Please
Please please. I'm begging AI. Please. I'm begging you AI. Please. Please
Please don't fly out of the garden. Please. We could have an eagle
Please
Please, please. Please. Please. Please. I'm on my
No way people need water after talking. I know it's shocking behavior
But we have made
63,000 coins. So if we do another batch we do we get the 100k coins achievement
I must I must pray did the eagle go home. I think it did
Oh, that's the one lucky timing, but it's okay. It's okay. It's okay
Um, are we warmling you're not happy buddy. Oh
Please eat the pixie wherever it is. It's a week. So you can eat it. That's how it works, right? Please
Just all lock on to the pixie. Don't throw up any more sweets. My refling is gonna hurt himself on it
He's doing it
Oh, did you hear the bees there?
Mmm
God he keeps messing up the hunt
Reflings no bad candy. I know it looks sweet, but it's not it makes your tummy hurt
He's making everyone miserable. Oh, is that why everyone's so unhappy in the garden
You're making everyone miserable. Eat the pig now. Where is where did it go?
Okay, that's a pigeon up in that tree
Refling
Oh, if you're tired darling, you can just go to your house. You don't have to sleep out like the other pinatas
Oh, he's gonna do it
Okay, you go to sleep darling. Okay, there you go. You get a nice comfy sleep in there. Oh, it's happening. We have a mallow wolf
Oh
I've completely forgotten what a mallow wolf looks like when being on her
She doesn't want us camping and sleeping. Let's you leave. Just come back in again. I guess you're like sleeping under the star. I'm gonna see
Okay
Oh
Right, is this the last sever pinata? It might be
I'm gonna sell the mallow. Give them high. Bless you. Thank you replay
Okay
I that might be the last sever pinata. I needed to get I don't recall another one
You've made space so you can continue to grow. I get it
Right. I'm looking at the journal because it keeps saying that I'm running out of space
What is it? It's not encyclopedia. Is it garden area?
No, it's not
This singular oak tree takes up eight slots
The tower of sour the dragonfly takes two
Bluebells chili
buttercup
Yeah, the gem tree and the oak. Oh, no, the oak tree is nine. I didn't see the one on below it
The oak tree takes up nine twos candy accessories take up space in my garden
I think that parry bow is getting sold. I'm not being funny
If his accessories are taking up space as well, that's outrageous
Oh
You getting some snacks we fling. Yeah, the yummy eat your tummy getting full of those the sweetie
Okay, that's good
We want to stay with mommy as much as possible. Mommy's one enough. Unfortunately
I'm a retired baby. Oh
What do you look like when you change up into a summer mallow?
Oh
Got to get a big tummy for mommy real
I've trained you well
Wow, what level are we?
Whoa, wait your eyes are red. What's wrong?
Are you fighting what's wrong? Or is that just how you look in general? Maybe that's just how you are
Uh
You look so unique
What unique boy you are I've never seen that before I don't really recall doing that
I really didn't do that much in childhood because I actually didn't know how to get a picture
Um, he's got them stoner eyes. Okay. I'm just going to order another buzzing just to
Help this ego in case it glitches out and it's like I haven't eaten four of them and I'll be like, well you have actually
You're just telling fibbers
If you're feeling tired getting nothing, okay, sit sit in my suite. I'll try and get the ego. How about make your deal? Once I get this dang ego
Then
We'll do it. I'm actually going to check how you get that lion because the lion
Like was unlocked and then just never came over to us
So those are level three
Level three
Level four
Quite a few fours. I need to get that squirrel actually. I need it for the next level of the serpent
Um, a donut hasn't even come into the garden. What do you want?
That's the noises it makes
When she keeps swarping
um
Right
Now we could go crazy and try and get all this book filled in
I am slightly tempted to do I wouldn't do it right now, but
I am tempted right rory. Oh, what's your story?
I have zero donuts in the garden
That'll be why your ass hasn't shown up in my garden. I'll go for you later because I actually don't have any donut
Oh, that noise does not spark joy
Okay, I
Think I'm going to sell parry ball because for some reason the game is registering his accessories is making taking up room
And it's getting a bit outrageous
Getting a bit outrageous. I have to admit. Um
I'm all riefling. I can't handle you. Yeah
Wait a minute. I thought the line appeared and left he went outside, but he never came inside
It's like for them to come inside the garden. They need like a set amount of things
Um
I don't know if that eagle's gonna spawn back in or not. I don't even know where it comes from. I assume up here maybe
Oh that nest up there is where he would spawn in
Maybe we should go for a donut then I guess then
What is the appearance requirements for them?
I don't think they're a high level pinata either. So hopefully it's not too awkward to try and get one
I just don't seem to ever get them
naturally
I knew get hasn't even showed up. I don't know what I'm doing so wrong with that
It's never visited me
Have watercress growing in the garden. I guess I only did like a few watercress and then give up
um
They even have a donut on look I do okay my apologies I do
So six percent long grass which I have have 10 blackberries in the garden and eat them
Okay
We're gonna plant a ton of blackberry bushes. How about that?
And then it'll show up and then we can work on getting the level 10
um
The level 10 what the level 10? Uh, pinata
Freezing because not thought behind her eye. Oh wait, I've not even bought the seed. I'm literally putting fertilizer in the hole
Oh
Hello
Okay, donut first. Okay, I'm not fuzzy
Okay one
two
three four
Oh the eagle's back. Oh the eagle might land
Okay, I've planted those
I'm now going to fertilize them
We're putting fertilizer in the hole
Okay, there's no other
So they need to get to a stage first before you can put fertilizer on like crop producing things
I need you to come in at this garden right now and eat all of the dying
Eat all of the dying things
Oh, I needed to make corn didn't I?
What was it corn and snap dragon seeds?
Remember
Mummy's brain backfiring. I'm getting tired. I have to admit. I'm actually starting to shut down a bit and I'm like, oh
There he is. He's just lurking in the distance
I don't have a donut for you. Please don't be disappointed in me. I'm sorry
I'm not ready yet
Is that wait did I hear the did it?
Oh, I did okay now I can do it. Okay
Okay
Uh it bloomed so can I do it again after the bloom animation?
No, okay a bit too early a bit too early
Something's making noises. Who are what? Oh the
Is the eagle mine?
Are you mine?
No, see that's what I thought would happen. He cleaned and she's out right now
Hmm, oh she's back. Okay
He's not eating he needs to eat
Better catch a second one
Buzzing number eight. Okay. Come on. I have not had eight of them
This game hates me
I've tried so hard and gone so far
In the end
Didn't even know
I'm trying my fertilizer's ready to go. You guys are too smooth
Okay, it's not ready yet. Is it ready? These ones ready because they're blooming over here
No, I'm just fucking drowning them in fertilizer hoping for the best
Right hen. It's okay to overwater them a little bit. I'm not being funny
Or you're gonna be bouncing back between these two plants over and over
It's okay to overwater. I promise you
A farm that works on ink instead of petrol
Then they need gas where we're going
No, you're gonna fight with my puzzle gum
I'm sorry. Can I tell you to go ways like nice by doing this? Why is there two of you go home?
Go home. I don't want you fighting with my little puzzle gum
Oh, Riefling's getting in on the drama. What drama are you watching? Huh?
What drama are you? Oh, are you just getting some water? Are you hydrating? Okay, I'll hydrate too. Riefling, you hydrate so I need to hydrate
Hmm
Bullying the ants honestly. Oh, no, don't ever sell my riefling don't I would actually be just short if I accidentally sold you or something
Oh my god, please be the last one
Oh, we're under the ground
Please be the last one
Did he glitch out and didn't eat him
Did he glitch out and didn't eat him?
Oh my god, right i'm putting the water away from the edge of the map
That just glitched out that eagle and he didn't
Get any
He didn't become mine because that freaking glitched out because he was at the edge of the map
Right, no more water at the edge of the map. I'm not having that. That's outrageous. Sorry. That's outrageous. I deserved that
That should have been a dub and it wasn't
That eagle was mine
Oh
How frustrating
I wonder how many didn't register. I hope that was the only one
Please don't be stuck there now. Oh god. You kind of look like it though
You're shaking your head. Please don't shake your head. It's never a good sign if they shake your head
Hmm
Right, I'm going to
Well, one of them just perished so yeah, he saw a ghost
He's in his nothing box at the moment. There's the guy's zone out
I don't know. I don't know
Please don't glitch out and be at the bottom of the map
I really hope he flies away if he glitches out. I'm gonna cry
Malo
What's malo? What with the fruit? What's the food item?
A werewolf a malo
Marsh malo wolf?
Yeah, that sounds correct. Marsh malo wolf
Uh, I'm actually gonna sell the water lily stuff
because
I just don't want to add them to the garden. I'm already struggling enough trying to get I think once I get the eagle
The oak tree doesn't matter
Actually, how much does you sell for two thousand and how much does the gem tree sell for one thousand?
But it takes up less room
Game will never let you leave is he still stuck there. Okay, he's gone home. So that's a good news
So we have another chance again. Who is?
Oh, it's the buzzingers
Oh you oh you want corn. I forgot my apologies
My apologies you want corn. I forgot about the little side mission that we were doing to get the pigeons to do a wee dance
right, I'll plant some corn
And give them
I'll just plant two in case I'm dumb. I'll give them to
Now up dragon seeds, so we need press some press X to drop it without
um
breathe
What are you?
Oh my gosh
It's actually ac
Oh, okay, so we have done them all that's fantastic. Okay
Right, and then what's the last one and we don't know because you haven't eaten that. Okay. Well that would be too easy, wouldn't it?
Maurice. Oh my god, it is Maurice. Oh king julien. Please let me sniff your feet king julien
Come here. No
Hate when they do that
You stop being so sad and eat this seed
If you're planting a little corn could call this
Isn't that mortino? That's morty
Me mort. I don't even know what animal is based after unfortunately
Can't recall seeing that
Have a
Captain black eye statue in the garden
What what is it where you pinatas and wanting to stat you in order to hump like I'm starting to what's going on?
Is it like a monument? Is it like if I was like, oh
Refland's you need to put a monument to big willy wallace. Um
In the garden, no, that's a pirate statue
That
I've been trolled. Is that what it wants? Is that what they want? No, you don't recognize quality good when they're staring you in the face
Is that the statue they want?
You want a random pirate statue?
I don't think that was the right one
It what what
But why
But why is that the deciding factor if you're comfortable
How bizarre
Everyone's snoozing outside
Oh, there's a a wolf there. I need a wolfie
Right, I'm gonna buy 10 berries while I'm at it actually
That statue doesn't get you going. I'm afraid not maybe you know
Maybe I need to get my leg caught in a bear trap and punched in the face in order to
You know ink. I don't sorry. That's a really specific meme reference that I adore
Okay, I've put down 10 berries
So hopefully try and attract a donut as well while we're at it
God that statue makes me want to get it on so badly
I don't know any what's the bounce you could want while I'm music like
I think that's how it goes a little bit a wee bit something like that something like that
Oh
Gem tree or a gem we can sell
My shopkeeper senses tingling which means that's a good deal. I'm happy to go ahead if you are
I'm happy to go ahead if you are
Okay, now we have corn
We
Both the pigeons are in sage right now. I could ask them to come out and maybe
I can get them to eat the missing one to eat the corn
The chances of them flying back inside are incredibly high
And they don't listen to your instructions for like five seconds
Okay, thankfully it didn't fly
When I get that feeling
It's deep inside of me
Yeah, he's flying straight. Okay. It's fine. They can fly back inside at least I know that both of them are able to vomit
Um
And then it's fine. I need this eagle to come break open some of these pinatas. I said what I said
And then once these pigeons have done their thing, I'm going to sell their house and sell them
And thank them for their services towards the leveling up system
Okay, can I just say something really bad? I'm so glad I'm a feature. I'm currently itching my
I'm like straight up touching the nips
I said, oh the freedom
When you're a feature for literally and it's like you guys would have no idea if I said otherwise
Oh, he's back for more. Oh
Wait, he entered the garden and it registered that he's mine
Okay, well, I'm selling these and keeping the money of that's okay
You can't leave right the game's not gonna go like
Are you squiddin me right now? I've never seen that pigeon shit. Mama. I think you broke my brain earlier
Every time you mention your garden or a bush. I vividly remember you smacking it to prove it spoiled
Or don't I actually don't hate it
Oh
Thank you wavelength for remembering
My
My bold penini
Thank you for the tip and all of it. That's funny. Okay, if you are saying you've eaten four, I'm not letting you eat anymore
I don't right get off. I want this pigeon. I'm gonna sell you because I don't want to waste any more money
And then I'm gonna tell her to release the one she's caught his brain. I broke his brain. Okay. I never ordered anymore
When you get into
3d scrawny will be funny. Oh my god. No because it'll give away everything I do
Remember that what's she doing down there and I'll be like
smile
Can't believe she would tease us about the not even sure how to
I get I said, it's not really messed up. I was like, oh, if there's ever a reason I've lost my boobies
I would make the most like main ball going
Oh
Hold on. I'm having a big stretch
Master collector. Oh, that's such a nice name for achievement because I only get called a master bear
Oh, he's like, oh my unique color scheme
Oh his wings are
Oh my no, hold on. No, it's not the time dragonfly. No, I don't have a look at him. Sorry
Where is he? I get you and the first thing you do is take off
Oh
It's time
It's time. Mr. Pigeons. I want to admire you
It looks like he's the one that's been crapping all over the station America. Wait, is that american?
A little bit I guess
We got a donut
It worked
Oh, no, where'd I go?
Huh, I didn't mean to do that
What's going on? How is I even I can't even see what where or what I was supposed to do
I did it. I did it. We're here. We're here. I did it. I did it. Hey
It's a love letter. I didn't see where the entrance point was
I think I was couldn't see the forest for the trees type thing
Um, right. Where's the donut? Where are you?
Oh, oh my god, right. So we need you need uh six just go eat mukbang mukbang
You know do the korean mukbang kansamida annyeong unerun
Uh, uh-huh. Okay. Okay. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. You stop it. I don't want you in my garden
You upset my puzzle gums go home
Very unconventional way to do the minigames, honestly
I have to leave now. Take care. Take care. Please don't whine. Uh, I'm gonna be wrapping up stream shortly
This was a good
entrance way into
um
Into what
And it did an endurance again
Um, I don't know what we're doing. I think tomorrow we're doing the asmr stream in the bathtub
So that's going to be fun and you can hear me hear me slap more bold
Bold parts of my
I don't know why that was so funny saying it like that. Um
Okay
Hello you
You went three sweet tests. You're one hungry boy. Honestly
Intro to endurance madness. I'm gonna miss the asmr stream because of work. Oh, I'm so sorry
I do have more in real life asmr
I'm not showing my before anyone's like as a camera turned on no for the 15k celebration
However, I'm going to do thigh asmr and it'll be like a webcam thing. I'm going to see if I can find
Um
Psy I think the thigh highs I got will work. I need to test them out for that stream later
But that's later in august. I think the second week of august is when I'm doing the 15k thing
Oh, look at the the egg
right egg there
building sold
parents gone
Child's an orphan got it. Oh almost sold the bird by accident. Well, I'm glad I didn't
No
No to get rid of this because it's just taken up room
Oh, no with the cam we would see the net. No, you wouldn't
No, you wouldn't the way I'm going to say out the camera. Is it like that?
My heart can take it so far
Please crush our heads of your thighs. You got it. No, you're going to upset my baby fuzzling stop it
Oh, he doesn't even care anymore. He said you watered me once
Where did that donut go?
Is it already gone?
Did the crocodile scare did the wolf scare it?
Do you do anything? No, hold on. I really need to fart
I farted are you squidding me right now? Oh my god. I'm so sorry. Thank you. No one has asked today. What color is your ponzu?
Uh, thank you, doctor. Do nothing for coming a member. I'm so sorry. I farted the moment you did that
So I couldn't announce it immediately my gratitude for your support
Um, and broly legend. Thank you for the super chart. Uh, my color. I know I'm wearing pants. It's just gray today
Boring gray. I'm sorry
Um
Stroney, should you crush a watermelon with your thighs? I don't know. You want to find out in the stream?
Hmm
Want to find out in the stream? I think snappy might have scared the donut
I don't know why you didn't eat. I literally bought so much snappy. Do I need to sell you?
It would be a shame. I don't know why the donut left the garden or is it coming back in?
It's like on the perimeter
Hmm
Please yes, please send me to the ER. I mean we could find out
Ezekiel's horn called the moment you members literally
Oh, this is a big eagle the eagle must take up some room
I think snappy takes up a lot of room as well
Wearing pants through unheard of well
I can't say that but when my dad got here
I had to get used to wearing clothes again and like showering every day like and like
I don't want to say it like a normal person. But as the average person does
Like and I did I need to go shower
But I'm gonna I'm gonna nap or sleep whatever happens first
It doesn't really matter if I nap or sleep as long as I'm awake before stream
I'm going to try and wake up one hour before stream
So I can record whatever ASMR I need to get done and then I know that the file is sitting there to be edited
You really could have eaten more berries. I'm gonna be honest. You could have been mine
But I don't know what spooked you. I don't know if the wolf might spoke to deer that
My your eyes going red. I don't know if that's a mistake or like a really cool thing that he does
No, no shower and slips at home bed feeling if you do it. I'll make a scene out. She became a normie. It's ogre
I know
Like I got used to wearing clothes like I've got clothes on now because I got used to wearing it
But I think if you just give me some time
Before you know it, you'll hear me slap everything
Like like oh god, that's terrible. Okay, but it's true. So is it really terrible?
Right that donut doesn't know what to do with itself. It wants in
Take them off it's so over shiver time. Let me in
We're doing a bath tomorrow
But I think I'm gonna get clean before I go in the bath. I feel like if I went in the bath stinky, I'll be like
Here's soap ASMR
And it's like actually me just straight up like soap cleaning myself with a
Can you
I'm so sorry to do this little malo. Can you go all the way with reefing over here?
Just because I think you might be scaring
The donut of the doughnuts now going home. Well we're blower chances
I'm going to put some berries on the perimeter in case it wants the berries but it's too scared to come closer
No feminine
pheromone maxing
She's going to start playing the guitar with no guitar
Is that does that mean what I think it means? Who is honking? Oh the eagles honking
I can't hatched. Okay, we can sell the pigeon but it's going up in the tree. I was always does
How much for stone is that? Oh, you do not want that. That's a biohazard and a tub
We brieflings can clean you. Oh, I need to make sure I put that asset on screen
Because I'll be setting obs up here
But I'll be taking my phone away like into the bathroom on a tripod with the 3d o on a tripod
And like twisting myself to look at you if that makes sense
So do pre-prepared. I think it will be less than an hour
Unfortunately Vigo and Gimli are going to have to be locked in
My bedroom because if they knocked something over
Then it would be game over because it's a lot of expensive equipment
Well, the 3d was the most expensive equipment, but I don't want any issues
And I can only read chat on phone. I will only be able to read
Super chats on YouTube. So I'll put a notification just say if you give me stream elements
I will not be able to read it just for this stream in particular because I need to read you off of my phone
Yeah
Do they freak out when you take a bath?
They they always come and check on me when I take a bath because I take such a long bath and they're like
Oh, what are you doing? I'm just like I'm still in the bath
Take talking away and then they'll go away again and do their thing
Yeah, give Gimli freedom. I don't want to risk the equipment. I don't know if that's selfish of me
Can you stop napping next to the berries? I think you're genuinely going to be upset in the doughnut
I asked you to go over here darlin. Please go over there
I'm trying to get a doughnut it comes from this hill somewhere, but I don't know where oh, there's a broken kayak
Do you see the yellow broken kayak upstream?
Hmm
Like an abandoned log cabin
Hmm. Hmm. This is a leaf off this house
A little honeycomb and it goes a little to the left
And then that's the workers house is up there and that's town village with a wee point
Pretty good
Here is the parents keep out
That's cute plant versus zombies
Wait, you what why are you in here you dober? I don't have any buzzing just
So, please don't attack any of my babies no more
I'm gonna see if I can get
Malil will
Right you're starting to take
The lady humps now you have the entire map to sleep and you keep picking there
For that reason alone. I would build you a house, but if you do not use it you are getting sold
Because I think it's genuine. Why is your house so long?
Shopping
No work for sprinkling right i'm so sorry, but I think snappy has to go. I think he's just taken out far too much room
I think maybe the banana tree as well
I don't know
I feel like we have a lot of bushes and stuff that the game's not happy
I'm so sorry, but snappy takes up so much room. I think the game keeps um
Thinking that he's like multiple things
I noticed like the dragonfly was considered two items and i'm like, bro that thing's a literal atom on my screen
Oh
It's the donut coming down from the hill
Please I want the donut before I go
I like the eagles flying around it's like majestic actually
Should I check I'll check I'll see what the game says about how full the garden is
Hmm
What like why does the tower of sour get registered if it's literally nothing to do with me
Like so your house is considered two. Are you even considered one? I can't actually see you
Are you're considered one your house is considered two
The berries on the floor apparently the bananas and acorns on the floor are taking up space
I say it's a bit multiple bananas. I guess that includes in the tree as well because what
What
Ridiculous
No when you're doing it
cousin
if your
Cousin Nico do you want to go bowling?
I want the donut to spawn. I don't want these guys. I want the donut
Come on
Please AI i'm passing out here. I'm trying so hard to stay awake
my voice
My voice is starting to hurt. Why are you giving me dragonflies? I already have dragonflies
Please I don't even meet the requirements of anything
Oh, I'm perishing. I'm not gonna make it. I'm so tired. I'm fighting so hard right now
Please please donut show up
Okay, mr. Wolf you're going into your house right now
I don't know what your house looks like but you're going for it mr. Wolf
That's a wolf then oh
That makes sense. What does the inside look like?
I thought he said uh, I may have been going to sleep after the what are those symbols
They've got like wolf talisman
And then gem i've never looked inside the home of a wolf
Uh
Right go to sleep in your home. Maybe that'll fix your red eyes honestly
Although he might want to fight with
Uh, I don't know if he might give me an achievement
I think the baboon gives me an achievement if I fight death dordos with him
I can't tell if that was an in-game noise or if my cat's at the door
Yimli
I think gimme's at the door
Now I'm going great. I'm losing it. I can now hear my children yell for me
Well, you're my child too, especially after the time
If someone
Oh, was that just wait can I minute I think if I do magic on the
Jen something happened
Or did I make that up?
You little shit go home go home. Oh my god, his eyes almost popped out of his socket
Give me the donor
I can't stop giving me the freaking ants. Oh my god the game thinks I'm one that ants because of the purple thing
This is the rng. I think the wolf will square up with ruffians. Oh already bought the cutlass. Oh, there's the donut there
If the wolf can stay in his house and if the donut can eat six whole fruits that would be great
Come on make go home
Is there anyone in my garden that is hanging around that I don't want?
Go home
Unless you want to die
No quiet, but
Mr. Raisin go home
Oh
He never came into my garden
I
I'm trying so hard. I don't know if I can do another day. Please
Stop this madness. I literally
Was it you or do the reason he didn't come in the garden?
I swear if it was you we're gonna have trouble mr. Eagle
Why is there an there's an L
What do you want black berries? I mean sure. Why not? You can have some blackberries
Maybe I'll have better luck getting a freaking elephant than I do a deer
Right, go have some blackberries. Okay
Go move
Oh, no the eyes are red on this. Okay. I think his eyes are naturally red because it's also like that in the house go
Go eat those things and then I'll figure out what you want to eat afterwards. Okay
Please don't trample my reefing
Okay, thank you reefing be careful there's
Okay, one
No reefing. No, I'm sorry reefing. I'll fix it. Okay
Mommy'll make it better. I'll get you some sweets today has been a good day for customers
Only strong he can trample
Right reefing this will make you feel better. Okay, darlin you grab that mr. Eagle you grab that
And uh mr. Wernling you grab this one
Why did you go a bit straight back to say why does everyone like camping out at the berry bushes? Is it like the perfect height?
Please eat more berries on the floor so I can discover what you would like
There's berries on the floor you don't need to break them off the tree
You know what as long as you're happy that's the main thing
Reefing has his air pods and he can hear you
Like you feel better though now. Where are you? That's not you. Oh, you're going back home. Okay, you went home
Ah, please mr. Game. I wish the flowers could last longer. I don't know how to do it though
I don't know if there's an item for it. Maybe
I feel like I put so much effort to make them look a certain way in the games like
Hey, mr. Elephant you want to eat that?
Wait, why did you get sad? You didn't even get trampled you got startled but not trampled
That's two different things
Okay, okay, is that three is that four? No
Mummy would you rather have a fresh berry off the bush or one that's been on
How dare you use such logic on little reflames
Okay, what would you like now? Okay, you still not had that's three you've had eat a fourth one. My goodness. You're an elephant. Hurry up
Have a fourth one
Please i'm trying my best to obtain you and you're making this so difficult
Is this turning into a 12 hour stream? I really need a rest. I have to admit i'm struggling
Mummy lost her endurance and he had bring it back
I think maybe I think what it was is because I also woke up early to write asmr
Right to record. Okay, and they're going back
And the donut is nowhere inside and it's not going to be in sight probably
Eight hours in sleep
Oh, so i need to be a good girl. Go get some rest, please. I'm actually i'm quite tired
Well, it's one of those things where you like point it out water and stretch not water and sleep
Would you guys forgive me if I did go for a nap? But in exchange for going a nap I will upload
Uh collab asmr and the pregnancy asmr. How about that?
You will pay real american dollars for you to nap. No not not done that
Eight hours of sleep. What's that an energy drink game is like you want to quit the endurance? Yeah, then i'm gonna have
I left five hours ago. We're still going that's the occasion. Absolutely. I love this game
I'm trying very hard to get one pinata to come but it keeps giving me the reason
Which are not the pinata I won and we had an elephant come in the garden at one point as well and i'm like, hey
Do you want euros? No, I don't want euros
Hmm
Please rest we want you to be healthy. I can't believe it the moment my dad leaves i'm all
I throw my health at the window
All that i'm going to see if there's someone I can redirect into
Um, but yeah, I'll make you a deal. I'll go off now. I'm gonna pass out and then
the
asmr
Collaborate side and then possibly the pregnancy is the mark and both the uploaders
Deal
Um
Oh maves on dark souls right now. Okay. Let's put a mave on dark souls. We'll see what she's doing
Just go sleepy sleepy so we can as well. Oh, yeah, I'm gonna kiss you right now. Thank you for letting me
Hold on. I'm gonna like make
quadruple sure I am saved my game
Okay, because we're definitely right save and quit everyone could see it says save and quit. Okay the game saving content
Please won't turn off your console. Don't worry. I won't I'm not playing on a console at all
Okay, I'm going to nap and come back
And I literally slept and woke up and you're still sleeping. Yeah
I love your mom may have a nice nap. I will have a nice nap reefling. Thank you
Do you want to quickly do you want me to quickly check marshmallows?
In case there is anything I need to see
Yeah
Baby, I need to know
Your exciting boy come find
That's okay. No maro's needed. Yeah maro check one reflet. No, no, it's fine. Go to sleep the other one. Yes, please
Howdy, this is my first maro ever yee-haw. I took your maro cherry
I made an account and everything. I really appreciate your shames. You're more than welcome
And they helped me through the back half of my work day. Oh, yeah, work is boring
And but we could space things up a bit
Hearing you yappin enjoy whatever it is happening to be playing or doing keep them up my spirits among other things
Hey, that's your pentas joke. Wait a minute. That's our pentas joke. Okay. Thank you for the I'm glad I can keep you company through the or keys
If you start reading maro's you yet for another 15 minutes, that's true. Okay. I'll read them so quickly then, okay?
Sorry stronti, but you will never be able to unread us as part of our core being
It'd be like asking you to stop linking. Oh liking banal. Honestly, true
Hey momay. Hi refling. I just want to say how glad I am that you and the reflings made it
I've never felt more at home more loved more like
More like I have a family than right now. Oh darling
If you're or your reflings didn't make it. I would never have known my little sister. Oh, that's me and me
From indulge. Thank you so god damn much momay. You're more than welcome
I love all the girls and I love all my brothers the fans
And I want nothing more than for all of us and all the girls and fans to be happy and love. Thank you
You're more than welcome pin towel a simple. Thank you. Doesn't feel like justice so
To just how thankful I am. Thank you so fucking much. You're an awesome woman. I'm so thankful like you wouldn't be you're more than welcome
Okay, you're more than welcome. Thank you pin towel
I see these are the messages I talk about like some people like slip in and like oh, thank you for letting me be
Bleeding heart furs or and all that and like thank you for like
Going out on a chance and all that jazz really legend. Thank you for the tip. Stop stalling mommy. You're gonna
I'm not stalling. I'm reading snow. Stop
um
Okay
Will you be my oh she am I deserving of that title refling? I don't know
It's up to you
The oh she is in the eye of the beholder
Okay
Uh, all you talk all the talk about you feeding us
I can't help but imagine you on my lap my big soft stomach between us and you
Slipping food between my lips as you bounce and I slip my meat between you
I thought that was not going there
I don't I get surprised every time
Because like the build-up is wholesome and then like my brain like all completes what's gonna come up next
I cannot read half of these at large
I
Literally the one directly below I want to stuff my face while I stuff mommy's mouth. Okay, dude
Um
Thank you so so much. I'm going to redirect into me as always when I redirect into another streamer
Please my darling reflings, you know to behave that they might not act like mean
Fuck and give a fuck like me. Sorry. That was like an M&M line that I
Might talk like me walk like me not give one like me
and
I love when she gets tricked into letting her guard down mid-mouth stop because I can't read a head like that
Okay, thank you so so much reflings for this testing and during stream. We're testing it
We're slowly getting back into it
No tomorrow is going to be shorter because I'm doing that asmr and then I'm doing a member if I'm not wrong
I may be wrong
But it might help to kind of balance to do like a longer one and then a shorter one to kind of thinking it
What you saying is to not be us
What no
Yeah, the streamers are at different comfort levels. They might not enjoy like I like when you guys are all
H word
But other streamers might not appreciate it. That's what I'm trying to say. You know what I mean?
Okay members carry okay, just to really f up my voice after ASMR let's go
Okay, we'll do it though
Okay, we'll do a laugh. Okay. I will see goofy givers tomorrow. I'm going to be directing to me
Please don't be afraid to say hi. I'll chill it for a couple of hot seconds
But I will have to go lie down unfortunately or else. I'm not going to be able to work. Okay
Yeah, I see you goofy covers tomorrow
But
I love you. I didn't give you
Did you expect that?
Did you expect it, huh?
Have a good rest of your day evening tonight work not work
Okay, see you tomorrow
Well, bye we think see you tomorrow
Oh wait, that's not kissing that's wait, hold up. Okay. That's kissing. So I don't know
I don't know how I made that noise there. I was like
Okay, I kiss you
Mmm